foreign
[Music]
oh
look at her face you're freaking around
yeah she she's [__] constantly
[__] with me oh look at that [__]
calls Mama yeah yeah
you gotta watch her though man she's
like super sneaky yeah he's funny well
that's why I always like I you know I'm
in the bedroom like trying to get
clothes out of the closet and you have
to keep you have to keep looking behind
you because she'll be like
then you gotta drag her out and she's
like no yeah she [__] cries and [__]
she's got there's this little thing that
sits the foot in the bed you open up and
you can put stuff in it
I think it's supposed to put like bed
sheets and [__] in there I got [__]
gun stuff in there yeah it's like a
bench too yeah I sit there and watch
[__] YouTube and she'll be at the
foot of it on that left corner just
tearing up the carpet where the corner
is I'm gonna stop it she's no
the carpet's [__] up right there I'm
gonna have to get a new carpet here it's
the carpet's kind of [__] up in here
anyway you know when we bought the place
yeah that's true but that's another
thing if I can get the place but um
she sits there and just pulls on the
[__] carpet man into like little
carpet fibers and [__] everywhere
and you can I can vacuum them up and
clean it and you can see that the
carpet's not uneven
like this you know corn roses
she thinks this shit's hilarious well
yeah I mean like I said she's a catch
and if I shut the man cave door she
tries to cross she tries to [__] dig
her weight underneath it no doors are
allowed to be closed you can't can't
close any door in the house she'll freak
out I mean you go in the bathroom like
my bathroom here has two doors you know
you go in the bathroom and close both
doors she's like scratch scratch scratch
either that or like you open it insert
you she sticks her paws yeah yeah like
what are you doing or she's just sitting
there
staring yeah this this all for all this
[__] uh closing door action she's not
about that yeah she's like that's not
allowed that's not allowed Jenny's my
bare shoulders that looks good on you
yeah I forgot I hadn't worn my Bluetooth
shirt in a while yeah we are going to
eat yeah zombie shirt
that's you know you're getting all he's
getting all it looked good from this
angle Twitter
what's Jenny drinking on it's a
screwdriver yeah that's my usual thing I
went down to Publix the other day and
got a big honking gallon of orange juice
because that's my favorite we did have
vodka and cranberry the other day which
was a nice change but you know I like
orange juice the best though
um apple juice is good too
I'm thinking about it yeah everybody's
back in here yay yeah man I'm just I'm
so glad that this week is over this has
been a really
stressful very busy week Lane England's
in there I think he was that body
builder yeah okay yeah remember I told
him that's right yeah that's right
[__] up it's a variation of spelling
yeah yeah okay
yeah
sometimes I thought it was an L it looks
like a lowercase L yes not though yeah
yeah I think I think he ends up I think
I think he's a bodybuilder really I
think so he says I got a stout uh I got
a stout moonshine and peach tea yeah
that actually sounds pretty good
that sounds pretty good
uh let's see vodka and Mountain Dew is
pretty good you know I don't think I've
ever had that yeah I mean
I don't know I'm ambivalent about
Mountain Dew one way or the other yeah
so Ian man I was I was at Starbucks a
couple days ago I got a video of the
dude
this dude was like 260 pounds all right
[__] was massive he was like
[__] he's he's 30 something he looked
like Lou Ferrigno he's sitting and we
were sitting talking about motorcycles
talking about Jim and [__] he invited me
to his gym guess what the name of the
gym was uh-oh what is it Silverbacks
Silverbacks and I was just starting to
laugh he says that's where the Gorillaz
is
I said I'm not big enough because he
says you could be a baby Silverback a
baby you could be a babysitter they want
70 bucks a month to go to [__]
Silverbacks not me drive yeah well it's
just like a social club it's nothing but
[__] power lifters and [__] muscle
heads and [__] and I said can I can I
score the supplements that I need over
there and he goes yeah
so you know it's a distribution center
that's right down downtown Eustis
that's hilarious that is called Silver
called Silverbacks I gotta I gotta I got
a video of him that sounds like a gay
bar for for Bears is what that sounds
like
maybe that's what it is maybe he's
trying to fool you no that'd be called
the manhole or the ramrod
yeah yeah I don't know Silverbacks is
pretty good
[Laughter]
Anthony says vodka and Sprite with just
a slight splash of Red Bull I can't do
Red Bull um it all kind of tastes gross
to me but I do really like uh flavored
vodka and Sprite like I really like
cherry vodka and Sprite I get that a lot
but you know what I mean
oh you got pictures he's got pictures to
prove it I have hair yeah hold on hold
on that's not the right one
silver background that's so funny yeah I
got I had a video of him I had a video
of him
did you take it without his consent a
little bit
a little bit just a little bit he would
have said this I you oh you were
secretly showing him oh okay you see a
[__] look look what you [__] cut
him off I cut it off or the video
there's only two seconds of it he and
his girlfriend were sitting there he's
right there uh I didn't get him oh you
[__] it up I didn't get it you [__]
it up yeah that's the Starbucks yes
that's the one that's the I've never
been to that one it's kind of boring but
it's closer well I mean you know they
have coffee there so that's a plus yeah
uh hey gadget3 what's up been a while
again I'm back though miss you too and
everyone in the chat we miss you too
gadget3 uh you know very very nice to
see you again
um Ian says uh trying to get gear out
here is almost impossible oh yeah oh you
you just got to get a
get you a VPN get that
and um
there's a good sight
called steroidify.com
these names are killing yeah and they
can get you anything now you're gonna
have to go through uh
you're probably gonna have to use crypto
all right
um I can you can pay through Zell but
you there's a complicated process where
you they want you to take a photo of the
Zell transaction and send it to them so
they can see the photo
and instead of the floater you got to go
through like this so I can uh third
party
photograph Handler I don't really
understand what it was it's imager I
think it's one that I use
and they want to see a photograph of
cell that you paid
and uh
but uh you can get anything and the
quality is good it's
and it's uh
they're more like an international
dealer
they have uh they're
um representing Laboratories from all
over the world they got Odin
Laboratories uh some of them are kind of
generic uh some of them are for chat
from China some of them are from um some
of them sounds like European probably
Eastern European Laboratories
and then other uh the other one is uh
um from Thailand Thailand's Got real
good Laboratories
and people think that oh man that's like
some basement [__] no that stuff's over
the counter in those countries so that
you know I mean guys will go to Thailand
not only for like hookers and ladyboys
they'll go there for steroids it's over
the counter you can buy [__] super
high quality stuff there and they'll be
over there for like two or three months
just doing steroids
I'm gonna do my cycle and they got jibs
I should do my cycling [__] uh you
know Bangkok you know
One Night in bed yeah but
um they and they have like a policy that
if it gets picked up in customs they'll
send you another batch well that's nice
of them yeah they don't care they cover
it they're sure
Danny Rowling said just saw Evil Dead
rise and I must say it wasn't worth the
wait but still decent in my opinion
barbarian was better just saying I loved
Barbarian I know like a lot of people
didn't like it but it was very divisive
but I thought it was great yeah you
didn't talk about him he said that
Mexico is like that yeah you go to the
pharmacy
that's all over the counter stuff if
you've got friends in Mexico that
they can hook you up
easily with tests some of the other
stuff if you bringing it across the
border like ah you're not really
supposed to bring this
you know I mean but if it's not a large
amount sometimes they let it go
um if it looks like you're not just
Distributing you know like right with a
[__] Carlo yeah yeah I mean but if
it's like if it's like a boss it's like
a bottle you know and you're local you
live on that border area they'll let it
through
because they're [__] amount of tons of
fentanyl are going through there
I'm gonna think of a [__] about that for
that that border yeah I mean they got
bigger fish yeah I would think right
they don't give a [__]
that border is open
but uh Mexico got good stuff
half of the [__] I did was from Mexican
Laboratories one of them is called Carl
skoga Laboratories which is like a fake
Swedish Laboratory
fancy yeah but they make real good
testosterone real good Winstrol good
Diana ball injectable Dianabol
injectable Winstrol too I don't really
do pills other than anavar I like
everything injectable it's just a lot
easier on you better on your system
it doesn't have to go through the your
kidneys and your livers and [__]
your liver is how many of you how many
of you got
I probably need four or five pounds of
drinking I need some backup flippers
kidneys and livers
just one liver it kind of could spread
out you know sorry I don't know why I
just thought of this but there was um an
episode of uh Mystery Science Theater I
don't know which one it was but um
in the The Skit was you know they you
know if you've seen Mystery Science
Theater they used to do like the
invention exchange at the beginning and
one of the inventions was the vendegut
which was a vending machine that had
organs in it and you had to basically go
in there and put like 25 000 worth of
quarters and they're like to get a new
liver
like once you got it out like what are
you supposed to do with it it was great
that was one of my like favorite
inventions on that [__] show
uh what movie are you reviewing for
Sunday well actually we don't know yet
um
yeah he says 2005 House of Wax we could
maybe do that one like I said we still
need to do breakfast club but um because
Louie sent us that like a long time ago
and we never got around to it but we
could maybe do House of Wax I don't know
I remember liking that when I saw it a
long time ago but I haven't seen it
since then like I said you get to see
Paris Hilton get killed so you know
that's a plus
um let's see
uh direball comes in a cool ass box
Deanna ball yeah well I'm just reading
what he wrote well that particular brand
does that he's talking about I know he's
talking about didn't you get some of
that one time yes because I remember
seeing that box I know what you're
talking about that's from Dragon Pharma
it's a big black box it's black and the
pattern is
and it's black and it's the pattern is
dragon scales on it you open it up and
it's [__] got a red bottle in there
with a [__] dragon face
hmm
Ian says he's got some
d-bal I think d-bell is like fake Deanna
ball or an or an analog of it that's the
pill form
with Dana ball jet injectable or or
pills you produce a lot of what's called
methyl estrogen I think it's called
methyl estrogen it's a type it's one of
the variants of estrogen it's harder to
get it out of your system you blow it up
my [__] driver's license photo is me
on Debo my head's like look like a
[__] pie plate
be with them
that he had to renew someplace this and
he was so mad I was like oh God man I'm
gonna [__] a Devo yeah it's not that bad
a picture I don't [__] hate it but uh
you're supposed to have a bunch of
estrogen blockers
the average dude would probably need
them but I'm just not real estrogen
sensitive I can get away with it I don't
get guy nowhere you're just too manly
for that [__] no I think I might be too
old yeah I think that's what it is you
just don't react to it the same way
um that's kind of true of everything you
like the older you get you're just kind
of like Yeah the more the more it takes
to get any kind of response
grab a steroids man or [__] did not
be that big of a deal other guys are
like dude you should be the size of a
[__] refrigerator and I was like yeah
but I'm mid 50s it's not the same
yeah you know everything is like a lot
more extreme I guess when you're younger
yeah [__] like that one thing about
Deanna ball though man it's [__]
because it's it's a variant uh
it's a variant of of testosterone that's
the instant chubby man you walk around
you like a sex machine
[__]
[Laughter]
and you get fat well you don't get fat
it's fall fluid you look like the
Michelin [__] tire the fish is
sloshing when you're walking around
marshmallow man you're sloshing around
in that [__] man I'm so [__] hot girl
it's kind of like being on the rag well
except for that I feel so hot yeah you
know you don't you don't feel hot when
you're on the right you didn't feel like
crap and like you know when you want to
[__] die is what you usually feel
like I don't recommend Deanna ball I
mean it's fun to mess with
it's just kind of expensive you have to
take a bunch of other stuff with it to
get away with it and it's not that
effective I like NPP better
alone
uh natural on [__] fennel propionate
thank you very much Gadget three that's
very nice thank you very much very nice
of you only got two and a half day
Half-Life you gotta inject a lot of it
or many several injections a week but
it's just it's dry
it's about size you get everything gets
round
you work out on it you heal up pretty
fast and no mental side effects it's
better than shred not like that we were
just talking about a lot better than
Trend situation yeah a few days ago I
don't think you realized at the time
like how no bad it actually was yeah I
thought it was normal that felt normal
yeah I feel good but [__] I became the
great it became the Goblin from the
[__] Spider-Man yeah you were making
everything
but you thought you were like everything
was awesome like that meanwhile
everybody else around you was like oh my
God yeah it's like terrifying of you
because you were like yeah it was
beating people up and [__]
no
right men I didn't know
if I knew you you're all right
you know and women
but dudes that I didn't know
especially if they were like
annoying
and they were annoying me I'd get real I
didn't want to [__] beat him up well
that's me every day yeah
especially when I'm driving I was
driving one time I looked in the car
next to me there was a dude laughing and
I'm like what the [__] you laughing at I
thought it was laughing at me you get
[__] paranoid and [__] see that's not
good that's a good way to get a shot I'm
not you not you yeah that's right you
better not be me you better not be used
laughing at me did you really do that
yeah yeah that was on the way back
dropping uh dropping soap off at the
airport on the way back ah you didn't
tell me that I looked by myself I know
but I'm just saying you didn't tell me I
was just waiting for it you did that
yeah I was at the stoplight dude look
over like that and [__] saw the dude
in the car not laughing he's probably
laughing at some [__] that was laughing
in my direction and I was like [__] you
laughing at you know Daddy's laughing at
me
and wild the dude in the other car was
like bro I was a little insecure thank
you Ian wow we're getting all kind of
flash bulbs thanks for the advice Tom
yeah gadji says uh because I thanked him
for sending a Super Chat welcome forgot
how much I love you pair oh we love you
give it okay the one you want is you
want MPP and test run them side by side
in about equal equal quantities
per milligram all right you want to run
about
about 500 milligrams of [__] test a
week and three injections
and about four to five hundred
milligrams of MPP divided up into three
injections Monday Wednesday Friday
you'll feel great on that you won't have
any metal side effects or anything
you'll get a good one I'm on it now
you'll feel good
um you have seemed a lot more yeah you
feel real good normal and everything's
cheerful everything just kind of gets
round everything's round on you
it's more about size and shape trend
I think if I was already big and weighed
a lot Trenton probably would have get
burned off a bunch of fat and give me a
kind of a more
ludicrous [__] proportions like a
shape you know be like something good
for pre-contest maybe
if you've already weighed 200 something
pounds
they didn't weigh enough for it to make
a big difference it just burned fat off
mostly but I could have done that with
MPP
and it wouldn't have put everybody
throughout through hell you know but but
trend is cheap that's it's a lot of bang
for the buck it's cheap but it's not
worth it no
do mpps yeah you turned into a crazy
person pretty much
and I was afraid to say anything too
about it because one I thought you
wouldn't believe me and two I thought
you would shoot my face off no
I just wouldn't have believed you
yeah because you were saying stuff
before I was like no you're crazy
because I felt totally normal
DJ Maniac says uh we lost Jerry Springer
this three this week that's right Jerry
Springer died uh Tom tell the New
Orleans story again which New Orleans
story about Jerry Springer oh Jerry
Springer okay
yeah there was this place called uh oh
man there's this little goth club
it's owned by a guy named Pierre he
actually owned the antique
shop it was down um
uh with his uh
[__] what was it the name of the street
wasn't Esplanade
I'll probably remember it in a minute
uh it's been a long time since I even
thought about it
but above it he had like an apartment
and he had that apartment turned into a
nightclub it had DJ booth and everything
had a bar
and he was running kind of an
underground
nightclub out of his apartment
it was a big apartment though you know
it's
the apartment was from the 1800s
looked like somebody interviewed the
vampire
had a balcony went around the outside of
it you could open the doors the doors
are all made out of glass would go all
right from the ceiling all the way down
the floor you know it was like French
doors I think what they're called
and um
that's where I met my first wife in that
place it was real cool candles
everywhere
and to get around certain laws
they didn't really run tabs
they just poured drinks and you better
and you had and you gave them money
all right but it was kind of like
donation
yeah that's usually how they get away
yeah get around that kind of thing right
you're like we're not charging you for
the drink necessarily donation at the
end of the night right but they kind of
expected a certain amount like five
bucks a drink right
you couldn't just go in it wasn't open
to the public
you had to ring a doorbell and Pierre's
wife would come down she'd dressed up in
her [__] Gothic gown it looked like
Lily Munster
and she'd open up the door and it was
like
bars in front of the doors you know if I
could like they have in New Orleans and
she's like hello you know who are you
you know she she didn't know you she
would give you a bunch of questions like
how did you hear about this what do you
know and if you're okay especially if
you were goth if you're dressed goth
she'd let you in
if you weren't she hadn't know how you
knew about the place
was in there one time
and uh
bunch of people showed up
I was at the bar drinking I was talking
to
um uh [__]
cappelletti was her last name
I'll just talk to her or Bridget yeah
Bridget cappelletti
she moved away though uh but she was a
work in the bar there Gotham chick she's
cool
and um
so I was she was pouring drinks
and she goes dude so did you see Jerry
Springer
and I said and they're like what like on
the TV yeah and I said you know I was
like yeah what are you talking about
he's in here this is he is because yeah
he's in there he's in the other he's in
the other room over there and around the
bar there was I said I'll go check it
out in a minute
about an hour or so later I walked in
there
and Jerry Springer was sitting on a dam
wicker chair big back on it and he's
sitting there [__] drinking and next
to his little [__] he's sitting there
drinking he's watching this girl
tied up to a little rack
she's just just in panties and shoes and
[__]
and her boyfriend's [__] putting on a
fetish show for [__]
Jerry
so I go to sit down next to him you know
it was pretty much empty you know but
four people in that room said now I'm
just watching them and then [__]
Jerry looks because babe you guys are
awesome
Jerry Springer with him watching the
[__] fetish show
ad hoc because the strippers would hang
out there
like a stripper hang out
when they were off duty that's where
they'd [__] party
is there anything could happen there at
any time
and uh
it was called the convent that was the
name of the place I'm trying to remember
what
it was it was at the corner of
[__] I can picture it right across from
the crystal
it's not Esplanade I'll remember it's
not there anymore he moved away Pierre
moved away
that's so cool though
yeah Gary Oldman was in there one time
he's up at the bar I didn't recognize
him
you just
in like Bermuda shorts and flip-flops
and [__]
dude yeah even if you're Gary Oldman he
got in now they let his ass in they're
like well you're famous yeah yeah and
then I kind of if it was me if I was
working the door I'd be like I don't
give a [__] if you're here like I love
Gary Oldman but I'm just like I don't
give a [__] if you're Gary old man
you're not coming in here dressed like
that sorry
Marilyn Manson
and uh Marilyn Manson showed up with
okay Trent resner used to come there
because they Trent resner live just up
the street
and evidently Marilyn Manson moved over
there too he moved in the same area yeah
because he's from Florida he's from
Florida Brian Warner Brian Warner yep so
we had heard that he had moved into town
didn't think much of it
trip would show up to the convent
one night I saw him leave we were up on
the balcony was hanging out with some
girls I think I think one of the girls
was actually Tiff my my first wife
and
resner [__] walks out underneath the
balcony and heads right towards this
[__] Ferrari that he had
he gets into Ferrari and [__] stereo
starts blasting and it blasts out head
like a hole and everybody [__] fell
out laughing like what a [__] [__]
listening to his own music that's some
small dick energy right there yeah
not just the car but also listening to
your own music yeah in the car like that
yeah and full volume and so everybody
can see you can hear you yeah I'm just
like how
yeah and he wasn't what was funny about
him is that [__] we were all [__]
decked out you know
in the best of late 90s goth attire
which is there was a couple different
styles you know but I was always doing
like Victorian stuff like [__] from
[__] interview the vampire type stuff
and he was just wearing nothing you know
black jeans and a [__] shirt you know
[__] band t-shirt
running around in a [__]
Ferrari well I think it was a far is it
the Ferrari or Lambo I think it might
have been a Ferrari it's been a long
time it's red good Lord yeah
a couple weeks later
I heard
people laugh at it chuckling and they
would say Tom guess what then I was like
what he goes Marilyn Manson and Trent
resner tried to get in and [__] and
uh they asked to come in and Pierce told
him no
that's so awesome send them packing and
[__] said no you're not allowed yeah
he said trap he said kicked the bars
yeah the bars they had opened he kicked
the bars demanded to come in and they
said no you can't come in it's because
Pierre couldn't stand Marilyn Manson
I can't
just always now there's this [__] you
seem like such a dude she just seemed
like such a douche okay now this might
be a little story behind this why
you wouldn't let in during that period
we were catching a [__] ton of Hell over
Marilyn Manson we've just walked down
the street in a bottle would come flying
out and Marilyn Manson you know we're
just constantly [__] with us I
remember those days yes
then a whole bunch of new guns were
showing we didn't even like Marilyn
Manson no no we couldn't stand him
uh we didn't really see it as goth it
was seemed like pop pop to us like pop
music
it was good though he had real good
covers I liked his covers
um
he had he had some
good songs of his own but I just
we were just catching so much Flack over
it
and uh no [__] Pierre told him no you
can't come in that's awesome yeah yeah
DJ Maniac yeah see he knows OG Goths
hate Manson because of this yeah I still
can't forgive the [__] even
though it's been like all that time
resner kicked the bars man boom kicked
the bus let us in and [__] [__]
pierce slam the door on him
yeah
it's like yeah I missed it I didn't see
it just heard about he's like plus I
heard about that douchey [__] you pulled
with the Ferrari and Blasting urine yeah
yeah
he wasn't bad though Trent rezner wasn't
bad it's just that uh
he didn't come across as like a guy
really a person really in the scene he
came across to somebody that was just
trying to
make money off of the scene he don't
think he was goth that was using part of
culture you seemed like a regular guy
yeah maybe not I just I mean I don't um
I've like okay he was kind of like Ben V
but
not as cool right you know it's always
like he's like yeah that's kind of come
off I like bed V A lot of people didn't
like bad V but I like Ben
I understand Ben said a band called
Ludovic yeah
actually a pretty decent they're a good
Batman they're from around here yeah
we're friends with with him and the uh
and his keyboard player
um the DJ Maniacs is trying to sell
since mellowed out because he's a dad
now and has Disney [__] you money yeah I
guess so I guess that would chill
everybody out yeah and see this is what
I always said DJ Maniac thank you and
totally ripped off skinny puppy and
didn't admit to it until years later
that's what always made me really mad
too I kind of feel like I saw Nine Inch
Nails only one time on purpose like the
first time I saw them was in 1990 and
that was like right after Pretty Hate
Machine came out and they opened for
Peter Murphy and even like a lot of the
Goths and stuff didn't really know who
they were or they were just like meh you
know what I mean they were just like
looking at him just waiting for Peter
Murphy to come out there was a bed and
it was weirder the skinny the skinny
puppy
when I was living in Detroit
this is even before I joined the army
skinny puppet come across the uh the
bridge from Ontario all the time [__]
they played fantastic shows
they had a bad we saw one time
it was about four bands that night all
of them pretty small but one of them
just I'll never forget it the dudes come
out on stage
on stage they had a television it was
already planned it was a bunch of static
and then there was like a it was kind of
like skinny puppy it's like
and we had a projector
projecting film and they had people
running the [__] film cameras they
projected that on a screen behind the
the uh the bad or behind the stage and
it was not a the stage was like two feet
tall we're not talking about a huge
[__] Amphitheater this is like I
don't even remember the [__] club
that this was that this was at my friend
Jason Quinlan took me there
and then uh [__] grandparents know
who that is
and it was he says this Jason he's
tonight is going to be these are all art
bands Art Nouveau type band it was BTK
yeah I was like that yeah
is the [__]
Trenton Michigan's [__] BTK did he
make you very upset no he was kind of
like imagine if BTK and Spock had a
[__] child it'd be like that
then the uh
so they had that [__] going and they
came on stage but they walked through
the crowd to get on stage and they were
all wearing these orange leotards and
the [__] the [__] orange leotard
went over their face they just they
didn't have [__] holes cut they were
just looking through it right and
they're [__] flat they're [__]
crotches all had a light flashing out of
it and I realized that what they had in
there was you know those yo-yos they had
the [__] oh yeah I remember they had
each one of those had a yo-yo [__]
stuff down in his [__] crotch and uh
pretty shoes and one dude was like
instead of walking a dog he was dragging
a [__] skateboard they had a bunch of
fur on it with a [__] poodle head it
was [__] bizarre and they get up
there and they do this so I can
bizarre music was kind of like skinny
puppy was cool the name of the band was
called
Kitty with a whip it was either Kitty
with a whip or kitten with a whip well
they were maybe they were named after
that movie kitten with a whale okay that
had John Forsyth and uh what's her face
that was uh did all his movies with
Elvis what the [__] was her name yeah
I'll think of it okay kitten with a whip
I saw it on a mystery science theater so
I'm watching this I'm just freaking I'm
just going with
is this [__] one dude had that white
motorcycle helmet on with his orange
leotards and it had [__] antennas and
I think it had [__] flashlights
[__] on the side of it it was kind of
like Gwar too
and um
I'm watching a [__] the film that
they're showing in the back it's black
and white film the [__] that they made
and on one scene you just see a big ass
come at the [__] camera and a bunch
of turds flying out of it they they they
[__] had stuck the camera underneath
the porta potty the dude was trying to
[__] on the camera or that glass or
something in front of the camera because
they had that in there oh it's just
anything you know I was like what the
[__] is this [__] I didn't forget it I
didn't forget it that's true it was like
a real cheap version of skinny puppy
and I haven't been I've never heard of
them since
that's funny that they were named I'm
sure they must have been named after
that movie and I think they were Detroit
man
yeah yeah I think
uh it's industrial what the [__] is that
chick's name God damn it somebody help
me help me
uh it's right on the tip of my tongue
right on the tip of my tongue
kitten with a whip come on
[__] she was in all those movies with
Elvis
I'll think of it in like five minutes
from now DJ Maniac said [__] Tom my old
band used to use three video monitors
showing hardcore porn and yellow films
sets yeah see I like that yeah they were
just [__] on the camera
well there's a bunch of other stuff too
you know I kind of feel like look I I'm
all for
subversive art and for pushing
boundaries and stuff like that
on the other hand it's like how
difficult is it to just like
poop on something
and smear it around and be like woo I'm
so edgy well I didn't spin around it
just cut off well no I'm just you know
just hypothetically yeah so you know I
don't I don't know I I kind of take all
that with a grain of salt you know what
I'm saying I think it had a Plexiglas
thing in the way and it just landed on
the flex glass yeah and somebody's
mentioned GG Allen I thought they would
yeah yeah that dude was insane yeah I
was friends with a dude when I was
living in Boston I was friends with a
dude who knew Gigi even would hang out
with him his name was Tyrone and he was
the only white guy that ever knew named
Tyrone
Tyrone was also friends with The Dead
Boys
you talk about them all the time I
didn't know who the [__] they like stiff
baiters and all that yeah he knew them
he said that um all I remember what Ty
told me about Gigi is that he he
got pissed off at Gigi because when when
Gigi was before it was famous he was
real good
but then he realized if he just [__]
[__] the show up and made a big seat
he wouldn't have to perform
so he started doing that right yeah so
it seemed like kind of cynical like
cynical right so you never were able to
really see his show and Margaret thank
you that's what I was trying to think of
thank you and he would he would do weird
[__] he got killed in jail
that's what happened to Gigi
GG out
he did something in the Central Lockup
he wasn't in there for any amount of
time it was just some minor [__] and
somebody killed him in there he said the
wrong thing this dude dude [__]
killed him
um
Ty told me all kinds of weird [__] he'd
be watching GG [__] acting an ass on
the stage and [__] some dude [__]
jumped up on the stage and whipped his
dick out on him and Gigi you're trying
to get a rise at Gigi like Friday you
know Gigi trying to make Gigi attack him
you know or something
and do children punk rock dude jumped up
on the [__] stage and pulled his
[__] dick out and [__] Gigi
[__] threw himself on the dude and
[__] sucked his dick
yeah which that's probably the right
winning yeah they said yeah the dude
[__] ran off
oh no I wasn't expecting that yet
hey you jump up on a stage and whip your
dick out at somebody yeah you better
expect that yeah to be going in
somebody's mouth yeah because it's like
you know don't act surprised yeah don't
act surprised
Ty said he saw that [__] and kind of
lost respect for him he's like oh yeah I
didn't think it was cool well that's
what I mean I just kind of feel like
like I said I'm all for pushing
boundaries and stuff but and you know uh
getting under people's skins and yeah
you know upsetting their delicate
sensibilities and whatnot but how much
talent does it actually take to just
like [__] in your hand and throw it well
he would do that kind of [__] that's
what I mean [__] in his hand throw it
he'd [__] uh like that's just gross
vomit he would vomit and rub around he
was he was but he would do anything to
just uh
so I thought that he was trying to get
the show to stop
because he didn't think that he could
perform anymore
and he was getting famous
for and they had him on the [__]
Jerry Springer Show and [__]
well then in a way it's kind of like
I'm gonna say it's kind of like the
culture's fault too because obviously
even if you're like a decent musician
and stuff like that like no one's really
gonna give a [__] but the second that
you start doing all that crazy crap like
yeah everybody's gonna pay attention
then yeah so
so it's kind of our fault too so I
thought that he was trying to emulate um
Iggy Pop
because evidently Iggy Pop did crazy
[__] on stage yeah he would like cut
himself with glass and all that kind of
I don't think Iggy Pop ever [__] in his
hand that I know of yeah or sucks up
dude try to suck some dudes oh well no
that might that sounds like something he
might have done he probably done that
[__] in private probably but he did used
to kind of like
um yeah like roll around in glass and
[__] like that but the thing about Iggy
Pop was that I mean the Stooges that
were actually like a good band and like
Iggy Pop was like actually talented
so you know and yeah some of the shows
were kind of like [__] up where
everyone was just like too far gone to
like do much of anything but
I don't know I kind of feel like they're
I think I'd be mad like if I went to see
like some band I really liked and they
were all just like too [__] up to
do anything like maybe it sounds more
legendary in hindsight yeah because
there's like oh man we went and saw
whoever and it's like they were so funny
murder said Gigi overdosed I heard that
he got killed in prison maybe he
overdosed in prison but the story that I
was told is that he got killed in prison
or died in prison I don't know actually
wasn't really prison it was jail
that's that's that was a story I heard
he wasn't sentenced or anything they
just got to arrest him like put him in a
drunk tank type of deal he died
DJ Maniac also says Rob Zombie owes
Ministry of blood dead for his success
yeah I agree with that too to be honest
Rob Zombie even kinda looks like Al
Jorgensen a little bit Maniac said the
[__] we've hit the overdose we've had
this argument before okay all right in a
fleabag hotel room okay before that was
just a story that I had heard that was a
story maybe you're thinking of somebody
else maybe
maybe I'm confusing him with Sid Vicious
although Sid Vicious didn't die in jail
either no he got out and then he got out
and he died but he didn't get killed by
somebody in jail somebody told me he got
killed in jail that's probably what and
that stuck with me I guess
yeah DJ Maniac said he took um Al's look
and he's talking about Rob Zombie and
schtick and gave him no credit for it
yeah and to be honest from far away they
look very similar Rob Zombie and Al
Jorgensen like especially back in the
day
uh DJ Maniac said so Al turned around
and [__] his ex-girlfriend
that's pretty funny
that's pretty funny uh Senor stick says
uh stage performance is very demanding
it is and I get that
honestly I have a lot of admiration for
artists that can be completely [__] up
and yet still do like a coherent show
because there are a lot of them that can
do that I'm like man more power to you
because man I have several drinks I
don't really want to do anything we go
to sleep you know what I mean I can't be
like running around singing and [__]
that's for sure I like Rob Zombie in the
white zombie uh era when he went solo it
was okay just started to get real to me
it sounded like too Poppy to me
it was it was okay though the Dragula
come on
you're kind of pushing it Living Dead
Girl
I mean there are good songs but those
are pop songs
you know yeah
yeah Ben posts something it sounds like
he'd copy this I'm sorry later that
morning uh puke noticed that Gigi that's
a person yeah uh notice that GiGi Allen
uh still laid motionless where he had
left him and posed for Polaroids with
the corpse before calling for an
ambulance yeah I remember I remember
that story I remember that story Alma is
pronounced dead at the scene okay yeah
after her show he OD'd okay and then
somebody said heroin and then somebody
took pictures of it yeah I specifically
remember that that detail that they took
pictures of them because you know that's
clearly the punk rock thing well didn't
some
Scandinavian black metal guy Norwegian
black metal guys do the same thing where
they killed some dude took pictures of
him
you know now that you mention it didn't
we watch did we watch it together but
there was that documentary that was
about that that was about I don't think
it was about one band particularly but I
think it was just about the Scandinavian
black metal scene in particular yeah it
was just like burning down the church
nothing happening in the Scandinavian
[__] scene it was a sleepy [__]
town these dudes are killing each other
and burning down churches over over
black metal music
and getting into gag fights and they're
they're not really tough guys when you
see them boys gotta fight about
something they're fighting about it they
just make [__] up and there was
something where one of them killed the
other one until the light takes us yeah
that's what it was did we watch that
together or did I just watch it
because I remember it being really good
yeah I thought you watched it with me I
thought you watched it with me I
wouldn't mind watching that again
actually but yeah that was like actually
really good I don't think I did too long
in prison either I'm not I don't think
he did what 10 years some I don't
remember
I don't remember
and Ben says uh varg the guy that oh
that's right the guy that was on the
documentary uh he's now a popular
podcaster yeah that's right I remember
that guy who's that varg yeah the guy
that was on the documentary oh okay
popular and racist Assad Sparkles yeah
but
um
yeah murder horn had said yeah before
they called the cops they went out to
buy a disposable camera and took a pic
and made it their album cover that's
that's right that's right yeah I
forgotten about that that's the black
metal guys right
yeah was that that or was that yeah I
can't remember did I remember that they
put the dead guy on the album cover I
love the detail that they specifically
had to go out and buy a disposable
camera
losers because they didn't have one yeah
yeah you guys you guys yes and evidently
only people in the black metal scene
there knew what that all you needed
Mayhem that's who that was yeah nobody
else really knew it nobody really knew
what it meant except the fans in the
area
they had one of their album covers was a
church they had burned down too yeah
that's right
I don't know C man that kind of stuff
just it just seems very try hard it's
very try hard boar they're bored
guess if you've got nothing to do
you know what I mean it's just like if
you're gonna be like cool and badass and
stuff like that just be cool and badass
you know it's like it's just that just
seems like very very it's easy to be
cool in bed over coffee well I'm just
saying that's just like seem like
they're really overcompensating and it's
like when they get to that point I'm
just like that's it's so Edge lordy
that's so
and it's like that's it's they're trying
too hard they're trying too hard
you can't try hard to be cool or badass
you just have to be cool or badass you
just there's no trying involved you know
what I'm saying
murder horn has said Christian black
metal band
they have those though don't they really
me I mean I'm sure they they must right
they have Christian everything
we've talked many times about
the whole Christian
sub-genre subculture sub because they
have their own versions of everything
they even have their own version of
Netflix and it's called Pure flicks
and they have and basically like one guy
whose name is David a r white he I don't
know if he owns Pure Flix but he for
sure like has like all the shows on
there and he's in a bunch of them like
they make their own sitcoms and I've
never seen them directly they gotta be
bad but I watch Like I said Nick deramio
and he's like this hilarious hilarious
like gay guy and he does like he does
all kinds of different stuff but he has
a pureflix subscription so sometimes
he'll do like these religious and so and
they're not long they're like they're
sitcoms but they're like eight minutes
long like each episode or whatever oh
that's it and so yeah and so like
sometimes he'll talk about
about them and it's like those are the
best ones those are the best episodes
because they look
[__] awful they look awful I wouldn't
I wouldn't think that they'd have like a
really huge writing staff
well no like I said I think it's just
one dude and it's just the dude David a
r white he looks like he should be like
a Nickelback or something
no like seriously he had that you know
you know how you know how like in the
90s or early 20s out like I can't
remember it all blurs together but like
the early 2000s or whatever when all of
that like nickelbacky type of [__] was
going on and all the dudes like look
like Guy Fieri like where they all had
like the spiky like you know blonde
tipped hair and little soul patches and
all that kind of nonsense
um yeah well he's got that and he's on
every like he seems like he's on every
show yeah I guess they have movies too
but I don't really I don't know I'm not
paying for that [__] come on now
foreign
yeah pure flicks yeah seriously it's
called and even the the logo looks kind
of like it's a very very similar font to
Netflix except they don't use red
because they're like oh it's like yeah
it was like a it's like sky blue with
like a cloudy [__] or something like
that but it kind of looks like I'm like
why like they can't
it's almost like they can't like make
their own [__] it's like they always
have to do like a Innovative
you know kind of a substandard version
of like a regular thing yeah that's
that's uh
I talked about this before
on the show
it's a shame because there's a lot of
good material that could be made into
some really cool Christians sure man you
could like work with that and there
there have been some I would call I
would classify them as Christian movies
that were badass all right uh but
Christians really did very few of them
were actually made by Chris's
like Noah was [__] badass that was
like something out of [__] the daily
yeah that was really good
um well you should probably watch mother
too because that's also like a religious
allegory you might dig it I'm not sure
then there's that horror movie that had
the dude that played uh [__] uh did
from Alien remember they thought
everybody was demons
what was the name of that Frailty
Frailty that was [__] weird I love
Frailty and that was a Christian movie
but it it was just good yeah because the
Christian guy who was killing like
people because he thought they were
demons like turned out to be right they
weren't right they were demons yeah and
you're like yeah they were demons yeah
and Oscar says yeah I was gonna say this
The Exorcist is a Catholic yeah the
exercise is good yeah so this there is
it's not the fault of Christianity
it's the fault of Christians like I said
they get a lot of good material they
could work with yeah they need well what
it is is that
these people trying to do [__] like pure
flicks and everything
they're trying to adhere to a certain
ideology which fences them in anybody
who's real creative doesn't want to work
in that environment they want more
freedom of movement right so they're
gonna go work for somebody else
you gotta have some but you gotta have
if you wanted to have like a Christian
based version of Netflix you have to
lacks up on the on the ideology you know
so therefore you can bring talented
people in there
because
you can have many different
interpretations of Christianity if you
read the New Testament those books are
all written by different people at
different times that is not one thing
that's a patchwork quilt of a bunch of
different works and none of them really
agree with each other and they're all
definitely those books came from
different Christian Traditions some of
them where there was never a [__]
Jesus that was born it was a Celestial
Jesus in heaven other ones there was a
Jesus that actually lived and then
ascended to heaven so
Christianity never was just one thing it
was a group of competing cults
so therefore modern Christianity really
should be that it should be a bunch of
competing ideas about Christianity
that's why you got so many different
churches you know like even
protestantism is divided up into so many
different churches so you're never going
to get these people to agree on anything
just let it all be different
like if you ask me
Mormonism is just as valid as any other
Christianity it's well I mean it's all
just amazing it's all about the same
thing so so it's just their
interpretation of it and they've added
some stuff they've got [__] you know
Joseph Smith writing new stuff you know
he's a new prophet
I mean why not why not that's in the
rules they've been doing that [__] for
life it could be a prophet why not gonna
pull some stuff out of my ass and like
[__] write some [__] down I'm gonna
start my start mine yeah like I can't do
it now because I already told everybody
all that stuff even even the old stuff
even going back to the septuagen you
know in the in the which would be like
the Greek version of the Old Testament
all of that stuff was just kind of
written from day one as religious
material it was not written as a history
book or it was written as a religious
material from the very beginning it's
written in that Motif it's written in
that style
no dates mentioned no real places
mentioned and there isn't you know it's
it it's spiritual
it's religious Mythos
Oscar says been having anxiety working
from home sorry about that hopefully we
can cheer you up a little bit yeah
um yeah catchy three I'm Guy Fieri
that's he always says it like that and
we're rolling out prick yeah he's kind
of a douche I do like Diners Drive-Ins
and Dives I'm not gonna lie but that's
not it's not because of him I like
because like seeing all the restaurants
let me chop that drink up yeah Larry
says what about God told me to That's a
classic I love God told me to so good if
you haven't seen it uh Larry Cohen uh
it's Larry Cohen film it's weird as [__]
and I'm into it I don't remember if I
did I thought we reviewed it at some
point
or I did a video about did I do a video
about it I don't know I remember like
writing a big long thing about it but
yeah I really do like that murder Hornet
said uh I dated this rule Holy Girl once
we went to the mall I wanted to buy this
shirt a Hot Topic that had a skull on
the tag on the neck and she flipped out
saying it was satanic I can't imagine
I can't imagine like growing up like
that or being like that
I just I can't imagine it like just
something as stupid as that like a tag
on a thing with a skull on it I'm like
you do understand that you have a skull
underneath your face right it's like why
I I don't know why it upsets people so
much I just I don't get it I just I just
really don't uh and Ian said the Old
Testament was metal as [__] yeah right I
mean there's all kind of like [__] I
mean you know there's a reason why
they've been why there's so much like
cool [__] like based off of that I mean
the stories in there are [__] great
um and Oscar said Mormonism is Twisted
as [__] it is but like I said they all
kind of are
they uh I don't really I don't know if I
really like make a distinction between
all of them because they all seem
[__] weird to me you know what I mean
murder Hornet said I'm a level 20
operating season
then Ben said the Old Testament was an
or well it's all oral tradition until
someone wrote it down yeah and by the
time they wrote it down I mean who knows
how many centuries or Millennia had
passed and you know just like the
proverbial game of telephone
all the stories became you know changed
and people added details and [__] like
that
but see I mean we've talked about this
before I find that kind of [__]
fascinating though what kind of Chef has
me all the um just like the uh origins
of mythologies and stuff like that just
because it's so fascinating like how
different cultures around the world kind
of come to similar conclusions but like
with their own unique spin on it you
know what I'm saying a lot of the
concepts in those books are kind of
universal yeah that's what I'm saying
um Ian says I grew up in a Mennonite
group I've seen some religious [__] oh
how interesting I actually don't know
that much about the meta Knights so if
there's anything you'd like to discuss
about it then I'd be curious to hear it
because I don't know that much about it
like I said
um Camp guy said just tell her the whole
earth is the domain of Satan says so in
the Bible yeah if you're worried about
Satanism might as well get up the [__]
off the planet because you know
uh Larry says yeah most myths and
religious texts are just allegories
uh of events of objective truths that's
why there's so many similarities between
them all it's coming from the same
sources Back Down the Line yeah exactly
it's like Human Experience largely the
same
uh you know like I said with minor
variations uh for culture so a lot of
the stories do have a lot of more
probably more similarities than
differences but everybody kind of has
their own unique spin on stuff
and Kalyn Higgins says weren't most
Messiah themed religions based off the
Epic of Gilgamesh a lot of them probably
were I feel like because
I mean Epic of Gilgamesh was so
similar it's funny because I mean I've
read it in uh high school or something
and then I took a Humanities class
in college and
some people in there were really
surprised like they didn't realize that
Gilgamesh had essentially the flood
story like the Noah's Ark sort of story
in it and that they didn't realize that
the story was thousands of years older
than the Bible was and I think a lot of
them got kind of offended when they
found that out like we were making it up
or something like the teacher was making
it up or something he's like no for real
this story is like way older than the
Bible it was just kind of repurposed and
like put in there which story the Noah's
Ark like the flood story
yeah that's what that's what you're
talking about so yes it predates the
Bible by yeah a couple thousand years
well I think the Epica Gilgamesh was
considered to be authentic history at
the time
everybody grew up with that so they're
like yeah there was a flood
I mean there's proof of a flood think
about it go to the highest mountain
you're gonna find seashells in certain
places oh man this is all underwater
they're the flood yeah so everybody kind
of thought that yeah which I guess is
what you would think because they didn't
understand back then like the concept of
deep time and it's like yeah this used
to be plates right and like this used to
be underwater at some point like it
wasn't a flood necessarily it was just
you know the way [__] moves around and
all that
but evidently the
um Dr Robert M price
in his uh Old Testament studies
a recording which you can
um you can get it on YouTube
I think it's in about eight or nine
Parts the audio recording isn't very
good he actually reads a lot of the
Epica Gilgamesh
and uh it's a lot better written than uh
the Bible version
I remember quite enjoying the
translation that I read in school
I think there was a more recent
translation
it's probably like a decade ago now that
was
they made a big deal about it about
there being a new translation of it now
the older the New Testament
scriptures that have survived the
original Greek
they're hillbilly versions of kind of
what has survived kind of hillbillies
versions
of religion compared to other stuff that
was going on like you know [__]
Persian and Mesopotamia stuff is a lot
more sophisticated it's just that what
we have survived
because uh
Christians and Jews and Muslims over
time just destroyed everything else that
they got their hands on they tried to
erase anything else we're lucky to have
what we have
yeah sometimes when I think about it I'm
like it's good that like somebody to
stash some [__] away otherwise we
wouldn't know a bunch of stuff about all
of this stuff that happened back then
and the versions that we're dealing with
this includes Judaism
they're kind of like copies of medieval
versions they're not even that old
they're not that old they're they're
reboots reboots reboots reboots of
reboots
and ours is a reboot version of this
include of kind of like medieval
versions of it of Christianity the New
Testament the Old Testament
um
I think they said the Septuagint which
was the original was in Greek
and it seems to be a great copy of
something
that may have been the original language
according to where it looks like it was
written
it's where the Torah and the Old
Testament and the Old Testament came
from it's it's not that old
um
it's not from the time it clan that it's
talking about
I think if I remember correctly it's
about 200 BC yeah no 200 A.D I think is
what uh which is about as old as
Christianity which is funny because
people think Christianity started in 30
A.D it didn't
the first versions of it you know it
started to be putting together where you
had Bibles you know I think around 200
A.D it's not it's not as old as people
think it is
so
no I think the oldest book that came out
of that Bible before it became a Bible I
think was I think it was around
70 A.D I think what are you doing
the thing about event mark
but you know
I mean the idea that you would want to
construct your life and your values
around something that was written when
people didn't know [__] about [__] is
mind-blowing to me why on Earth would
you want to do that well modern religion
what are you doing oh why stop it
she's trying to get book pull books out
she's trying to pull books out of the
bookshelf
damn Pokey hey she pulled a book out
ripped it up yeah you punished oh you're
in trouble he looks real guilty
um she's gonna get right back and do it
again though
they're kind of taking it out of context
all that stuff is written basically from
priests back in those days
and um yeah I don't really think you're
supposed to really model your life after
it well no I mean you're not supposed to
but right but yes people still do it the
interpretation of what that was it's not
deception had a lot to do with uh like
God didn't write that [__] it's fine
the septogen which would be the Old
Testament had a lot to do with the
Covenant okay if you actually look at
the details of the Covenant that's like
something a pip would do to a hoe I have
chosen you and you will do this you know
what I mean [__] that's all it is you
know [__]
um and then there's a bunch of laws that
are given out that get changed a couple
times I remember and
uh then they [__] about the law
and then there's a bunch of stories
about uh Jewish Kings
and uh then a bunch of poems it's more
like a it's more like a cultural Library
than anything else
it did have some laws in it
but it's hard to know which laws are
kind of in effect because it kind of in
other places says oh well don't worry
about that or then you got [__]
favorite you know got big figures and
Kings doing things where they're
actually kind of breaking these laws but
then they're not punished for that
they're punished for another thing that
you didn't know that was a law it's just
it's weird [__] you know
well like I said it was kind of cobbled
together by from lots of different
writings over yeah centuries and
centuries so it's like obviously it's
inconsistent it doesn't make any sense
and it still is even though it's been
edited and yeah put together like in a
more cohesive form but it's still
contradictory
you know yeah they'll say it's not
contradictory but it is yeah that's a
bunch of crap yeah there's a lot of yeah
like uh if you're gonna go tell me if
you're gonna go the good test is if let
me ask you this if you're a Christian
is it or is it not a sin
to eat meat that was sacrificed to a
Roman Idol or to a Roman god should you
eat can you eat that is it okay
and the Bible is going to say well in
one place that says well
if you're a guest at somebody's house
and they serve you meat and that meat
was Sir was sacrificed to an idol when
they're talking about a Roman Idol
as long as you know that that Idol isn't
true God then yeah it's okay you can eat
it then later on it says but if God
finds out he's gonna [__] kill him
see you just better you just no right no
yeah and then I thought the whole thing
was well God knows everything yeah
so they're basically saying don't do
that [__]
that was all Pauline material and some
of the some of the poly materials
obviously a forgery it's not poly
materials it was it's another source
that somehow snuck in there
and um
any anything that's Pauline seems to be
talking about a Jesus That Never Was
Born a Jesus that existed in heaven
and it always was in heaven so you're
talking about an angel an angel above he
never came down here yeah you're talking
about an Angel that's above Michael and
above Gabriel
God's favorite son that's why they keep
saying he was born of a woman in other
places they're saying oh no he was
really born he was born
yeah because like I said if you think
about it saying born of a woman I'm like
well wasn't everybody yes now they're
trying to say they're trying to tell you
that this Jesus was actually born right
yeah that's why they're making that and
uh the other Jesus these other people
believe in that one would that one
wasn't born and that one just hung out
and yeah and that one's not real
ity's favorite the real Jesus was born
that's why in some of the Pauline
material it says
we are partaking of our supper while
they protect their supper and don't
worry about their supper
okay so there's more than one Christian
religion
if you know like the Last Supper
yeah yeah that's what they're talking
about but there's evidently more than
one last supper
different groups of Christians had
different stories the second to last
yeah
the penultimate supper
not their savior we're talking about our
Lord not their Lord but our Lord so
there's not not there Jesus or Jesus
that's what he said he's saying Jesus
fight yeah the heaven Jesus Wars well
what you're talking about is a bunch of
[__] Fanboys yeah comic book Fanboys
reading these books there is literally
no difference that's what they're
talking about difference they're like
they're saying this is Star Wars this is
Star Wars that other Kathleen Kennedy
[__] that's not Star Wars that's what
they're doing that's what they're doing
yeah like I said I I see Mandalorian
that's Star Wars
Obi-Wan that's not Star Wars they're
saying you know
the acolyte that's not Star Wars this is
Star Wars the original trilogy you know
that's what they're saying that's what
that's all that Paulie materials that's
what it is
yeah it's like it's [__] there Jesus
we're talking about our Jesus fanfic
extended Universe all that kind of stuff
yup that's fan they had it way back then
yep that's the exact same thing
Gadget 3 said my niece has a kitty who
has all kind of preggers guess I'm
getting a cat swore I wouldn't after I
lost we Sergeant meow meowmenstein yeah
I'm Stein oh yeah you need another kitty
kitties are the best
even when they tear your books up what
book is that that she that she tore I
think that one was well like I said I
put like all my old
secondhand paperbacks on the bottom
because I know that she has a tendency
to go in there and like rip them out
what book is that that she tore up
it looks like
is it I don't know oh it's uh that's
like a Horror Story compilation
yeah a fabulous formless Darkness look
it's got like couch on Blackwood and
Demon King and stuff
yeah so he was saying that they've
removed a lot of books from Canon
there's a lot of different cabinets you
know the Egyptian Coptic Bible there's
uh the Catholic version and the English
uh you know you asked me Shakespeare
wrote the King James Bible that somebody
showed me where the the word Shakespeare
was hidden in the Bible in that version
of the Bible
so I think and really in English
the King James Bible is the [__]
Bible that's the best sounding Bible
okay well that's kind of the standard
yeah English language right yeah
um
so there was never an agreement what
Canon was
never
and there's a lot of stuff that probably
should have been in there
for some reason they didn't want to have
been the Gospel of Thomas
not you no the other times
it's just the book of Thomas what in the
gospel times the book of tongues
the book of Thomas just evidently had a
bunch of sayings sayings wise sayings
about from Jesus
probably not in there because it
probably conflicted with the budget with
another narrative that they had that
they're trying to assemble from this
cobbled together so it was maybe like
Jesus's failed stand-up comedian career
like and his friend was writing down all
his funniest lines yes
[Laughter]
because there's a lot of advice on how
to save money
so you know how to do it Jesus tells you
how to clip coupons
that's awesome how to deal with money
oh my God sounded useful they would have
been invested they're gonna cut the
useful [__] out yeah we just we just
want the frivolous stupid [__] that's
gonna make everybody miserable I think I
think Thomas also had the one where
Jesus the baby Jesus is bringing dead
birds back to life
um it's one where I think uh he brings a
little boy back to life to say no he
didn't push me off the baby Jesus or the
young boy Jesus got accused of murder
accused of pushing his playmate off the
roof and killing him what [__] so so
Jesus brings back the ghost of the
little boy the little boy testifies in
his defenses no he didn't kill me I fell
on my own
I believe that was book of Thomas but
somebody might correct me but that's a
good story
did he did he chop down a cherry tree
also he brought dead birds back to life
I think he
had some clay birds and brought him to
life I think
my better what it was fake toy birds
he's bringing her life
doing Miracles as a child and a baby
man can you imagine if your kids started
doing [__] like that you'd run a mile
away in the other direction it's
obviously fan fiction Well yeah if you
believe that Jesus could do all these
Miracles what did he do when he was a
little kid
uh he was uncontrollable he was like
Dennis the Menace
manners doing Miracles just [__]
Willy new oh my God how awesome would
that be like
and [__] and [__] Jesus
resurrecting little kids to go no he
didn't kill me all right go back walking
across the swimming pool at the pool
party so it was like Kawaii Jesus that's
what you're talking about do you
remember that video game that you see
you still have it uh no what was it
called
it was a game about Jesus and you could
Jesus and John the Baptist yeah
oh I got it it was super cute fighting
zombies it was super cute if you fought
zombies yeah what the [__] was the name
of that thing I forgot
it was um zombie attack or something no
oh damn
oh my God are you still like every time
you played it I always wanted to watch
because it was so [__] up a cross and
start fighting them you can pick up a
fish and throw that was my favorite like
the the fish throwing that made me laugh
like everything you could power up over
time where you could oh yeah it would
like make a noise like that
[__] oh my God it was so funny yeah I
forgot what it was going I can't
remember what it's called it was good it
was good game but it was kind of like
Kawaii looking yeah like SD super
deformed yeah like that like they were
super cute like the little short big
heads like yeah like a super cute little
Jesus
you could yeah you could play as either
Jesus or you could play as John the
Baptist right yeah
but and they both had different
abilities yeah but my favorite thing was
the fish throw well it wasn't just
throwing fish you could like smack
people with fish right like you could
win you could hit some of the fish you
could hit people right other fish you
could throw it that made me laugh like
every single time
every single time it's kind of like who
designed this game automated person
Japanese that's one of the funniest
[__] things
I guess it's yeah it was like it would
that would be like the Japanese
interpretation of what Christianity is
it's just see that's that's my that's
more of my speed fish and bread and wine
yeah in Judea
it was so so funny I wish you still had
that game I think it's free yeah it's
free you can get it I can I could
probably download it again you could
probably get it on your phone I just
can't like remember what it was called
though
I mean it's not like super exciting you
just basically walk around Ray it's like
a retro game you just like walk around
like you know whacking zombies with Fish
And yeah you know stick on crosses and
hitting them across them with crosses
and stuff but it's like calling down
rain and earthquakes and [__] yeah like
lightning bolts and whatnot yeah it's
like super funny
because that's what a Japanese person
would think Jesus was like to fight like
I said that's bad that's better I like
that version
I saw if I could I saw a video of a
Japanese Christmas parade and they had
fun they had
Santa Claus crucified on a cross and
carried him like he was Jesus I've heard
that yeah is that true or is that an
urban legend oh I saw the video of it
because I always thought that I think
they do the legend I think they do no I
think they do that
because I've heard that story like your
memories [__] up even well I've heard
that story like going back to at least
the 90s yeah like that they like
somebody was in a mall and they saw like
Santa Claus like in Japan and they saw
like Santa Clauses crucified and I
thought that I had read that that was an
urban legend but I'm not entirely sure
so anybody that's you know maybe they
redo it maybe maybe they're doing it now
well yeah maybe now like the urban
legend took off they said oh that's a
good idea
now I think the KFC thing where they eat
KFC on Christmas I think that's true oh
yeah because they don't have turkey
right so I think that's true and that
was because well I was watching like a
whole video about food history and they
were talking about how KFC specifically
uh tried to make the Japanese think that
Americans ate big buckets of chicken on
Christmas and it worked
so now like a lot like not everybody
obviously but now like a large portion
of Japanese people they think that it's
like tradition I think a lot of them
know that Americans don't do that but
they just got so used to doing it like
suicide that was made by a guy who ran
Kentucky Fried yeah that's what I just
said that was that was like his that was
like one dude's idea and that was his
idea but the thing is is that from the
Japanese perspective at that time and I
think that was the 60s you did that with
60s or 70s
that probably would have been accurate
from their point of view because they
probably really wouldn't have given a
[__] about the difference between a
chicken and a turkey I mean you know
they're both poultry so yeah close
enough so instead of saying yeah they
eat these big chickens
you know
like you know do you know they
understand a yak and a water buffalo I
don't it's just you know it's a cow yeah
I admit that I do not
so that's probably all that's probably
the Japanese
solution to the problem is well well
yeah chicken is like turkey so it is but
you know I think they give them dressing
and don't they give them dressing and
potatoes and and cranberry and all that
that would work it doesn't happen that's
what I mean I don't know about cranberry
but it definitely does come I'm not sure
what comes I think it's the same thing
that kind of comes with the family meal
if you get a KFC over here you like a
bucket of chicken and then you can
choose what size you get sides you get
so you get Like Biscuits and uh mashed
potatoes I don't know about coleslaw I
don't think it's fried though what the
chicken yeah I don't think it was fried
yeah it is I thought it was a whole
chicken no no it's just like the regular
Fried Chicken bucket like you get over
here all right because I saw the
commercials they should like I saw some
Japanese commercials okay and it was
yeah it was just like a bucket okay like
my dad used to manage a KFC back in the
day so I ate a lot of KFC growing up did
it come with dressing though
and February
I no I don't think it came with cream
well I don't think it came with anything
that you wouldn't normally get at KFC so
I think it came with mashed potatoes and
biscuits I don't know about coleslaw
though because I don't know if they sell
coleslaw in Japan yeah they probably do
is that I mean yeah I guess that would
be kind of big it's cabbage cabbage I
would uh the thing is is that I would
think that I remembered seeing the
commercials for it when they talked
about that on that program and I thought
it was a a I thought it was a holiday
version
it was special I mean yeah you might be
right about that version you might be
right it came with something that wasn't
normal
and it was more like a dinner service
from what I remember it did look like
something you get for not Christmas it
looks like something you'd give for
Thanksgiving
but a lot of times that's the same meal
in the United States yeah I do kind of
feel well like I don't know because
everybody does something different but I
mean I do kind of feel like probably for
a ham for Christmas actually but I yeah
like growing up
um we always had a ham yeah although my
mom's side of the family would do a ham
and a turkey yeah but usually like my
dad's side of the family would just do
like a big ham and a bunch of sides with
the Publix and got a smoked turkey that
thinks badass in it yeah we made like a
couple sandwiches yeah and it wasn't
expensive either turkey I was gonna say
that even though chicken and turkey are
kind of similar I I mean I could
probably tell the difference if my eyes
were well I don't know because you were
you know on um
what [__] Gordon Ramsay one of the
million Gordon Ramsay shows how does the
dude never sleeps I swear to God he has
like a million shows but I was watching
the most recent Master Chef and you know
how he always does that um that test
where they put the blindfolds on them
and then like put different foods in
their mouth and they have to identify
them and even though these people are
all like presumably like professional
chefs and stuff they all most of them do
like really really badly so and some of
them are like way off like some they put
like a mushroom in their mouth and it's
like pineapple you know what I mean it's
like it's crazy so I kind of feel like
I don't know if I was in the situation
between if you put chicken in my mouth
or turkey in my mouth and I had
blindfold on I probably couldn't tell
the difference but if I know like you
know I don't know they taste different
to me but maybe if I couldn't see it
maybe not uh Ian has to go so have a
good night uh good night have a have a
good one I'm glad you could stop by and
see us
Sebastian Moran said any baked beans and
tomato sauce yeah I don't know I'm not
super into baked beans I know that's
like a real big thing but
I don't know I have to say one of the
weirdest things and I know if there's
some Brits in the chat one of the
weirdest things that I experienced when
the first time I went to the UK was the
whole
sometimes having like baked beans on
toast for breakfast and I'm just like
I don't know man beans are not really a
breakfast food that's it's too early in
the morning to be like facing I could
see maybe having some toast with a
little bit of butter or a little bit of
jam or something like that on it that's
fine but
I'm not eating beans that early in the
morning come on now and also another
weird thing was that sometimes they
would put like canned spaghetti on toast
for breakfast oh that's terrible and I'm
just like why on Earth would you do that
how high were you when you came up with
that you're either very high or very
poor gross I don't even want that for
dinner
so you know what I mean I don't mind
those two things separately but it's
like putting canned spaghetti on toast
you just have soggy toast are you sure
that's not something real retro we gotta
ask our British people if they still do
that well that's what I'm saying some
[__] I'm just saying well the first time
I went to the UK in the 90s
people were still eating that but I
don't know if it was just like a
regional thing or whatever yeah
Ben says prefer an American breakfast uh
or a tin of treacle Puerto Rico sausage
hahaha
what did he say I mean
to be honest I don't usually eat
breakfast
um I mean I get up at the ass crack of
dawn and I'm you know usually my
digestive system I'm like I'm not
prepared to like eat anything at that
time of morning if I do it'll just be
literally a cup of coffee or a packet of
oatmeal like a you know a little bowl of
oatmeal or something that's like usually
all I eat how long we've been on uh an
hour and 21 minutes okay
okay
I do love big breakfasts
Foods though like I'm real into like
omelettes and quiche and waffles and
pancakes I love all that [__] I just
can't eat it though I usually have to
eat it like later in the day or for
dinner
because I can't eat that much early in
the morning actually I can't eat that
much anytime but I seriously can't eat
that much early in the morning I can
well of course you can I can
I can go I can get down immediately as
soon as I wake up I'm ready to go
I wish I could because I always kind of
wish that I could just like I wouldn't
do it all the time obviously but I was
like sometimes to be like man it'd be
really nice to like wake up on Sunday
and you know even if it was later like
10 or 11 to like go and like to get
brunch or something get some waffles or
some [__] like that but
I just I don't know I just can't eat
that much [__] food which sucks
I can eat it late at night like when I'm
drunk and stuff like I could go to
Denny's and get a grand slam or some
[__] but that would be good
I don't know I just
and this past week I've just haven't
even though I get up at five actually
this morning I got up at 4 30 because I
had some work I had to do
but I just haven't really been hungry
and then I don't get lunch break until
one
and
all I've been eating for lunch was like
a little cane of like tuna salad and a
couple of crackers
and then you eat to like at home soap's
on her way out to the club oh that looks
awesome did she say that you should yeah
I can show pictures of stuff soap's
getting ready to go to the club
okay
Gadget 3 said carrots make you see in
the dark Germans actually believe that
propaganda rules I remember hearing that
as a kid I think my grandma used to tell
me that
the carrots would make you see in the
dark
I mean they do have stuff like vitamins
in there that are good for your eyes but
they're not gonna like make your vision
any better really
and if you eat too many carrots doesn't
your skin turn kind of yellow or
something you've never heard of that
[Laughter]
I don't know too much big carotene
you're gonna like turn weird colors and
why not
I mean we might go to the club tomorrow
night right yeah maybe
I got paid today you just you probably
don't get paid till midnight though
let's see I can check right now that's
what I was looking for oh okay
because it's just I mean I might [__]
say [__] it and go but I'm kind of
sleepy you'd probably be sleepy I don't
know well like I said I got up at 4 30.
yeah and it's
that's the thing if we if we're gonna go
out on Friday night I usually like to
know before we do the show so I can wash
up and do makeup and all that other kind
of stuff nine now
yeah it's not here
so yeah it'll probably be here at
midnight
well I mean you know we could probably
go tomorrow because then we have time to
yeah we have time to do other stuff and
yeah we'll go in tomorrow
get ready what's going on
at uh barbarella's tomorrow
same as always
Saturdays would you want to go there
would you rather go to mannequins I
don't like mannequins on Saturday what
is mannequin Psych on Saturday it's like
Friday night but douche here douche here
like even even more normies yeah good so
you know and there's a lot of normies
there on Fridays so it's like that but
like all right 30 more normies so I'm
like no thanks I'd rather go to
Barbarella on Saturday to be honest with
you
if if we go out at all okay but you know
we got other [__] we got to do tomorrow
though yeah
she's living
well you know I didn't know if you
wanted to like talk about it or not I
don't care what you're talking about oh
okay you want to talk about well because
we mentioned it on Wednesday yeah but
tomorrow
I mean we don't know how we gotta see
how this goes but you know yeah
[Laughter]
you can talk about it
tomorrow me and Jen are going to be
doing some of our first porn shoots for
for the new channel that we're opening
up we're gonna open up [__] a new
Channel all [__] stream mate
which is going to be kind of like kind
of like this show right now but it's
gonna be [__] fetish oriented and
[__] all kinds of [__] could go down
and we're also gonna uh sell
videos
so it's professional amateur stuff we'll
see how they come out I want to see how
they're gonna be good they're gonna be
good
just uh the thing is is that it's gonna
that's gonna be a long time from now
because
there might be a couple months because
we have to get a back catalog
and when we
start opening this up we have to have a
lot of stuff to sell
um you can't just have like one video
you gotta have like several dozen
and then you want to eventually get a
backlog of about six months worth of
material so I know guys in the industry
and
talking to them seeing out what best way
to go and what platforms to use
because there's some sites that just
sell Pro-Am videos some of them can go
can be sold through streammate
but
we talked about it earlier on other
shows
Jenny got real spoiled about working at
home and um she doesn't really like
working a corporate job I don't [__]
blame her I [__] hate that [__]
and um We're not gonna stop 13 o'clock
it's just that uh we're gonna keep keep
it going it'll be even more fun because
we will have more stories to tell
but we're going to open up another side
business that brings more Revenue in
because we got bills to pay and 13
o'clock doesn't really pay bills that
well
books do and some of the other stuff
that Jen does that that pays but 13
o'clock really is because the algorithms
in YouTube this is just more like a
hobby for us
anytime we get a Super Chat of course
we're very
[__] uh uh thankful for that and
we're always trying to get more
um patrons patrons
oh because if it went down to zero we
would stop this show but it's it's
making enough to keep it open
just that it's not really paying for
things
well we had some other ideas man you all
know how we are
okay we're gonna do some creative [__]
because it's gonna have cosplay mixed in
with it it's gonna be fun I kind of
pictured is
um like this show but with the
possibility that some x-rated [__] might
happen yeah right that's kind of what I
would say because that sounds like fun
to me that'll be well that's that'll be
just on stream mate
yeah yeah because we're gonna do like
two phones I mean we're gonna do
streaming right and then we're also
gonna do video video and the videos will
be more artistic that's gonna have
that's gonna have like cosplay type
stuff and role play like I said I want
to see how they turn out because we
don't have like we have some lighting
but we don't have I need to get the we
got we get lighting and better camera I
gotta get a lighting and like I need a
better camera but you see
we're in a position where
that's like right up our alley because
we can do video editing and all kinds of
photo [__] shop touch-ups and
everything's highly talented and all
that
and I'm trained in theater
uh [__] I have all the [__]
contacts I got people in the industry
that can help me if we wanted to get
other people other girls in here I don't
know if it'll go that way because
we kind of wanted to stay amateur
we just have to see how it develops
yeah but her friend bill is like oh I
got all kinds of girls I can send over
there you know and tell you what their
rates are and everything and oh she'd
like this girl she loves to work on that
kind of stuff and but we'll see I mean
we'll see how it shows like I'm not
worried about it like right at the
moment because the whole the whole way
that we got into this and like talking
about this was because I just I wanted
this to like be a fun to like to make
money obviously but I wanted this to be
a fun thing that you and me could do
yeah like together if we eventually like
bring somebody else and that's fine to
you but it's like that's I'm not
thinking about that no right you see the
idea though is that eventually what
happens is is you want to be a producer
to where you're producing material for
other performers and that's where your
money's coming from
but the thing is is that you cannot
really produce material for performers
in other words back other
girls you can't bet
unless you yourself have done this kind
of stuff you'd never asked somebody to
do something you would do yourself right
and you know there's
a lot of these uh a lot of talent is out
there those girls barely can manage a
[__] phone a cell phone and no
laptops you know they're starting from
scratch they need support to get their
careers rolling if that's where you want
to put it and if you if they're going to
be cabin it helps if they have a bunch
of video behind them and
um
photo shoots and we've done lots of
photo shoots for goth stuff but they
need help they don't have the equipment
or the skills they can't do photo
touch-ups no photoshopping they don't
they don't they don't know any of that
and there's ways where you can make
money as producing this
well you know it's interesting I was
watching on YouTube there was like a
like a British News segment and it was a
year or two old but it was about a
couple that had started couples camming
during the pandemic because they both
got laid off and they were talking about
how much money they were making and they
kind of asked
um you know what their end game was or
what their dream was and stuff like that
because the guy I think like the the
host or the presenter was kind of like
thinking oh we'll go back to normal jobs
or whatever but the woman didn't say
that she said we actually eventually
want to open a studio for other
performers who can come in who don't
have a space to cam and like so they
wanted to do that as well so I thought
that was kind of interesting Tammy is
saying something about other people I
don't really you don't put out your own
videos they have to be leaked by someone
guys I guess so well the thing about it
though and I was you know we've been
watching a lot of other I mean there's a
good Channel on YouTube that's just
called cam 101 and it's like it's a
bunch of different people like a bunch
of different performers and stuff like
talking about their own advice some of
them are you know some of them are not
as good as others but there's like a
couple good ones on there that gave like
some good advice and stuff but
um basically they're kind of like well
one of the things that you have to well
like particularly with your video
content and even with your live
streaming content like you know someone
a bot or something like that is gonna
record that or is gonna you know yeah
right that yeah and is gonna repost it
someplace for free so they're like
there's really no way you can prevent
that like there's ways to yeah because
what you're doing is you're producing
more than more than they can copy and a
lot of that shit's you just you have
you're basically casting a very wide net
you're producing a lot of stuff so if if
some of the [__] leaks it doesn't matter
there's a small percentage of what
you've made yeah and I think that's
probably why you should just like focus
on making a lot of content I just make a
lot of content because then and the
thing about it is that what I was
thinking is that the market is so
saturated I mean there's just so much of
it out there that I mean the chances of
anyone stumbling across your [__]
specifically is like pretty slim and
stealing it and having it do it hurt you
in any way no that's what I'm saying so
it's like I'm not gonna worry too much
about that kind of thing and you don't
have to worry about security or anything
[__] because they can figure out who
we Who We Are and who our real names
were well that's the one thing like we
were talking about this because I'm like
well what can they do to us right well
because we were talking about it's like
well it's not like we're just like
coming out of nowhere like you know
people kind of know who we are and [__]
like that and I was like and I'm
thinking well am I gonna be bothered by
people I know or something like that
like coming across it and then I was
like you know what I don't no I don't
really give a [__] I don't give a [__]
I probably would have given a [__] when
I was younger yeah but I'm 50 now and I
don't really when you get to be our age
you just don't care that's that's really
the only good thing yeah about getting
old it's that has been like the one
thing that I've enjoyed the most about
getting all this like you just stopped
giving a [__] about anything and I'm
like that is so liberating yeah it's
very liberating it's all just fun and
games yeah and you're just kind of
because I thought about it I thought
about because you know some of the cam
girls that are younger and stuff like
that and obviously probably have like a
lot more to lose because yeah you know
what what if well what if they have to
go back to a quote-unquote regular job
later on and somebody finds it you know
on the internet and they're like oh
we're not hiring this person she's a hoe
or whatever so um so they have a lot
more to lose I guess but I think the
main thing they have to lose the young
ones is that they're what will this stop
me from being being able to get married
or will this affect relationships well
[__] at our age [__] no it won't
affect relationships well
no I mean I feel not nowadays no I kind
of feel like like I said maybe back in
the old days it would um you know and
maybe there's still like a little bit of
a stigma about it but I don't think that
there's as much of a stigma well like I
said it depends on your age
to a person in the 50s no it doesn't
affect your it doesn't affect
relationships if you're a girl who's
[__] 20 yes it would yes it would if
I can because a 30 year old guy wouldn't
want to marry you most likely well let's
say
some sometimes the guy that she wants to
marry wouldn't marry her
it's gonna be somebody else
because the average 30 year old dudes
not going to marry some chick that was
[__] gang banging dudes in the
[__] down [__] 200 [__] guys
you don't know he's not gonna do it's
just not in his it's not his makeup he
has other options he's going to go for
the one that didn't do that
yeah it's just how it is so yeah you'd
lose out the dating game most of those
girls that are doing that [__] are
single mothers or they're just broke
they don't have a choice there's no
other way although I have to say that
some of the some of the women that I was
watching that were like giving advice
and stuff like that on it they seem to
actually genuinely enjoy doing it yeah
which like I said about caming right
right I'm talking about camping the porn
industry well it's I mean camping is
essentially porn but I mean very a lot
of differences it's well it's not like
professional porn it's just no you know
there's big difference
in the porn industry you got to [__] all
these dudes
and Cami you don't [__] anybody you're
in your house by yourself
that's true it's just it's just well you
have a lot more control over that's kind
of the nice thing and that was one of
the things that appealed to me about it
is that you can essentially you have
complete control over what you will do
and you won't do yeah because like if
people want to watch you fine if they
don't want to watch you that's also fine
you don't have to
go to some studio and being like okay
well you have to do this that and the
other thing with this person that you
don't necessarily like or whatever and
it's like you have to do that for a
paycheck but when you're camping you
don't really have to do that you have
like a lot of our show will be probably
comedy and it'd be a lot of [__] uh
fetish like Dom type stuff probably we
just go we can go with the flow like I
said I kind of had a sensation that the
show would probably be like this where
we would like have some drinks and just
like [__] around and stuff but you know
but I don't know it will just like see
how it goes like I said it sounds like a
lot of fun to be honest with you like
with the more we talked about it would
be fun for us I don't think it'd be fun
for the average person
well I think it would upset them
well what do you mean by upset that
person couldn't take their clothes off
in front of somebody else eating the
camera
well to be honest I'm I would be kind of
kind of a doubt about it but I'm
not because
you're not like no one's in the room
with you it's just you yeah you know
what I mean it's just another show for
us right so it's like I don't like I
obviously like we you know we do this
show and it's like obviously I know like
all y'all in the chat are like real
people and stuff but we can't see you
yeah I mean it'd be different if there
was like a whole bunch of random ass
[__] standing around in the
room watching you yeah that would be
yeah different I would probably be like
I probably wouldn't be able to do that
but if it's just like words on a screen
and you don't see the person then it's
not you can just pretend nobody you guys
already know us a lot better than we
know you right you know that because you
guys have been listening to us and I
mean I'm fine with that yeah like I said
I don't I'm not a kind of person that
like really hides anything or
you know what I mean I'm just I just
kind of like let it all hang out there
yeah and everything's gonna be out in
the open
well there's gonna be links we're gonna
open up a new um
Instagram it's gonna have a lot of
[__] cool promotional photos [__]
Jenny [__] oh hi me [__] hot
it's going to have we're gonna do a
Twitter
that's going to be oriented towards the
thing Bill's going to send us a bunch of
[__] people through Twitter so that
that thing's going to be a cesspool of
[__] porn [__] people following
that thing uh and but then we're gonna
have links to where you can buy videos
uh we'll do custom stuff if you guys uh
you know if we have any freakazoids out
there that want us to do custom [__] the
idea sounds good but like yeah yeah
we'll do that I mean some [__] We're not
gonna do yeah like don't get any don't
get too weird yeah it's gonna be it's
gonna be fun it's gonna be good quality
and we're gonna be looking good in it
don't worry
DJ Maniac said I used to date a girl
that had an only fans account a few
years ago she was they may do it only
fans also well I mean yeah I mean we
might as well we open that up so we can
put some [__] on there too I guess what
if you can put the same video yeah you
can and I think as far as I know I have
to look into the legality of it but I
think you can put your video clips on
multiple sites you can stream live and I
and I think too that when you do live
streams like on stream eight or whatever
I think you can take clips from the live
streams and turn those into videos and
sell them on multiple times I heard
something a little announcing uh that
she was going to be streaming live on on
only fans
posted the time that she was going to do
it oh okay so I think you can I think
you can live stream through it too I
mean I kind of feel like yeah I mean
most most sites like that would have
like a live streaming option I imagine
but yeah so DJ Maniac is saying yeah she
was a hairdresser without a chair and a
single mom so I understood it work is
work yeah that's the thing and it's like
it's not really
and I liked um like I said if there's a
channel called cam 101 that's just on um
YouTube and there's a bunch of different
creators on there and they all give
different advice and stuff and just the
way they talk about it is really good
because it's just very
non-stigmatized they're just very like I
said it's a job just like anything else
you're just entertaining people you know
I would call it a job just like
everything else it's a job like a show
business job it's just well yeah but
that's what I mean it's not I kind of
feel like people make a distinction
but there's really not a distinction
you're doing essentially you're just
like entertaining people yeah well we're
we'll [__] we're we're entertainers
you know what I mean some people just
aren't entertainers but we're
entertainers we can do it well and see
that's what I was saying and okay so I
watched a video I don't I didn't show
you this because I just saw it like
earlier today like on my lunch hour but
I saw
um these two dudes I can't remember what
their [__] names were but they were
um they're a gay couple
and they do couples camping I don't
remember what platform they use
um but and they were super cute they
were like they were not attractive in
any way they were just they were mostly
like just tubby and nerdy and funny yeah
but um but they were like quite popular
just because they were funny you know
what I mean and they were talking about
um they really really liked caming
together because they said the the best
thing about that is that you know you
like if you're camping as one person
because I feel like it's pretty common
for like you know single like solo girls
like to cam that seems like the most
common thing but they're like well
couples is better because it's like you
know when you're just solo camming it's
like there's really you're very limited
in like what you can do it's like you
know you're bored you can you can play
with yourself and that's about it and
yeah and a lot of times like sometimes
because we've been watching a lot of the
stuff for like research and stuff like
seeing what other people are doing and a
lot of the girls that are solex you know
sometimes they're caming for several
hours you know because they're trying to
get tips and whatnot so but you know if
nobody's in their room or nobody's
talking to them like sometimes they're
just laying on their bed like on their
phone like playing a game on their phone
sometimes like they nod off and like
take a nap [__] like that so and I'm
like and obviously that's probably not
the best way to go about things but
these two guys were saying well when
you're in a couple you can always like
if there's nobody talking and the thing
you can talk to each other and that
usually stimulates other people into
talking to you and so you get like that
interaction back and forth and they're
like and there's a lot more stuff that
you can do you know to each other rather
than just like you being one person just
being do you know what I mean and they
said sometimes they bring in a third
person as a quote unquote slave
um you know they have a hot tub and all
this other kind of stuff so they can get
in the hot tub and do [__] like that but
it's like
um they were like super funny but but
yeah so they were talking about
they really liked
um you know just camping as and also
they were talking about I didn't even
know this existed until I started like
researching this kind of [__] but
apparently they have and I mean I guess
I should have thought about this but I
didn't really think about it but I guess
they have
um they have sex toys now that can be
you know remotely controlled you can
control them through an app
so a lot of there are some sex toys what
are they called
um [__] I can't remember the name of it
love sense or I don't remember what the
brand name is but they have ones that
interact with some of the caming
platforms so that people
you know in the audience wherever they
are if they have the app on their phone
and they tip you they can control your
sex toy like remotely so a lot of times
they'll be like hey I'm gonna give you
five dollars or ten dollars or whatever
and they can like turn the intensity up
on your [__] or whatever so they have
that
so this um so this one couple was
talking about they're like well we have
the app on each other's phones too so
it's like a lot of times like if we're
streaming and one of us like goes in the
kitchen to get a drink or goes to the
bathroom or something like that like the
other one will like start controlling
like some like remote control butt plug
or some [__] like that like from the
other room this is like you could like
hear them screaming from in there so
it's like a lot of people really like
that too so I thought that was like
really funny those two guys I can't
remember what their names were but they
were like super funny it's just on
YouTube but um
so we've been watching like stuff we've
been watching stuff about that like all
week long like trying to get some ideas
and stuff Kaylan Higgins says it's much
like any other content creator
find your Niche and keep appealing to
your Niche don't attempt to go
mainstream see that's what I was saying
because look the caming world it's
saturated like I said there's millions
and millions and millions of people that
I don't know about Millions but there's
a lot there's a lot of people doing it
like I said a lot of them are Solo
um girls but not all of them there's a
lot of variation in there too so I said
you know you need to do something to
stand out and even like a lot of the
um you know camming people that I was
watching that were giving advice they
kind of said the same thing they're like
you really have to
just be yourself and don't try to do
what other people are doing and don't
because you know if you do that like
it's just gonna get really samey and
like No One's Gonna notice you out of
the book because like I said there's
Millions so you really have to kind of
like I want to do some cosplay stuff
yeah I already got two bang costumes I
want to get her a Catwoman out a costume
that'd be cool use cat one I want to get
a [__] Klingon Warrior [__] outfit
yeah we got the cling on it yeah after
we saw that that Danzig wig back on your
forehead remember yeah the other night
remember Commander kirg
uh wasn't it Lloyd played it oh yeah
yeah Christopher Lloyd played him okay
remember how his girlfriend gave him the
[__] [__] to the Genesis device his
Klingon yeah that's right and [__]
and she goes and she goes she goes
you're gonna love it man it's good you
can see because you've seen it she goes
yeah he goes unfortunate and he kills
her
that's right yeah she goes yes my Lord
and my love because she saw the [__]
she she made sure that's how much she
loved him she made sure that the [__]
that that the [__] data was good but
look seeing it herself knowing that
[__] she'd have to [__] give her
life to that's that's a woman there he's
[__] and even Krug is like choking up
that's [__] that's unfortunate you
better not kill me for some [__] like
that
[Laughter]
that's some Klingon [__] right there man
yeah but uh I don't think I'd look hot
as a Klingon
have you seen that you see her yeah but
she had the [__] ringed hair like
that in the [__] uh I don't know
silver metallic dress and the low-cut yo
you'd be great cling on you think oh
yeah yeah you look great well she was a
Klingon civilian though she wasn't
dressed as a soldier with all the armor
she was just wearing a gown
yeah that's right vaguely remember she
had her hair all done
Krug had a fine woman what are you
talking about she was a civilian I guess
a spy
not not really a civilian
Oscar said Bane and poison ivy with the
red hair yeah a lot of people have said
that yeah yeah I should do poisonous
poison ivy yeah that's a good idea yeah
yeah I could get a poison ivy yeah I
think I could pull that off
let's see if I can find I mean we're not
gonna do whatever like I said most of
the time it would probably just be like
we'll be goth down but I would like to
incorporate some well the cosplay we
should do for video not right yeah yeah
not for a lot well yeah because that
might be a pain in the end yeah because
you can't edit it yeah like [__] might
be fine
I was thinking that before like you do
all this work on this costume and then
like you're trying to like do some [__]
and shit's falling off your head and
whatnot so
DJ Maniac said Tom the warrior female
Klingons from the Next Generation two
yeah yeah she'd look good at that with
the [__] with the cleavage action and
everything I was all right I'll look
into it I have um you can I like being
hot monsters that's like my that's
that's my yeah well that's that was why
I had so much fun with the Medusa
costume last Halloween because I'm like
I like and this year this Halloween I
think I'm gonna do hot werewolf yeah
yeah we were talking or hot Predator
yeah I can't I can't decide I can't
decide but I like I don't I don't like
to just be I've ever since I was a
little kid at Halloween I don't want to
be pretty I don't want to be a princess
or nothing like that I like to be
ugly but hot you know what I mean okay
look that's like my that's my perfect
krug's woman
let me see I don't even remember this
hardly like don't show it on the show
because we'll get like demonetized I
mean we'll probably get demonetized
anyway because we're talking about sex
toys and [__]
there's her right there let me see
oh that's right okay yeah I could total
I could do that look at her I could rock
that yeah yeah I can rock that
yeah how long would it take to do that
[__] hair though that's a wig
but look now I know but I'll dress up as
Krug look at Krug man oh my God that'd
be super fun I'll make that armor out of
leather because I got that leather kit
oh my God all the truck all the trekkies
yeah yeah yeah they'll be creaming their
jeans over that [__] yeah nice because I
want to make some Klingon armor but it's
gonna be leather
I got my leather kid in I do like that
outfit yeah
Oscar Perez says Jen B Bathsheba from
The Conjuring oh that's another good one
see I could think of like a million like
I said I want to stick with like fine
you know I want to stay in my wheelhouse
man I want to stay with like some horror
[__] and like [__] you know what
about what about Jen as a [__] Vulcan
Federation officer
see I wanna yeah I could be a Vulcan
having sex with a Klingon
Oh Daddy
[Laughter]
I got a dick like that yeah it looks
like a [__] Tusk or something
like a [__] big ass tentacle with
armor on it
see I'm liking this right now Jenny
loves it [__] Kiki [__] I did well
well like I said anything that makes it
fun it'll make it fun for me okay
oh and I just repeated myself back to
myself maybe the nun too yeah see yeah
that would be good too was the [__]
nun's name for something but they're not
from from uh miss 45 no no they're not
oh well that would be good too she
wasn't a monster she was just a person
but um
Gadget 3 said that you two do what you
do you both do it together and it's nice
as a viewer to see it see that's what I
thought I thought
well we'll make sure you guys know where
it all is where you can buy I mean like
I said don't I don't want to I don't
want to make it weird but it's just you
know what I mean like if anybody wants
to watch it but yeah
well I told Tom I was like look it's
like I kind of feel like the reason that
people gravitate to this show like
especially like the Side Tracks and
stuff like that is because of like a lot
of people have told me like we like you
guys as like interaction like you guys
are funny or whatever and I said I think
we could sort of like you know leverage
that in a new in the middle direction if
you want to call it that it's not really
a new Direction like I said for us we'd
be doing like the same [__] we're doing
right now except like I said it might go
like you know several steps farther
that's it but you know like I said we
wouldn't be doing anything we wouldn't
normally be doing if we weren't on
camera so so we're not worried about it
so I'm not all that worried about it
it's not like you're watching some 22
year old single mother taking advantage
of her [__] you know she's having to
blow these dudes for a [__] on video
to feed the baby that's not what's
happening see it's like I could not I'm
wrong we're growing people we have fun
with this kind of [__] we how to come
from a background of knowing [__]
porn people and fetish people this isn't
really that big of a deal for us we're
just we're entertainers we can do that
we can do what we're getting ready to do
it's just a different product we've
never sold before
and uh it's going to be our own products
you buy from us it's just it's gonna
we're gonna make Jen's gonna do editing
and everything we'll write scripts if we
have to for the videos or we'll start
off very basic I think first
but yeah because I can't really like
afford like wait we have decent uh like
lights and [__] like that now but it's
like I want better [__] like going
forward but you know we'll see how I
don't really care you know the camp
thing that's all cool and everything I
really look more forward to the video
because videos you can edit things and
shape and form something into a product
yeah and you have more control over it
and it's uh I think it's something more
you can be proud of
although I don't know because I'm just
saying that based on the way my way I'm
imagining it camping is something you
have to do it's right on the [__]
which has its own charge it's because I
really kind of enjoy doing yeah live
streams which is weird because when we
first started doing it because remember
we didn't do live streams until
episode 200 right that was like our big
special thing oh we're gonna do a live
stream and then we and then I liked it
so much that I'm like oh my God we
should do this all the time now because
you know I still do videos and stuff but
I didn't think I would like it because
I'm like oh my God I'm just gonna be
sitting there like a dork like not
saying anything
more experience [__] live streaming
being a stunt [__] I don't have a stuck
[__] yet you don't have to understand
yeah like a stunt man it's not [__]
right
gotta make sure [__] the [__] works
out
performance anxiety
well you just can't
I you just can't think you just gotta
get psyched up yeah I mean like I said I
mean the thing about it you are a lot
more well you're gonna make me another
can I make another drink yeah I mean
you're a lot more used to performing in
front of people and stuff like that
that's why when we initially started
live streaming I was it weirdly I still
get nervous sometimes I only get nervous
if I think I don't know the topic well
enough which I never think I do because
you guys know how I am but go ahead and
drink some of it before I take it hold
on
okay
but
over the um you know over the time that
we've been
doing live streams I've actually started
to really look forward to them and now
I don't know if I'd say I like it better
than doing video because I still do
video but
I don't know I like the interaction I
like the back and forth yeah it's kind
of annoying when we go up like on big
long tangents and I'm trying to get back
to the topic so the show's not five
hours long but I don't know I mean I
didn't think I would enjoy it because
I'm very introverted and I'm not you
know and I have a hard time
interacting and I you know and I just
always thought that I'd be sitting here
not talking and it would be like really
awkward and but I'm glad that it didn't
turn out like that so it might be like a
weird
and I was thinking to myself it's like
who is this person like now the kids
like we're talking about doing doing the
caming [__] and I was just kind of like
probably like five years ago I would
know I'd be like oh my God I would never
[__] do that but now I'm just like I
don't know it kind of sounds like fun
you know what I mean so I that that's
what I mean that's what I like about
getting older is that like I don't
really give a [__] anymore
you know if anybody sees it or I'm just
not bothered and actually it kind of
sounds like a good time but like I said
I don't it wouldn't sound like a good
time if like you said it was just I
wouldn't do it if it was just me I
wouldn't just be like a soul that
doesn't sound like any fun
um or if it was just I wouldn't do like
porn porn where I just like [__]
random people it's like I'm not doing
that that didn't sound fun either but um
but you know it sounded like something
that me and him could do that would be
fun you know so the fact that both of us
are doing it together that sounds fun
but I'm not
I wouldn't do it like if it was just me
like by myself because I don't
I'm not good enough with people
especially with
um because you know when you do camming
and it's kind of it's like this like
it's live streaming but you have people
coming in and they have
um I don't know like different platforms
have different things like some of them
have like different games like oh you
can spin the wheel and you know you pay
five tokens or whatever it is and like
you spin the wheel and like hey I'll do
this if you land on this or whatever
so it's like there's that kind of [__]
and you have people like coming in your
room and like asking you to do things
and like tipping you and stuff and it's
just like
I don't know I don't know how
comfortable I am doing that just
by myself you know what I mean but if
he's with me and he's there and you know
we can kind of have fun with it and play
it like I think it sounds like a lot
more fun in that you know what I mean
um let's see Gadget 3 said I downloaded
paranormal radio app and heard sweary
people and went from there
sweary people yeah I mean
I I can't really I can't really talk
without swearing at this point which I I
apologize but you know what I mean
Kellen Higgins said what's good is that
it's not corporate in any way it's total
self-proprietorship on your part yeah it
was just an idea that we had well
because remember on the show before we
were talking about we were just kind of
joking around about
um you know I don't I don't want to do
like porn porn necessarily but it's like
if it was just like a domination thing
where I could just like step on dude's
balls and stuff
um like I could totally do that and I
was like I was kind of joking but not
really
it's like yeah if you pay me to step on
your balls yeah I would totally do that
um but you know right because I'm kind
of I'm kind of a dick like that but um
well to me it's I think it's funny that
somebody would pay me to step on their
balls but um you know and I would
probably like get a lot of enjoyment
about making dudes suffer like that but
um so we were talking about that and
then Tom's like you know you probably
could do that and I was like maybe we
should do that I'm like maybe I could
make some extra money like you know
going and you know kicking people in the
middle she's got security I'd go with
her yeah I wouldn't go by myself again
murdered but you know what I mean I know
the platforms to do that through but
then was like he just came in and said
why don't we just like cam why don't we
just cam it's like then we can just sit
here in the house right and [__] around
right and people can just watch us do
whatever and it's like we don't have to
go any place and we don't have to like
interact with people in person well
wanna well when I first when I first
started the thought of it a thought of
us actually camming
as dominant as Doms because we can like
insult people oh yeah they come on and
people they have that would kind of be
rad too I don't know if I just want to
like focus on that though that [__] well
look man we got look you guys can't see
it I'm gonna show you the camera
we got a wall over here that is [__]
fantastic if we rearrange this [__] it
looks like hell
I'm gonna show you guys
background
oh you can't see it you gotta like it
can't see it no it's a it's a bunch of
like see him
those that's the curtains so they look
like something out of a damn funeral
Park I love those curtains all right
they're red well that's why I got them
right they're like haunted mansions all
right curtain what I got them on Amazon
what I'll do is I'll take that couch
right there
yeah a little couch over there you can't
remember move that right there
and we have a whole area we can set up
some lights
and you can do a fetish so there she's
got this satanic mirror right there
that's a mirror yeah do we have a light
no hold this for a second I'll grab a
light
he's making
I'm not pointing at myself why would I
do that
yeah it's like you're seeing parts of
the room you don't usually see
oh
there's that box I gotta send back to
[__]
use it
oh look there's the Pookie parking sign
there's my other computer
there's the bookshelf she was tearing up
that's the bathroom over there
I here I come he says all right okay
hold on
you hold it
that's the flat
that's it
see that's gonna make a badass set and
look I like you missed it but I have a I
have a little bitty lizard and a woman's
skin
like little poster over there
so that's gonna be the background
there's the mirror
it's like Satan's mirror right there
this place is [__] satanic looking
I love this room yeah
this is what it looks like
okay
there's a little piles toys back there
yeah there's cookies toys
that's her little toy pile she likes to
go over there and just like sit by them
and go look at all my toys this is
Jenny's desk yeah
oh no nobody's ever seen my my Anubis
yeah over here I got that from like a
local artist it's leather yeah hold on
oh there we go
there's Anubis and my profundo Rosso
poster or my Nick Cave poster my shining
poster yeah so this whole room is
kind of a
you're gonna get in big trouble and you
gotta put that back you got there's the
other room
bathrooms that's my Art Nouveau absence
set well that's not that's the dressing
room the bathroom is through that door
there hey poop yeah
there's poop
what's up poop
she's like why is this light on me right
now all right all right [__] that I'm
gonna put that back to she's not having
it
she's not having it
let's see if we can oh my
oh my God now we're never gonna get this
back to where it was before yeah it is
I can fix it I can fix it because I know
where Spock is I can fix it
there my dad's got a badass set of tools
my bad my dad's got a bad ass set of
tools I can fix it I can fix it
dude yeah we're quoting Fast Times
[Laughter]
I kind of feel okay so you got a worse
Pockets yeah and even the lighting isn't
messed up all right so we've seen that
it's cool that we're doing this and it's
not corporate yeah yeah they're going to
big studios you're just gonna did
you lose money
I mean there's no reason see that's my
favorite thing about the modern era is
that you don't really like all of the
technology and stuff like that is so
cheap if you know what you're doing you
can basically do all the [__] at your
house yeah
there was a I actually saw an interview
with a cam girl who was doing all kinds
of [__] she got made a [__] ton of money
on cam and she actually joined the
studio to make videos
and she said she loses money when she
does it
but she does it because she likes to go
through the whole ritual of getting the
makeup done and feeling important and
that it gives her I would like somebody
to do my makeup yeah and she says it
gave her street cred
yeah I guess free credit in the cam
world right yeah but still to me that
doesn't that's not worth it
having having to deal with
someone besides me and you is just
sounds exhausting yeah so no thanks we
can make our own product that's like
having a having a job and like yeah no
thanks and we can make our own products
we just work with friends and people we
know
so for whatever we make is going to be
it's going to be legit
it wouldn't I'm not going to call it
real it's going to Real Entertainment
though
well I mean we were talking about this
and I was just like we have to just try
to
make it as fun as possible like as
entertaining as possible and we have to
make it kind of like stand out another
thing I don't want to think too much
about it because I'll overthink it
because you know how I do nothing
another thing is that see we're gonna
we're gonna represent old people see
we're gonna
representing people okay because [__]
we're in our 50s we still look good
though all right we still look real good
and [__] we can we can deliver
although here's something that you guys
people don't know
a lot of those girls is [__] real hot
women we know some of them
they're claiming to be 30s and 40s no
their 50s
yes I remember like way older way older
than they say they are claiming yeah so
we're not the only ones that look good
in our 50s they got a lot of them
well and you know I kind of feel like
that's sort of a that's sort of a big
thing I I think there's a Miss maybe not
so much nowadays but I kind of feel like
there used to be a misperception that
dudes only wanted to watch porn of like
young women yeah but that is not the
case I mean MILF is one of the highest
uh searched terms for a reason yeah I
don't know who's searching it I think it
might be young guys it doesn't really
matter right but they just tend to be
popular there's a
on on a stream mate
there's a woman who claims to be 58.
she doesn't look 58 when you look at her
she looks but she does look like
somebody's teacher or somebody's mom and
she's like one of the Top Cab models
just totally like conservative normal
looking she looks like
and she just
brings over these other girls and has
sex with them
and some of them are in their 20s and
30s
although there doesn't look like there'd
be it doesn't look like there's a big
age difference between them but she's
like one of their top models
and it's obviously amateur it's in her
house
yeah but see I think a lot of that's why
they like that that's why they like it
that's what I mean it's like I'm not you
know I'm not a big porn connoisseur or
anything like that but because a lot of
it is not I mean let's be honest a lot
of it's not really made for women no
it's male oriented right almost all of
it so a lot of it is just like very male
oriented so to me it's just kind of like
you know but I you know I I kind of feel
like watching porn though
with you was kind of like
instructive because there's so much of
it out there that
you wouldn't necessarily think I don't
know like a lot of the corpority kind of
stuff yes yeah a lot of the a lot of
dudes don't seem to like that a lot of
dudes seem to like kind of amateur [__]
which I get because it's kind of like
well
you know the it's it's more illicit I
guess yeah because you feel like oh my
God I'm I'm doing something bad I'm
seeing somebody's leaked like here's
this couple that just like ooh we're
gonna film ourselves like [__] in the
car or whatever and then like it leaked
out or something like you're not
supposed to see it I kind of feel like
there's a little bit of that yeah uh
illicit nature to it that makes it like
hotter than something that was obviously
like oh we rented this million dollar
mansion and like everything is beautiful
and the lighting is perfect and
everyone's makeup is perfect and
everything like that which like I said
that's nice but it's kind of that's
right that's driven into the ground
right it's a there's a lot of that and
it seems like really stale to me I like
stuff that looks like it's made on
somebody's cell phone and they're doing
something they shouldn't be doing and
they somehow got away with it
you know what I mean it was maybe it was
in public or you know that you know that
the girl that's doing this is doing it
for the money
she wouldn't normally be doing it she's
uncomfortable doing it it's it's kind of
hotter in a way like yeah she's
desperate she had to do it there's just
something wrong that's that's kind of
funny something wrong about it well
that's what that one that I showed you
is kind of like that she's
she's she's doing it she's having fun
doing it but she kind of tells she
doesn't she wouldn't have done it under
normal circumstances
I think she's a stripper I know who she
is she's a stripper
well like you said maid that might be
part of the fantasy is that you're
trying to play into this whole thing
it's like oh I really wish I didn't have
to resort to you don't know it's real
right to porn but you know I need to
feed my kids or whatever you know what I
mean so maybe that's kind of like ooh
this [__] is like so desperate yeah
awesome yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but you
don't know it's true coming from me as
you know a mostly straight woman
is that I kind of feel like I enjoy porn
where
the woman looks like she's having the
time of her [__] life that's only in
lesbian porn
yeah well I do actually like a lot of
boys being important yeah well I'm well
and I like lesbian porn and I like gay
porn
I do I have seen some straight porn I
like but not a lot a lot of it is just
like you said it's very oriented toward
me and it's just it seems like it's
mostly focused on I don't know it's not
really focused on
like the women having a good time it's
just like what dudes want to see yeah
and it's like so to me that's like not
all that interest let's just beat off
material they're trying to get it over
with right right right
so it's just kind of like I mean well
that was kind of why like one of the one
of my favorite you know big porn stars I
liked Belladonna because you could tell
that she was into that [__] yeah she was
having a great [__] she's from Biloxi
Mississippi she was having a great
[__] time yeah you could tell she was
just like really into it and it was
mostly girl on girl she didn't she did
straight stuff too and now it was mostly
straight but it did she did have a lot
of about 50 50. yeah but she did a lot
of girl over girl too and it's like so
and I mean she was like really really
successful plus I always thought she was
like she wasn't
I don't know if you'd call her like
conventionally attractive but I always
thought she was like super hot she was
cute like she had like that gap in her
teeth and she was kind of like she's
kind of like punk rock looking she's got
yeah and it's just like kind of I mean
at the same time I was down and I'm kind
of more into that yeah she was hanging
out with the French Quarter the same
time I was but I don't know if I ran
into her or not because I didn't know
who she was during that time but I know
she was there during that time she was
from Biloxi
and I was uh well she wasn't from Biloxi
she was living in Biloxi because her dad
was stationed at Biloxi I think he was
in the Air Force right either Air Force
or navy
and uh
when she hit 18 she lived in that area
and then she was going to the French
Quarter a lot and then they were flying
around to certain areas and doing porn
with her
so she's going to the same Club as I was
but I don't remember
yeah
but she was just one that stood out to
me because she just looked like she was
having a good time yeah she looked like
she was doing what she exactly what she
wanted to do she didn't look like
because like a lot of straight porn that
I've seen is just kind of the women look
like
you can tell that they're just like
pretending that they're having a good
time being there they're just like Bella
was a nympho give me my check please
it's like this is that's enough of that
yeah but you know but yeah Belladonna
look like she was just like she was
[__] into it yeah and that's like way
hotter to me than somebody that's just
like collecting a paycheck it's like yep
getting rail bellies dudes okay it's
like let's wrap this up you know what I
mean it all a lot of it comes across
like that to me but like I said that's
why I kind of like
you know probably I don't know girl on
girl porn is good like I said I like gay
porn too yeah I think I think a lot of
straight women like lesbian porn uh I
think it's a it's a mixed bag
most of it is [__] fake as [__] is
terrible
well I just that's real lesbian porn's a
lot better where they're into it but
most of them are not into it and I've
heard
behind the scenes [__] that sometimes
the producers and the directors would
take two girls that absolutely hate each
other and make them work together
as like a joke in a certain way see
that's what I'm done
something like yeah they would do [__]
like that to him and uh but the thing is
is that they're not they're not gay
they're Straight girls Straight girls
they hate each other and they're making
them work together right they do that
kind of [__] because most of them are
straight
um but Bella was bi yeah definitely
she was into it well yeah she seemed
equally enthusiastic
um about dudes and women which like I
said I think I that appealed to me also
because she was just like man whatever
yeah which like I said I like that like
I said she seemed to like enjoy it but a
lot of times like I said straight porn
it just seems like the women are not
really
enjoying themselves
um you know so to me that's not but I
don't know like
the one of the it's weird because one of
the one of the most amazing things that
we
saw was not even
so much I don't even I wouldn't say it
wasn't sexual because it was but it was
these two
Tom probably remembers it better than I
do because we haven't seen in a long
time but it was these two women and they
were a couple
and their whole shtick was they would
they were Japanese I think
and they would bring in like white women
their whole you know they all their
videos were like this where like a white
woman come in and they would take all
her clothes and like just massage her so
there wasn't anything like overtly
sexual going on but then and then the
two of them like like I said there were
a couple in real life so they would like
start making out and stuff and then they
would kind of like do stuff to like the
the woman they were massaging and I'm
just like that that's kind of hot that
was kind of hot
but you know that's
weird how I don't know something like
that like seems like it wouldn't really
be all that interesting but it actually
was like pretty interesting you know
what I mean porn and Memorial yeah we
haven't really decided like I said we're
still
we're still in the preliminary phase of
research and
you know like I said we're gonna do some
um kind of experimental
photos and videos just to see what
everything looks like because like I
said I don't have
I need to get a lighting rig but I can't
really afford like I have a ring light
there but it's small and I so I need
like the big
ring light rig it's like two lights like
that go on either side of the camera we
probably need a better camera we also
want a camera that has like a bigger
um a tripod that you can like take off
easily that you can see you can do like
yeah like a 4k camera that you can do
like POV stuff with and with the 4K we
can run that for the show here too yeah
like yeah so yeah we want to use it for
this too I mean this camera that we're
using here
this is you know one of the this is like
the mid price yeah you know webcaming it
could do HD but it's not like Ultra
height right right right
um I don't even remember how much it
costs I think but it was like one of
these 70 80.
it might have been 90 or 110. I can't
remember okay but it would I mean it was
one of the better mid price
webcaming I mean there's better ones but
I don't I can't afford to like spend a
[__] ton of money you guys can help us
out hit us that thumbs up button I think
we only got one thumbs up of all things
that might be mine no we got a left we
got 11. I see it just I thought it was
one but I'm [__] timelined did you
really like our own video yeah yeah oh
yeah I've never been that lame I like
our own video from another account
I've done that accidentally a couple
times Yeah because sometimes I'm on
because I have
you know a bunch of different you know I
have
13 o'clock and then I have crime at
Memorial and I have scarce on so
sometimes if I'm like in another
Channel like all like a comment and I'm
just like oh [__] that was like yeah I
messed up but you know what I mean
are people still coming or they start
they stop commenting they're in there
they're not talking though
nobody's how long how long we've been
going for
two hours okay two hours and 17 minutes
also speaking of scare Salon I'm hoping
to have another scare Salon video up
this weekend I have it all written out
like planned out and everything like
that I just have to like
you know record it and edit it and stuff
like that but which I'm gonna do
sometime this weekend I'm gonna get back
to if you guys have been following over
there I've been doing uh my five
favorite horror movies from every year
since I was born so I'm up to 1980 so
that's going to be the next one that I'm
doing so I'm gonna put that up sometime
this weekend hopefully if I get a chance
to
I should have a chance to like do it
this weekend I think we'll have time it
won't take that long I got like most of
the hard [__] done like I said I read
all my notes out and all that stuff that
that's the part that takes the longest
to be honest with you
I'm writing all the notes out and all
that crap
but um but yeah
so
uh
uh what oh I don't know I was just like
reading everybody's what do they say
comments
Gadget 3 said if I can't smoke and swear
I'm [__] because we were talking about
he said that's how he discovered the
show he like down like a Paranormal app
and we were on there and he's like he
was easy we were on apparently these
swearing these sweary people and he's
like and that was like how it started we
we were on a Paranormal app I wonder
what that was
it could have been it could have been
any number of things yeah but well we've
been on a lot of paranormal shows right
and some of those shows like have yeah
have different connections right maybe
that's what it was through a third party
earlier we were guests with somebody
else maybe yeah
we used to guest out of the shows yeah I
don't know why we don't guest anymore
after after the pandemic a lot of that
[__] [__] just kinda
drifted away and it was also that
happened during a time when everyone was
new it was new channels asking us to
[__] guest with them
they probably have as many Subs as we
have now so they don't need us
yeah I don't know if we maybe we helped
them get up to because Spirit normal was
one of them that you used to ask us to
[__] guest with them all the time
yeah
where is Adam
I haven't heard well I haven't heard
from him in a while but we have been on
his show since we've moved here so it's
been in the last
few months of the last year or whatever
I'll contact Adam see if he [__]
wants to do a show
yeah we'll guest on his show again we
like to he probably just forgot about us
yeah he's been busy because I still
subscribe to him he's got a lot of good
[__] coming up well remember they did a
um they did a um was it last year or the
year before
they did like an online conference and I
did I did a talk at that yeah it was
like an hour long about those murders in
St Augustine yeah
yeah I gave like a whole talk about that
Oscar said Jen was The Exorcist on your
favorite five films for its Year yes it
was
um and then Oscar said I discovered you
guys through the Ed Lorraine video you
made okay yeah I kind of feel like that
was like one of our most popular ones
that one and uh the [__] uh original
Night Stalker video
yeah that was another one that was and
well we had like a lot of hits on it
before he got caught right because we
did a showing before he got caught right
and then when he did get caught we made
another one yeah like we did an update
and I called it I predicted everything
about the [__] when they call
and people were going Tom you predicted
everything about that dude that he was
military and a police and did yeah yeah
well yeah like just the tactics because
the attack either either a cop or a
soldier
you know what's crazy speaking of Golden
State killer and how they caught him
through you know uh you know genealogy
and everything I didn't realize until
I'd started
posting on my crime and Memorial site
um where I post new stuff on there every
day like I schedule new posts like every
week like for a week in advance
and I'm going back through all the cases
that I wrote about in my faceless
villain books and a lot of the
unidentified bodies that I wrote about
like back then in the books like even
well back then back in 2017 2018 a lot
of those people they've identified them
and that same way like through genealogy
which is awesome and I was like hoping
that they would use it for that so
they're not just using it to like catch
serial killers which obviously they
should be doing that but they're also
using it to solve all of these cold
cases because a lot of times I'll go
back and I'll be like Oh I'm gonna post
this on my
you know on my uh you know site this
week and then I'll go back and check
like for updates and I'm like oh my God
they identified that person that was
just like a Jane Doe or whatever and
they've identified her since then like
in just the last couple years so they
actually are using that for identifying
so they haven't like forgotten about
those people which I thought was like
really awesome
they have I was actually surprised by
how many people they had that I had
written about in my books just a couple
years ago that they had identified since
then so that's really cool
but yeah so you seem like you're getting
quiet no I'm getting drunk
[Laughter]
well that's actually I feel good if you
want to keep going you can keep going
just uh we've been on for two hours I'm
having a good time you had a good time
we're not we're not going anywhere look
if y'all you know we got people in there
if you all want us to extend the show a
bit just go ahead and drop a comment in
the [__] comment section if not we're
going to wind it down in a few minutes I
mean like I said we're not going
anywhere I mean and if you have any any
suggestions what you want to talk about
you know want to talk to us we'll
[__] we can move on to other subjects
or whatever
I mean it is a Side Tracks
and it is a chill [__] show getting
drunk ready for the weekend y'all didn't
go out we didn't go out [__] it we could
probably go out tomorrow we might go out
tomorrow right yeah
after after the photos after our porn
shirts
hopefully this hopefully this show comes
out good it's gonna come out good like I
said I already got a [__] already got
an idea of [__] well I'm not so
simple I'm not so much worried about
that I'm more worried about like
lighting and stuff like that because we
don't have like super good lighting but
we'll see how it goes I've already got
it oh you do yeah okay and it probably
during the day like I said we've been
like discussing this we're gonna do
simple [__] that uh it doesn't
necessarily have to be the first video
that we release but it's going to be the
first one we're going to record
yeah
we just had to start getting uh getting
a backlog of about six months of
material
well like I'm an initial blast when we
open right and then we have to have some
left over that can be released
you know every week
so you need quite a bit
but yeah I'm used to doing that yeah I
mean I mean I kind of wanted to I kind
of started doing that with my book and
movie reviews like getting a few weeks
ahead now I don't have time to do that
now I'm lucky if I get one put up a week
because I don't have much time anymore
but it's always good to have a backlog
of stuff it makes you feel like you
might be able to do two tomorrow
maybe two well we'll see what you have
in mind yeah we'll talk about it I think
I'll talk about it like I said well yeah
but we'll see like you know what we
should be able to get two outfit changes
yeah well now we can keep the same
outfit we just release it maybe change a
wig
or change of this and that we release
them at different times okay like a
machine yeah and we might be able to get
two
you know two 15-minute ones
okay some of it can be done with editing
yeah like I said if you send me the
footage and all right something you
could sell for 4.99 599 6.99 something
like that yeah two of them
and then we do this on a regular basis
start letting let them pile up
it sounds totally unromantic people but
you're making material
and I don't really do I don't really see
it that way like I said to me it sounds
like just a good time yeah like just an
extra like I said it's [__] that we
would just probably be doing for free
anyway yeah
that we weren't filming so you know what
I mean
it's gonna make us do it hopefully it
doesn't be like look you have to do this
now like oh [__] well see I was thinking
about that and it's like someone you
know because I was watching a couple
videos because there are like a couple
videos they're like giving so maybe we
should do that too like because I if we
get good at it like because there are a
couple
people that like give advice about it on
YouTube because you can do that on
YouTube as long as you don't get too
like explicit or whatever but make
videos on giving ungiven like advice
about it but yeah like some of them did
say yeah you kind of have to
compartmentalize like what is like work
related and what is just like you guys
you know what I mean because it's kind
of like which I can see that and I did
think about that but
I don't know I don't know well we're in
a relationship we can kind of blend it
it's just that we have to focus I don't
think it's going to be that much
I don't think it's good it's gonna be
all right of an issue it's gonna be all
right and we time it all right
[__]
costume and the [__] that we wear
[__] it's all going to work out
because we'll go out afterwards yeah you
know what I'm talking about [__] so
we'll start off easy
we'll start off real easy [__] we would
normally be doing [__] that's easy to
film [__] [__] close in outfits that
we'd normally be kind of wearing when we
went out anyway we might alter alternate
some stuff you know but yeah no it's
gonna be easy I got some ideas
that's good yeah
some of it could be freewheeling and it
could be edited into a couple different
videos
just at the sea yeah
I mean well always go back and fix
things and change endings there's all
kinds of stuff that you can do to change
the ending yeah you can change the
ending or add an ending Happy Endings
yeah yeah we can do all kinds of things
because that was the best that's the
great thing about video
yeah
right
I mean both have their charms I have to
say though
I like them both for different reasons I
did not think that I would like live
streaming but now I actually kind of
slightly prefer it yeah it's livestream
is fun
we love 13 o'clock we're not going to
step away from this channel we're going
to keep doing it no I never would
because like I said I have a good time
we're not gonna abandon you guys
all right [__] that's not the idea we
just need another income stream
we got a house pay for like I said yeah
we're just adding another yeah we got we
got untapped talents man
[Laughter]
well you know yeah
y'all are gonna see if you want to like
I said don't make it weird I'm just
gonna make it weird
from the kids and [__] I kind of have
that feeling yeah these aren't our
children I know but it's like
I know but it's like about potential
customers we got 17 000 of them
I know but I'm just saying I guess
because it's like in our 50s and it's
like I'm just like I mean I don't have
any kids but it's just kind of like I
get that it's like ooh it's like
watching your parents knows what's going
down and everything she's like look man
[__] because she's out right now [__]
she's gonna be checking up with me she's
at the club
up in Michigan she's like send me the
promo stuff I want to see you know she
just wants she doesn't want to see the
actual video
sexy teaser [__] the photos I said don't
send me a video though
yeah that would be weird because like we
know her yeah so that would be kind of
all that well I don't know it depends
because she's full she probably watched
that [__] anyway
well I was thinking about that I'm like
how well like which one of our friends
I'm not gonna name any names or anything
Scott would watch the [__] out of it
well that's a given uh and I thought of
that earlier too no I was thinking to
myself if it was me yeah like if I was
given the opportunity like hey you X and
Y of your friends yeah um you know they
made some porn like would you watch it
yeah and I'm just kind of like
most times no probably not but I don't
know like a couple of our friends well
maybe yeah you're a woman I would watch
all of my friends porn
well you would even the ugly people I'd
watch that [__] too
let me see this I want to see this [__]
I'll be [__] that's interesting not
watch everybody's porn that's
interesting yeah everybody
you would watch even the ugly people
Sports yeah yeah yo yeah yeah
to critique it maybe or to see how bad
give them some pointers
what you should look man
why the hell would you do that
I just don't take it personally you know
I mean it's just that's pretty funny but
uh I mean well no I'm not saying that
Dimitri you would watch
dormitious porn I'd watch Jaden Germany
Dimitri I hope they're not watching this
because I know Dimitri we were in the
[__] hotel room together
well no that would yeah I probably would
watch yeah yeah I probably yeah and
they'd probably watch they were watching
us they probably watch us yeah they were
already they'd probably watch ourselves
yeah but it's like well
yeah there's a couple people that we
know like couples that we know that it's
like if I was given that I was like yeah
I'd probably watch that yeah I'd
probably watch that
Jen's pretty
yeah yeah I would watch that yeah I
would like to see you know I'm the rule
like I said desk elements
elements
of an exception because like I said we
know they're friends of ours yeah we
know them and
some [__] went down at yeah in Tampa
yeah at the vampire yeah we were all
very drunk yeah and we didn't like we
were having sex in the bed yeah next to
them and they were kind of like why but
yeah but everybody was like super drunk
and it's like what you know so high five
and [__] to me so that was kind of
like a different situation but so yeah
so they chickened out
yeah they chickened out but yeah and
like I said they would probably watch
ours too but you know what I mean that's
like funny Tammy says uh does this mean
you're gonna quit your other job
um she wants to well I mean eventually
probably but well I don't know we'll see
how it goes we'll see here's the thing
the job that she has now she doesn't
like it I mean it's a corporate job it's
not right it's all right it's a
corporate job she's got to commute a lot
to go there it's bar we're gonna do the
other [__]
on top of this and see what the earning
potential is like
if it's good enough to where she can
quit that job we can do this other one
full time she'll probably do it
she wants to work at home she got
spoiled working home I mean working at
home is great it just is
well I've always been I I just like
being on my own schedule man I like
doing stuff when I want to do stuff
you know what I mean
um 13 o'clock will never die it says
Trey
yeah because Trey just got here and said
oh my God you guys are still here yeah
well like I said we're not going out
tonight so we're just like hanging out
with you guys
um
yeah Gadget says please don't as in quit
no I never quit doing this show I would
never quit doing this show he's talking
about my regular day job
um Trey says I know it's weird for a guy
but I just don't care about porn at all
no I know I get that I mean like I said
I don't watch it I've been watching it
lately because for research purposes but
it's not really anything that I sought
out so in a lot of ways I'm kind of like
deferring to Tom in this because I'm
like well you know you're a straight
dude so you know what the market is and
you know it's just like you know because
I'm not really like all that interested
in it
so I like now I'm not gonna lie I like
and I think this is true of a lot of
women
um if women are gonna
consume quote-unquote porn it's usually
going to be erotica like written erotica
because then written erotica is huge
with women audiences and I think it's
because women like to imagine dudes are
maybe like and like I said this is a
generalization obviously but dudes are
generally more visual
so they like to see some [__] happening
in front of their face and I think that
women are more
and I mean at least me and like most
women that I know that I've talked to
about this kind of thing it's like
usually you like to just be able to read
something so you can imagine whoever you
want or yourself or whatever like into
the situation you're not seeing
something already made like in front of
you it's like you don't have to have
those people
in front of your face you can imagine
like whoever you want so oh so women
usually generally will prefer written
erotica that they can read and imagine
whatever they want the female nervous
system is not as visual that's what I'm
saying it's a lot more internal and the
sex is very different to be honest like
a lot of straight porn comes across as
very
um what's the word I'm looking for uh
clinical yeah I can understand just in
the sense that it's very like here's a
huge butthole and I'm just like okay
you know what I mean it's like that's
not like sexy to me but okay
you know you know what I'm saying yeah
the male sex drive is very linear it's
you're trying to go straight at it
there's this big [__] build up to it
there's a climax and then it's Falls
that's it it's over right it's um
it's a drive almost like hunger
with women it's more like a mood it's
it's like a wave of things that they
swim in and it's just it's not they can
go through multiple orgasms and they're
not quite like a man's orgasm they're
just these [__] which I can
understand it it has a lot to do with
hormones
that's progesterone and estrogen doing
that and me [__] around with my own
hormones you know what I mean with tread
and [__] and been loaded with
progesterone I've had
estrogen a lot or methyl estrogen when
you're taking Diana ball so I understand
what they're what the female sex drive
is like it's very different
in the male sexual like I said
um it's a lot more complicated it's a
lot more
and I'm it's kind of ambient it's in the
background it's swimming around its
situations yeah it's it's it has more to
do with feelings and emotions the male
sex drive is not like that's a lot more
primal
simpler
um they're both good they're just
different I don't want to say one's
better than the other uh but I
understand the difference yeah like I
said so the porn is going to be a lot
different women it's more situational
[__] reading psychological imagination
man it's more like how it looks what
happened I like to imagine stuff yeah
that's why I think that's why a lot of
women don't really consume porn or don't
really like and I'm not saying that
because a lot of women do watch porn but
um
because collagen what they're doing when
they're seeing that they're seeing and
imagine right but I mean when you see it
in front of your face it's kind of
locked in you can't add yourself into
the situation you know what I mean I
kind of like
reading it because then you can imagine
whatever you want yeah the woman porn is
romance novel that's a female coin
although I don't really like romance
names either in general though that was
it right that was it I just got my
grandma's house and [__] and they're
getting romance novels everywhere and I
was yeah kid I didn't realize this is
[__] porn essentially it is this is
female like I don't like them yeah but
women did but women do like that I don't
like romance novels I do like erotica
though no that's two different things
I've heard younger females today they're
a little bit different because they grew
up with access to porn that they get
some of the same
things out of porn that they used to get
it in they used to get out of
erotica
so maybe they've changed a little bit or
tasted well nowadays the thing is since
porn is so ubiquitous
um you know you can find something that
appeals to your particular Niche so if
you are a woman that is into like
watching porn you can find like woman
produced porn that is more
suited to your tastes perhaps I have
seen porn that I liked yeah you know
what I mean some of it produced by women
some of it produced by men but it's like
you know and I was saying like how
sometimes you watch porn and you like
find something that you didn't really
think would be hot would be hot like
those two Japanese women that like
massage the white women yeah and also
that one time that we came across the
whole sub-genre of like lactation porn
yeah yeah and that was something that
like never occurred to me yeah but I was
like because that is also kind of hot
like weirdly yeah like that was
something that I that I never thought
Japanese the Japanese massaging the
white girl porn that was I still
remember that the reason why that was
hot is because
those two girls were a lesbian that's
yeah and I said that I mentioned that I
was talking about it while you were in
the bathroom and I said I think that's
probably why I liked it because you knew
that the two of them were together in
real life the two Japanese girls were
let were a lesbian couple the the main
girl was like a lesbian rights activist
in Japan back in the early 2000s that's
because that's an old video
and uh they liked white women and they
would they made it had a whole video
series where they would pretend to be
masseurs in a [__] Japanese massage
spa and these blonde white girls and
they were porn American porn stars
um I don't remember the names but
they're you know slender big tits that
kind of [__] and they would come in to
get the massage and it would start off
as a massage it would slowly escalate to
like bubbles blowing on them and it was
inventive [__] but it was definitely
female
Orient yeah see I liked that it was hot
very hot yeah and it was a very long
scenes
where there was no real spike in [__]
descent in it which is the male pattern
of right building up and coming it was
it was more of the floating kind of a
right thing which is more the female way
but even as a guy I was admit that's
[__] hot because those girls are into
that
that's what I mean see and that's what
yeah I feel like when I mean me
personally I'm not speaking for all
women obviously but
um for me personally if I'm watching
porn it's a lot better if the women look
like they're super into it yeah you want
another drink yeah what's the time I
mean do they deserve more time do you
all deserve more time come on we're
having a good if y'all want some more
time I'm gonna drop us a Super Chat I'm
gonna get some drink anywhere you know
I'm coming back you know yeah it's like
what are you gonna do cut me off
[Laughter]
I'm not going anyplace
it's Friday night yes I've been up since
4 30 this morning
it's fine it's fine I'm still awake but
yeah um
yeah I don't I don't know I I just kind
of feel like that's I think that's why a
lot of women don't like
straight porn it's just because it's you
know very oriented toward the dude and
like I said it's very clinical like
there's a here's a close-up of like you
know this giant gaping butthole and it's
just like
okay
you know what I mean it's just like
that's not particularly hot to me it's a
little like I said it's a little
clinical so that's but the whole thing I
like and I think that's why a lot of
people like amateur porn too is because
you're watching
I you know I like amateur porn because
you're watching a couple that would
probably [__] in real life
you know just [__] on camera I don't
necessarily want to see like
professional porn it's just like here's
somebody that was paid to [__] this
person and that's you know they're not
super into it I want to see people that
are like really really into each other
you know what I mean so I like seeing
like real couples or like people that
are like really into it
so you know that's that's kind of the
whole thing uh Camp guy said POV
[__] very male oriented yeah that's
you know in that like I'm not [__]
on it so like I understand that it's
like a different thing and it's like but
it's to me that's like not
it just doesn't do anything for me you
know what I mean like seeing these
close-ups of [__] do that as much as
they used to yeah and I don't and I
don't because the 80s and 90s things
right I also don't really particularly
like the the [__] that's like because
there's a lot of straight porn that's
like um
you know I don't know like making it was
like Hey choking my dick and all this
other stuff I don't really like that
either
like and I'm just you know it's like I
feel like the the women maybe they're
into it or whatever but it's just like
it looks like they're not having a fun
time and
that just kind of killed it for me to be
honest I just you know
Oscar says you guys should swap with the
demetrical
I don't know they they might be down I'm
not wrong I'm not entirely sure like I
said they might be watching so I don't
know so I know like every now and then
um every now and then Dimitri does turn
up in the chat because I know he does
like listen to the show but we kind of
like tease him about it
but he's gonna he's gonna be watching
this [__] if we ever put some stuff up
we'll see like I said we're gonna film
some [__] tomorrow
we'll see how it turns out I'm worried
about the lighting situation I'm worried
about
but you know Tom said he's got ideas
we've been talking about this for
the last week or so
and we've been doing like a lot of
research and stuff so we'll see how it
goes
I'm just hoping that
I don't know I have I have money to get
the lighting rig but I don't have money
to get a new camera right now we need an
HD camera
but we'll see how it goes I really do
want that lighting they have it on
Amazon for
I think it was 111.
for the um
it's like they're not ring lights but
they're like the big
filming lights there's like it's a set
of like two of them and they go like on
either side of the camera so
that seemed like the best option and it
was recommended so we'll see
Ben says research no yeah I know I know
but it was actually we were actually
like researching Tom kept sending me
he's so funny because he'll send me like
all these porn videos over like Facebook
messenger and he'll send them to be like
I'm at work I'm like dude you know I
can't watch these right no I just
actually I just didn't like book Markham
so we could watch my glasses I don't
know
what was he saying
he was he laughed because he put like
research quote unquote about watch
importance there's product research
well you know I was interested yeah no
you got to look at what's in the
background you understand what camera
this was yeah I was interested how many
[__] camera angles changed during
that scene there's a lot of [__] that
people don't [__] pay attention to
hold on well DJ Maniac made a funny
comment
oh he said I'd watch it not gonna lie
who Maniac yeah
you do Maniac you need to come in when
we're
live
on the gold show we'll do like an hour
gold show me and gentle just tear it the
[__] up and see when you on a gold show
you can send audio messages just [__]
hit the damn microphones and Tom as flip
her on over okay hold on let me flip her
over
and then he says but I'm also at the
point where I'm watching porn for the
set design and cinematography
well that's kind of what we've been
watching it for like the last couple
weeks or so because once we came up with
the idea we were like well
you know we want to do our own thing but
we want to see you know I want to do
like I said some market research I want
to see what's successful I want to see
what other people are doing that's
working out like what do they you know
like he said what are they what do they
have in the background like what are
they saying what are they what angles
are they using what you know how many
cameras do they have like all this other
kind of stuff so because we need to know
like all the technical [__]
um so our [__] can be good but so we
have been kind of watching it Bill said
he could come and film anything we
wanted to for a hundred
with his [__] 4K he's got a [__] 3
000 camera really does he have does he
have a lighting rig or no yeah he's got
all that and he's uh on the other side
of Orlando
so we can get it professionally filmed
bill could come over and film it he'll
probably bring his girlfriend or his
wife
but uh I wouldn't mind meeting her
you saw her
yeah you showed me yeah she's the one
that she was at the rent we got pictures
that we're at the rent fan Renaissance
Fair yeah she's uh her name she's a
poorest star named Amy Quinn you can
look it up two two ends
and uh her husband he's a friend of mine
yeah he's been like asking him for
advice and stuff like what what happened
with steroids he's helping me with porn
well yeah I mean he well we were asking
like what are the best because there's a
million different like camming platforms
there's like there's ChatterBait there's
um you know so we were thinking about
starting with that one but
then like the more we looked into it
like well ChatterBait seems good for
having sex in public that's what that is
right and well for like a larger
audience but they're like well it's not
as it's not a paying audience moderated
and it's not yeah a lot of people are
gonna just like watch it for free and
stuff like that like yeah you can get
like 4 000 people or live but most of
them are not paying any stream mate or
live Jasmine those are the two those are
the two of the best ones another one I
looked at was called um
sext with a t sexed Panther yeah I've
heard of that one yeah you have to watch
because you get 80 of what you earn on
Sex Panther oh we'll see that's good
it's because instead of 45 yeah because
I don't know if you guys know but a lot
of the Canon platforms like they take a
percentage and it depends like you know
on the platform like whatever they take
65 right but it's a tight platform and
there's good traffic there and everybody
on it is a paying customer
so most people end up making more on it
yeah most of the cam girls that I was
watching that were talking about being
on streamate they said well they started
on ChatterBait but then like they which
was okay but then they moved over to
stream it which was more like quality
over quantity kind of thing yeah where
you're gonna get fewer people in your
room but they're all pink but they're
all paying where is it on ChatterBait
you're gonna get like 4 000 people but
only like a couple people are tipping
yeah 4 000 people watching and four
people are paying right so it's just
kind of like and it might as well be
[__] outside right and I kind of feel
like well streamate seems like people
are more satisfied with it in the sense
that it's more moderated you don't get
as many weirdos you don't unless trolls
right you like
I did an account just to go through
there and feel with the experience of a
customer was like I felt like I was
being watched and it's easy to get
kicked out of a room it's very [__]
tight but that's a good performer is
that yeah yeah maybe not good for
customers you're not really in public
we're looking at it from a performer
point of view it's like we I don't
really want something that yeah you want
to make money but you don't want a bunch
of like random [__] coming in there
like not paying and just like you know
abusive comments and [__] like that you
don't want I'd rather work in front of
four or five people and we made a
hundred dollars or two hundred dollars
in a [__] in 20 minutes 30 minutes so
that's you want that and everybody happy
they're all going to come back
yeah I would rather that than have like
a bunch of random ass people that aren't
or they're just like making [__]
supposed to be good for for cut for
regulars regular customers the the
customer
um
what they call it customer loyalties a
little higher
on stream bait
because you can talk to them more and
they're vetted everybody in there that
you're dealing with has a credit card
and they got my
they've been spending
I wish they had a ranking system so you
know which members how much money how
much money members have spent
yeah
that way you know who you're talking to
because they have some dudes in there
that are [__] huge Spenders
guys that are just addicted to that it's
like a casino to them
Rich guys who are married and that's
what they do they just get on streaming
well the thing about it I kind of feel
like and from what I could determine
like a lot of the demographics of dudes
that go to those sites
is that I kind of feel like people have
a perception it's like oh it's losers in
their mom's basement but most of the
time not they're like usually it's you
know working class dudes or it's older
married dudes that aren't getting
they're not getting by their wives yeah
so they're just like you know a lot of
guys and they're beef and the thing
about it and a lot of the you know cam
people like what because I watched um
like gay couples I watch Like solo cam I
watched like a trans woman
so they were all talking about like
having channels on there and they were
like basically
um most of these people mostly what they
want is like companionship they want
somebody that's like gonna talk to them
and hang out with them and be interested
in them and [__] like that and honestly
most of the stuff that I saw they said
yeah it's about yeah maybe 10 sexual 90
of it is just like talking like what
we're doing now because it's like most
people they're just kind of lonely Oscar
knows who knows who Amy Quinn is yes
it's a cute ginger that's her yeah he
showed me some of her um scenes that she
had done I'm friends with her husband
yeah yeah
but um yeah she is super cute
but um she's got two kids
yeah they made they made good money
that's what they they have their own
studio and they uh a lot of connections
and
poor bills on Trend right now he's
[__] burning off a bunch of fat he's
on Trend and I said [__] you need to
come off soon he's like yeah I'm gonna
come up with me he says you're getting
cucked out and he goes yeah is he making
his wife suffer yeah yeah a little bit
because I nearly beat a [__] up
just for looking at me and I said yeah
yeah it's about time to come off see
that's not good stuff to be on seriously
right and he was doing a series he was
doing a BBC series where all these
[__] black dudes with big old dicks
were [__] [__] down his wife and
[__] and I said are you getting cucked
out yet he goes it's starting to get to
me that's you need to come off Trend
dude
[Laughter]
well that's kind of like the that's kind
of like her whole shtick isn't it that's
good no that was the thing that that was
recent she was just regular I thought
that was like her Niche no that's
underneath no black dudes aren't
underneath that was just something that
was recently [__] they got her that
uh where she did like four of those
recently okay because that was well I
just thought that because that's what
you shared no at all yeah because it all
happened recently oh okay I got you like
four or five guys recently did that I
it was a series they put out
gadget3 said catch you all next Friday
tnj thank you very much love oh we love
you too I'm glad you came by thank you
for stopping by
um Ben says apparently there are some
scams where predatory sites just copy
our stuff and post it themselves for
less money yeah I've heard about that
and like I said um there's ways around
that yeah there are and I was watching
some other videos and they're like look
there's really no way you can avoid that
entirely that's just gonna happen but
most of the time if you just put up like
a lot of content yeah it won't matter
I'm gonna you talk you gotta pee they
can a robot can come and steal live
shows from you that's just one of your
live shows if you have a bunch of
material out there it really can't put a
dent in you and the places that are
putting out for free they're harder to
find
and
video material in itself is more kind of
like uh you can make income off of it
but a lot of it has to do with street
cred and advertisement
um
it is good thing about it is that it's
residual it's something you did and it's
in the background making money so it's
just a residual income
main income is live streaming
live stream makes good income
I mean
you can make a couple hundred dollars a
night pretty easily only in a few hours
depending on what your status is on them
we'll see we'll see
maybe access was it BBC one two or three
or four or BBC America it was just the
BBC man you ought to know you're
carrying one around
[Laughter]
she was on that beat they did a whole
BBC series dude where young Ginger girl
jumping up and down on it as hard as she
could
okay
Ben's talking about apparently there is
some uh scams or predatory sites just
cup yeah okay you already read that yeah
yeah
he's back let me go the restaurant
oh I guess talking about porn is like
the way to go
um
foreign
BBC One or bbc4 or BBC America Woody um
I don't know if you're asking about the
[__] that I saw on YouTube it was on
[__]
it was like a morning show
and I don't know I haven't been to the
UK in a while so I don't really know
it was like an older dude and like a
younger woman
like the presenters
and they were I was I think it was from
like a year ago and they were
they were actually like pretty cool
about yeah they got a little bit like oh
hey tit or titter but not as bad as I
was like expecting I thought they were
gonna make like a big Jerry Springer
deal about it but they really didn't
and Sheppard just got here what porn
yeah you missed the whole discussion
uh I was cracking at what time used the
abbreviation for oh okay I gotcha
finally happening yeah you know I mean
well you know we'll see we're
we're probably gonna do it not 90 we're
gonna do it but
like I said we're gonna film some test
[__] tomorrow and see how it turns out
I might need to buy some new equipment I
definitely need new lighting I
definitely need new
maybe a new camera
and we'll see how it goes we have to set
everything up
in a way because I want to like make it
different than this I want like a
different background and so we're gonna
like set it up on the other side
of the room so really have like a
different background
uh oh I see what you're saying oh
because BBC in the porn industry is very
different yes it does yes it does so I
wonder if like
the BBC in the UK if they're like God
damn it
now our should be it's big black [__]
yeah yeah what do we do the thing is is
that BBC is full of [__] anyway they're
charging people for [__] charging
people for regular TV content they don't
need to be interviewing me because like
that's the first thing I do is like wait
a minute hold on y'all at the BBC y'all
know what that means right [__] I
would come at him that way like well
whoa like I said what do you mean and I
would just say immediately y'all are a
big black [__] that's what you all are
but see I think and I ain't seeing any
dicks where the [__] what the [__] yeah
where are the [__] dicks
I would [__] the BBC up man I mean
they'd have to [__] if they'd be fair
live they would have to change their
name when I was done with them I'd drive
them [__] insane with that to be fair
I think the big black [__] uh
acronym came about after
yeah
yeah the people that made that up didn't
know what the BBC was [__] man it's the
thing is though is that big black [__]
is bigger than the BBC now so BBC means
big black [__] I don't give a [__] come
on
and well here's the thing though like
Tom you are a porn connoisseur yes I'm a
student I'm a student he is
however I honestly I'm coming across
like new uh acronyms like all the time
and I'm just like what the [__] does
that mean yeah well there's like new
[__] you have to keep up oh yeah you got
to keep up with [__] you really have to
keep up with all the new acronyms
because I see some acronym and I'm just
like what wait what does that stand for
you know what I mean you have to like uh
keep up with all of it
mm-hmm
uh yeah Jeff I was laughing because Jeff
here I said I just got here what porn
yeah he missed a bunch of [__] you miss
all the porn
yeah we're gonna do some well I'd you
know I don't want to say we're doing
porn because it's not it's not really
porn
it's not really important I mean it is
kind of important but not but it's with
us right real porn is you [__] all
these other [__] and me [__]
all these other movies that's not that's
not really the same
that's true we're pro-ams
we're professional amateur like I said
not limited we're not doing anything we
wouldn't normally we'd be doing anyway
for free right yeah not on camera but
we're just doing it on a camera that's
all
which is not exactly porn but it kind of
is porn
Trey said you guys got a lifelong fan in
me oh that's awesome thank you very much
bro
Camp guys that I like to read Penthouse
forum
if you do when I was
I know this is weird but
when I was younger
uh my dad I think used to get Penthouse
and he used to hide him but he didn't
hide him that good so it's like
so every now and then I would find one
just randomly
and some yeah some of that [__] in there
was like really [__] weird
the penthouse for him I kind of feel
like he more had to like Hustler and
[__] like that he had like the dirty
[__] he had Playboys too but
you know you can always lie and say you
know what I mean okay I don't know if
I've told this story before this is
super funny I don't remember this but my
mom told me this later on
she said when I was younger I don't know
how old I was but it was young enough
that I don't remember
I found one of my dad's
I guess it was a Playboy maybe it was
pen Penthouse I don't know
so I found one and I was like oh what's
this and I was like looking through it
and I guess my mom caught me like
looking through the [__] well I didn't
know any better I was just kind of like
whatever it's it was in my dad's drawer
or whatever
and [__] and then my mom said I pointed
out the picture of the of the busty
naked lady yeah and I said well I look
like that when I grow up you wanted to
and my mom said to me but my mom is
Awesome by the way she said if you're
lucky
that's what she said to me if you're
lucky you're lucky yeah
I was like well I wasn't but thanks Mom
but yeah it's just that's like that
probably hotter than she is now that
makes me laugh that my mom said that to
me when I was like little if you're
lucky you'll look like that when you
grow up
I love that story and like I said I
don't remember that happening but she
told me that it's good
that I found my dad's porn magazines
oh my God
what are we doing now no nothing
I'm getting reports back from Sophie
when she she's at the club how's it
going it's going okay what club is she
at she's up in Michigan at the golf club
there with her what's it called uh let
me see which club it is I'll ask her
with her ex she went with her ex no she
met her ex there he's oh making sure
she's okay because it's in a rough
neighborhood down in Detroit
well that's nice and she said he's being
good and they're just friends
and that [__] she's okay it better
stay like that yeah we're gonna say
we're gonna say I mean not like well we
do the same thing or you know that we're
friends with our friends in the scene
and and then she and he says we have to
learn to co-exist in the scene
that's that's well that's the deal
ask ask your boy
that's one of the things yeah you have
to learn to co-exist in the scene the
god scene is all right small right and a
lot of us have I mean whatever City that
you're you know the deal maniac right
yeah DJ Maniac knows yeah whatever City
you're in and I'm sure like he's in New
York city so it's like larger but it's
like whatever City you're in the scene
is like not huge so a lot of times
um a lot of those people will have dated
one another at some point or another and
maybe have had acrimonious breakups and
things like that so but you still want
to go out to the clubs and it's like
this there's this whole Minefield that
you have to navigate it's like well I
want to go to this club but this
[__] might still be there and
it's like what if there's issues and
blah blah so it's like you have to do
that
and it's you can't avoid them because
the scene is small right so I mean we
ran into an issue I'm not naming any
names and don't you name any names
either because I know how you do
but it happened a couple we were not
there but we heard about it oh yeah I
know exactly later on you know what I'm
talking about week and a half ago a week
week ago where
like I said not naming anything I'm
trying to say vague so I'm not like
outing anybody yeah but there was a
situation where there was a couple that
we knew and they were together a long
time but they've been broken up for a
very long time how many years have they
been broken up I don't know two no it's
long it's been longer than that she is
engaged to someone else now
and
um she's a MILF and she's hot with a
younger guy she's about my age maybe a
year or two yeah and her her new man's
probably 30 something
and um her ex is a friend of mine he's
my age
I'm actually friendly with him but he
just can't let the [__] go and I just
can't and it's been years and years
and apparently there was an altercation
like I said we were not there but we
heard about it we heard all the details
about it the following week
um where uh
there were fisticuffs yeah
to you know evidently faces were bitten
it was only dude that got knocked out he
knocked [__] um he knocked him out
yeah he knocked Andy's boyfriend out
you said that he liked it oh sorry
I can't trust you to do anything can I
it was just one they don't know who that
is
yeah so there was a whole thing I heard
that on the second I didn't know hear
that at first I heard that later and I
was just like damn
but he's bad now he can't come back
we'll see how that goes well yeah the
dude that tackled me supposedly got
banned too and yeah a week or two later
he showed up again and nobody said eat
the [__] out of that [__] if I
see you we haven't seen him since then
but I'm gonna beat that [__] up
he's gonna call me Daddy when I'm done
with him
well I mean I feel like I should
probably get first crack he's gonna call
me [__] Daddy can I have first
cracker yeah yeah yeah okay thank you I
heard him I heard him back I would
actually like to have a crack at that
and then if there's anything hands on
Jenny if there's if there's anything
left I'ma beat that dude then you can
have him
if there's anything left after I get
done with it already beat him up and
then when I [__] let him go because I
got tricked into letting him go and he
started grabbing her and beating her up
and then I had to [__] and then
before I could even
divide him the whole crowd pulled him
apart but if I see that dude again I'm
gonna [__] hurt him I'm gonna hurt it
I told him because he's not allowed back
I was just standing there I wasn't doing
anything all I knew all of a sudden was
some random [__] just like
tackled me to the floor the debt is
unpaid
okay like I said I was so shocked I
didn't know what to do for a second
because I'm like why am I suddenly on
the floor with this random dude like
wailing on top of me okay and then so I
said well
um
the first thing I thought of was thumbs
and eyes that seems like a good thing to
do so I so I started doing that and then
everybody just like pulled him off yeah
dude thought he was fighting me
that's how much I [__] him up [__]
him up so bad that he grabbed her and
thought he was fighting me and I
couldn't get to it was because
a friend of mine named Pogue
slipped up on me when I had him I was
beating him [__] and she slipped up
on me she goes with a soft feminine
voice she goes let him go Tom let him go
and I let him go without [__]
question and he quit attacked her I
shouldn't let him go I just should have
beat no I mean he didn't know what he
was he didn't know it was you but I
should have just beat him into into
unconsciousness I just didn't know what
was going on because like I said I had
told you too like I saw like Anna and I
saw her talking to you and I was like
yeah just like [__] leave it it's not
worth it and then all of a sudden the
dude [__] tackled me I'm like what
the [__] did I do I was just like
[__] standing here I didn't have
anything to do with anything
so you know what I mean all of a sudden
I'm on the [__] floor
my wig is off yeah it's a whole thing
yeah shoot she she lost her dignity but
everybody was like are you okay [__]
all the girls were [__] loving on her
and [__] uh dudes were coming and
then every badass [__] came up
to me like I got your back and I'm like
[__] I don't need you to happen
[__] it where the [__] oh no it's nice
to have people have your back you don't
got to be a [__] about it they saw it
happen I'm just saying you know
I ain't talking about that anymore come
on
what time is it how long am I going
I don't know three hours three hours
this has been a three hour show DJ
Maniac said my last girlfriend was into
Psychobilly so I'm not too worried about
it running into her although we have
friends that carry over between the
hardcore metal and punk tribes yeah that
happens plus we had an amical amicable
term so that's well that's always good
when that happens
um DJ manic says I don't even live in
Florida and I know who these people are
keep in mind I have a lot of your
Florida friends add me on social media
yeah hey man yeah man
[Laughter]
Mania come visit us bro you totally
should yeah come visit us he totally
should or we should go up there and
visit him he's up in New York though I
know I love New York
I think New York's falling apart right
now and it's expensive
New York's always been expensive it's
expensive I used to be able to go there
I used to go there every couple years
if you want to come down here and hang
out you can stay with us bro
yeah that's an open invitation some
invitation you come stay with us you can
meet all these people in real life yeah
you'll know all kind of [__] about them
I sometimes I feel kind of bad that like
we're saying all this stuff I'm like I
always wonder like just if anybody I
don't think any of our friends really
listen to us regularly yeah
um you know because they're like
whatever we see you [__] all the time
in real life so it's like why do we want
to listen you talk more yeah but um you
know some of them do so I always kind of
like feel bad that it's like if we say
something about one of them then they're
like hey they're talking about me what
those [__] [__] I always wonder
about that but you know what I mean
because we're talking about people like
really without I gotta buy a new day bed
because the [__] Kitty ruined my
[__] inflatable one she keeps [__]
putting her claws in it and [__]
popping it I gotta fix it I'm gonna get
a new day bed I'll put that [__] up in
the [__] man cave where I want it but
then if you come over and visit I'll put
you over here in the gym
I got rooms over here
you stay you can stay with me for a few
days if you want to maybe even a [__]
a week
DJ Maniac said uh may take you up on
that when I get some time off from it
yeah seriously and we'll go to a couple
of club nights maybe come down here when
when the show's coming or some kind of
event
and then we'll go yeah it'd be fun some
around Orlando
and then you'll be able to meet all
these people
I mean like I said it's not like it's
it's pretty small you're gonna see like
the same people but
it's not
um we have a lot of shows down here
there are actually like oh there is a
lot of [__] going on down here I've been
in New York too I've done the New York
scene [__] um it's it's
as good it's different
it is different it's different it's more
laid out more open because it's it's
more tropical
uh
there's not as much [__] there's not
as many backstabbers and cutthroat
people here uh people here are
friendlier even though I like New
Yorkers I thought New Yorkers are tough
and friendly it's just it's just a
different kind of I was like New Yorkers
as well yeah they were a lot more
friendly than bostonians and I lived in
Boston for [__] like five years man
but if I can uh New York was more
friendly than Boston Boston people are
[__] got a stick up in the ass you
know but uh
Florida's Party Town you'd like it it's
it's laid back
although I would recommend good-looking
people here too I would recommend
probably coming in the fall or winter
don't come in the summer it's like not
yeah because it's still it's still hot
here in the winter it's already and
here's the thing like at my job they
don't have a break room or anything so I
just kind of have to like sit in my car
at lunch and I'm just kind of like
sitting out of the car for an hour and
I'm just getting like oh he said he can
sleep anywhere no I have a place where
you sleep you want to fly into Sanford
Airport that's our local airport it's
easy to get to it and it's [__] dead
so I mean you can fly into Orlando
International too like that's not
Santa's bar but Sanford is better uh
it's closer to us it's closer and it's
like much easier
it's where Sophie flew in she flew into
Sanford
and um
it's a small airport little bitty
Airport
and you can get good deals flying into
Sanford
yeah because not a lot of people do you
know because I I feel like a lot of
people don't know that that airport
exists yeah but they actually have some
well [__] they have some international
flights because even
back a long time ago when I was married
um my British husband's
relatives flew directly from Manchester
to Sanford
so they do have and it was direct as far
as I know so they did have flights I
don't know if they still do that
nowadays that was a long time ago but
they still do that [__] and Sanford
Airport is very small but it's a lot
easier to navigate Orlando if you time
it right I'll introduce you to [__]
goth DJ's here and also at the castle
you'd like the castle Paradise we do all
his [__] Paradise Mark Paradise we do
all his flyers and [__]
yeah pretty much any show that happens
in Tampa or Orlando yeah uh
that's goth or industrial or something
if you see a poster for it I probably
she did yeah I probably did it
um
yeah DJ Maniac says yeah I don't do well
in high temperatures
fall would be idea actually probably
winter would be better come on man what
you talking because no seriously fall in
Florida is still pretty hot it's yeah
it's still pretty hot it doesn't really
get cold well it doesn't ever get super
cold here but if it's gonna get cold
January I can't understand it bro
January yeah man hot weather hot weather
you just get used to it come on man you
got some of that I'm not used to it I've
I was born here but I'm still not used
to it I'm [__] Celtic and Germanic
and I can deal with it your African DNA
ass could have no problem with this
[__] heat down here you know you know
African Americans came from the south
all right [__] around New Orleans
area Mississippi Alabama I know there
that's you know what I mean y'all were
built for this you just adapt to it man
up it's not that hot man it's not that
hot yes it is it's not that hot you
adapt to it
if a white [__] like me can
adapt to it you can adapt to it yeah but
I don't know I could be tropical as a
[__]
you just deal with it I like it I just
and honestly like I said I was born here
I was born in Daytona Beach
um and I've never liked it my whole life
I I do not like hot weather I do not I
just I don't like it
so it's every summer
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I remember yeah
I forgot yeah he's a good buddy of mine
too I like Octavia yeah he's rad I
haven't seen him in a while we time it
right you can come down you can meet all
of them
gotta find the right event it would take
a week to meet them all wouldn't it
probably yeah you'd have to have the
Stars would have to align because
where's that Octavia spinning right now
do you know
I haven't seen him for a couple months
and be careful I think huh
somewhere yeah cause he's not here in
Orlando anymore I think he's Captain
yeah I haven't seen him in Orlando in a
while yeah I think so that's tip a Tampa
area just uh an hour from here
maybe he should come down like for um
vampire ball Absolution Absolution yeah
Absolution which is usually
first or second weekend in October yeah
Absolution I can't remember when it is
this year I just did the teaser are we
gonna do shirts for absolution I don't
know I haven't heard yet I'm gonna talk
to like I said I did the teaser
with the preliminary bands but that
always changes because you know what I
mean but yeah in case you don't know in
Tampa every October
we have a three day if you're into like
old school
goth music but new bands uh they do a
three-day Festival actually it might
just be two days now I'm not really sure
no I think it's still three days but
it's called Absolution they've been
doing it for the last three years four
years he says he's bouncing bounce
between uh Louisiana
or Louisiana that's the way you really
pronounce it Louisiana Florida Philly
New York and Vegas
I didn't know that [__] I didn't know
that octopia was moving he's moving
around I guess yeah he moves her well
he's from um I've done some flyers of
his uh yeah he's like a Philly guy okay
he's a Philly guy
since my brother been trying to drag me
out to Vegas to see him but it's in the
middle of the desert dude Vegas is dry
heat though
dry heat is a lot easier to deal with
than humid Heat
down here this is tropical it's [__]
100 humidity
they basically walk out and it's just
like instant swamp ass yeah yeah Vegas
is dry [__] even 130 degrees in zero
percent humidity is comfortable I mean
it's hot but it's just it's comfortable
because your cooling system works you
can sweat
here here You Can't Sweat in the
normally it doesn't
the imagine yourself being wrapped in
plastic
yeah that's what it's like here yeah it
feels like being wrapped in hot blankets
yeah hot blankets with plastic
white sweat because it's just too
goddamn humid like you sweat but it just
stays there and it doesn't it doesn't
cool it doesn't yeah evaporate yeah it's
supposed to evaporate that's how that
system evolves to work but it doesn't
work I was out in the cyanide desert in
[__] Egypt for six months
in the army it'd get to be 130 degrees
out there but it was zero to zero
percent humidity and I [__] loved it
it was a heat you could just eat it up
you just loved it I loved that heat it
was nothing like Southern Heat
because there's just no humidity and as
soon as the sun goes down it [__]
gets nice and cool cold see I don't like
heat period yeah I always just I would
rather be
cold I should have been an Arab or I
should have been an Arab I could yeah I
could live that life easily
I liked it
see I always felt like I should have
been
like I should have been born in Alaska I
could have been a desert Bedouin I'm a
cold mother a bit of a cold weather
[__] yeah yeah okay and I was
born in [__] Florida where it's hot
all the time I like cold weather no I
like cold
like I said you can always put like
coats on you can sit by the fire it's
like but down here you can't do that you
can't do that
down here you just always like
ugh
every time you go outside I'm just like
uh what's Maniac saying
uh talking about
we just had one of the two up here last
month dark force Fest formerly dark side
of the con murder of prose is a two-day
event here in New York City I've done a
poster for that
um last year or the year before I did a
murder of girls poster and we have icon
heading headlining this year yeah see
you guys have good [__] up there like I
said it's
it's been a while but I remember going
to the drop dead Festival there many
years ago
but yeah Absolution down here is really
good I think he started it
when did he start doing Absolution a
couple years back we've done both of
them
it might have been three this might be
the third or fourth year I think this is
the third one and it's three days yeah
gothic music festival yeah and it's all
like there's no industrial there's
nothing like that it's all like old
school like old school well they're new
bands but they're like it's like old
school they also had like retro wave and
cold waves right yeah because chlorine
was there chlorine was there man that's
I love chlorine
I told them that to their faces and it's
only two dudes I said matter of fact I
heard I found you guys on new retrowave
matter [__] I love you guys look at
Heaven servant [__] great [__]
song If you want to travel back to a new
retro 80s
Corine with a K they were so jazzed that
we knew who they were
yeah you guys are [__] grade man yeah
we heard them on that YouTube channel
called new retro wave new retro wave
yeah we heard their stuff on there and
then we saw them like I bought shirts
from them yeah yeah I still have that
shirt I just wore it the other day I
want to see them again
but I know as somebody on the show said
thanked me for talking about chlorine
about a year ago yeah we were living
here at the time saying that dude I
[__] somebody said I I checked that
bad out that is a [__] badass
basketball yeah very good yeah they're
really good there's a lot of really good
bands out there anyways and like I said
um Absolution
um kind of has the best like a starry
night usually play there but it's like
you always have stuff like like twin
tribes and yeah
um Rose Garden a funeral party and like
all those kind of bands like usually
play there they play their their playing
there this year I think they played last
year as well but it's always like a
really really good show I think they are
doing it
the first time they did it I think they
did it two or three different venues but
I think they kind of narrowed it just
down to one at this point
there's a new place there I don't know
how new it is but it's called New World
Tampa it's like a brewery but it's also
like a live venue and a lot of bands
play there as well
because I've been doing a lot of like
posters with them
um DJ Maniac said oh we haven't done
drop dead in a long time yeah it's been
a while I remember going there I think I
went to one in
I guess it was 2009 or 2010 or something
like that I went there like two or three
years in a row and then I know they used
they moved it to like Europe after that
which was kind of a shame but I really
had a good time like at that [__] that
was like that was like some awesome
that was they had it at um
[__] what was that venue called
I remember in a minute but it was like a
three story kind of thing and like the
basement they had DJs and then the top
two floors they had different bands
playing
it's like I saw
uh Cinema strange slash Dead Fly
Ensemble they played there like and then
they had like like they had newer [__]
and then they had like old [__] like
they had skeletal family without like uh
Anna Marie they had like a different
singer and then they had like Nina Hagen
uh Lena Lovich was there one year
uh [__] I saw like all kind of good [__]
was there it was like really really good
but yeah
um yeah DJ Maniac said we had all those
bands less here last year on uh Moc yeah
so Absolution same kind of thing
um I can't remember all the bands that
we had
there was a whole bunch of them like I
said it was like three days worth
I remember chlorine I was like obviously
a starry night
um Rose Garden Funeral party who the
[__] else were there I can't really
can't even remember
ah [__] I'm kind of drunk so I can't
like think of who it was but yeah
um sounds like either the old bat cave
or Delancey Lounge it wasn't though it
was um
[__] man what was the name of that place
the Knitting Factory Knitting Factory
that's where they had it ning Factory
that's where it was I knew I'd remember
and they had it there a couple years in
a row because I went a couple years in a
row but I can't remember what year it
was it was when I was still married to
my ex-husband so it was probably it was
before 2000 and
nine because I think we got divorced in
2009 or 2010.
so it was before that
uh
accent now I gotta figure out a whole
Florida goth wardrobe it is it's a whole
ordeal I I get it I get it like they're
during during the winter it's not that
bad
dude I bought from killstar
I bought an awesome
uh like crop
hoodie that's Dario Argento Opera from
1987 which I reviewed not too long ago I
think on my channel
and it's like it's got chains on it it's
got the hood and everything and I'm just
kind of like I still have not worn it
yet because it's long sleeved and I'm
just like when the [__] am I ever gonna
wear this because it's long sleeve and
it's like I wear that [__] in a porn
shoot
okay we'll see yeah
I mean I could just wear a regular I'm
just saying that it's kind of [__]
titties flapping and [__] [__] like
that maybe just don't slapping the back
of the head the [__] titties
something like that you know it would be
awesome if I wore that
and then you taped pins that not real
pins obviously but like taped pins under
my eyes just like an opera I know you
haven't seen an operator
but that's like the iconic image because
she because he like tapes pins under
their eyes so they can't close their
eyes so they have to like watch him like
murdering people Pookie is [__]
walking around what are you doing come
here come here where are you going
where are you going she's walking away
she's trying to get me to go play with
her DJ Maniac says oh that's gone now
yeah I figured what's going on any the
Knitting Factory that's where I went to
drop dead and he says I went to the
original Knitting Factory like 20 years
ago
for yeah that's what it was though that
was it was the Knitting Factory
look at Pokey yeah she's just like you
she's putting up with it no she's okay
you were bored anyway weren't you
she's like Daddy's drunk yeah she was
she was look at her face look at her
face look at her face
look at the camera
yeah oh yeah
yeah she's like wow it's been going on
all day
[Laughter]
you okay pook she was like I guess so
one come down let me put you down she's
like oh yeah I'll put you down okay
yeah she's not a lap kitty yeah she
doesn't really like them she'll like
she'll let you do it but she's like I
kind of want to do my own thing
she kind of likes to do her anything
like tear up your books and why not
man we got more people watching than we
had before I told you yeah see we should
talk about porn more
sex sells I guess see that's what you
said that's it you always say that yeah
oh yeah you always say that that's a
saying back from the 50s and 60s well I
know that but I'm just saying
you always say that so I guess you're
right it's absolutely true
foreign
just put up a big post there
the owner of Knitting Factory actually
bought the old pyramid Club oh yeah it
is in the process of renovating it to a
small live venue for touring ax and
that's pretty cool actually I really
need to get back to New York City one of
these days
I haven't been since
2009 I think that was the last time I
went it's about the time I went it was
2009 I think I was with 2010 or 11.
and that was the last time I went I
haven't been since then
I kind of miss it
because I pulled up there that's okay I
like that I used to go every year
it's like the Yiddish food man you can
condition [__] you can get whatever you
want them yeah that's the nice thing
anything you want anywhere now but it's
just well yeah but I'm just saying that
I mean up there it's like much easier
everything's kind of like you can just
like walk to [__] and it's like I like
that
like where we live
like let's be honest it's a little bit
rural well yeah
so
if you want something you have to drive
you're gonna have to drive yeah there's
really not anything the only thing
within walking distance is Dollar
General yeah well why would you want to
walk though this is where no I'm just
saying if if you had to if you didn't
have a car we got a good sushi place
close
it rated pretty well
um the only thing we don't have a good
[__] uh Chinese buffet
you gotta go a long way to get koi won
well yeah that's it's a drive yeah we
have to go tomorrow honestly it's
farther than isn't koiwan farther than
mannequins oh yeah yeah I think it is we
have to go tomorrow actually I'm in the
mood for some even though you cheated on
me and I cheated on you went to [__]
coin
um I told you we talked about what we
haven't been to the trough lately
oh that's right maybe we should go to
the oyster trough yeah we got some good
stuff with two and trough with two f
with 2fs
they got good food though good [__]
fried oysters fish [__] everything
it's right on the water yeah so it's
just it's just we're in a different
environment you know we got good [__]
it's just it's gonna be like local yeah
well and you have to drive because it's
not you can't walk to it everything's
far apart it's cow pastures and [__]
horse pastures yeah everything's like
it's very well we posted a video of us
driving around this area on this channel
yeah a while back wow back yep to show
you guys what what it looks like here
yeah it's a good motorcycle country yeah
Orlando's not far it's right here
we're on the edge of it very very edge
going to in 10 years this will be part
of the Orlando sprawl easily well going
to Barbarella which is it's not in
downtown Orlando as it used to be it's
in the warehouse District yeah but it's
about a 25 30 minute drive but easy like
a 25 30 minute like on the toll roads
like it's easy to get to
so it's not horribly firing okay I got
some questions Sebastian's asking me how
the uh the biker bar is I only went a
couple days back and uh Amy was like
where you been and I said look I got all
the [__] I gotta do I can't hang out
with you all Little Folks you know what
I mean and she's laughing harsh yeah
um
now the biker bar is okay it's just it
man the music they [__] play there
they play too much [__] country music
and they're they're just don't get me
started yeah I'm more like uh I like sad
for bike night on Tuesday because those
are people in their 20s and 30s and 40s
and yeah he always has a good time he
always posts videos about that if you're
on his Facebook no uh Instagram or
Instagram go on my Instagram and you'll
see I got pictures of [__] me hanging
out with like a lot of younger bikers
all right they got girls and everything
sport bikes and Harleys and everything
you know so it's just
the Oasis is the old bike biker crowd
50s and 60s all right which we're in our
50s too but we're not old like we're not
that old we're not old like they're
we're not like old like them yeah
like I said that's what I always say old
is not that doesn't have anything to do
with your numerical no no some of these
people it's a completely different
concept yeah I'm gonna show y'all
my uh
that's why I see I went to the Oasis
with you one time yeah I met you there
just to see what it was like that's my
Instagram just go look at Thomas Ross
this is me hanging out
with CJ and Mike
and CJ just turned 21. all right I was
trying to hook Sophie up with CJ he's
like but he's even too young but I said
but that's a handsome young man and he's
got a and he's got a Harley eight ball
all right top yeah I don't know but Tom
is like a consummate I'm a Matchmaker so
I'm trying to hook every one of our
friends if they are single he
immediately starts trying to like hook
them up with him look at him look at him
look at him look how cute he is it's
hard to tell with the hood on
but he looks all right he looks like Ian
Asbury
uh yeah I guess
oh yeah yeah okay all right yeah like I
said it's kind of hard to say because
he's got like a hood and a hat yeah but
I guess but no he had a heart he has
he's got a Harley a ball and everything
he just turned uh 21 or 22 I think
that is a little young for soap though
isn't it so so ready with the younger
guy I'm trying to steal her from that
younger guy get her with another young
boy
we'll get Soph move down here into
civilized territory see with her young
boyfriend soap's only 31.
oh okay yeah she's not there yeah she's
only 31 and [__] she can go out with
a guy that's [__] 10 years younger
yeah that could happen I mean I showed
him pictures although I showed him
videos of her and he's like yeah she's
hot she's hot she comes down here you
want to meet her she goes I'll take her
for a ride I'll show a good time that's
what he said although I kind of feel
like like he was confident he was like
speaking as a girl yeah
um you don't usually want to go younger
unless it's just for sex because younger
dudes are
exhausting to put up with okay
okay
she's told the truth he says I'll show
her a good time
will he though he's not sure
from his perception yeah will it be a
good time for me probably
we'll see probably that right I got a
good nose for that kind of [__] I got a
good nose there I like the kid I liked
him I liked it
all right
this is the same way you're like sending
my sending pictures of my titties to
people and I don't even like know about
it
that was only a couple times though
that was fun and yeah well you're an
excuse was well I pierced your neck I
pierced him so I could do it so I'm just
showing the work so I'm just like
showing them it's like clinical yeah
right you know you got some badass
titties though
well why are you ashamed I'm not ashamed
I'm ashamed of him either I'll be
[__] working out working them over
lusting over them
they're beautiful people you're gonna
see I know it's gonna cost money but
y'all gonna see
it's all right
Victor says Victor just got here said
wow y'all are still on yeah believe it
or not yeah well like I said we're not
going out so we're just kind of yeah
this is our night out Victor says uh
country sucks I agree uh well new
country sucks 90s and back is real
country honestly it depends on the
country okay
I like Johnny Cash I like Hank Williams
I was telling country music yeah yeah I
like all that kind of [__] but
Okay so the two Network and I've said it
before he's like the DJ
most of the time he just plays kind of
like generic dance music somebody like
today he played like 80s stuff like he
did like some cool ladies like some New
Order and stuff and then like there was
a whole like Madonna Super cut that's
fine
but sometimes he for some reason he kind
of likes country like new country so
sometimes he'll play a playlist of that
that [__] is
okay it almost sounds like a parody of
itself
but it's not it's like serious I think
is it
um
I guess I don't I don't know I I'm
conflicted I don't know if they're
meeting for me to take it seriously but
it's like it's it's terrible it's really
terrible
so I don't I don't know what to make of
it I don't know what to make of it but I
do like old [__] like I love Johnny Cash
I love Hank Williams I love all the old
[__] I'm not sure Khan Johnny Cash is
even country though I think he's Western
yeah like I like that kind of well
because I'm I really like
um 50s rockabilly which was very
inspired by country so I like that kind
of stuff so I like more country that's
more rockabilly inspired like from the
old days new country I have no
time or patience for that it's awful and
it sounds like
self-parody but it seems like it's
trying to be serious but like parody at
the same time and it's
I don't know it stresses me out
listening to it just see maybe X is that
he used to date older women when he was
doing look it's not like I'm trying to
I'm just trying to get a friend of mine
laid by a hot young guy who's got a bike
she so missed out on a lot a lot of
[__] certain Elements of Life
I know her whole story good friend of
mine we talk all the time we talk almost
every [__] day she's my buddy okay
um so I know everything about it she's
almost like my sister and I'm just
trying to
hook her up with a fun guy you know what
I mean [__]
now he would have worked I think she
liked him
it doesn't have to be permanent it's not
like they're getting married or anything
you know as if I don't look at maybe the
same way as a woman would look at it I
guess
but
because a guy is going to look at it
like well it's going to be fun it
doesn't matter if it's going to last a
long time it's the male strategy you
know so
maybe I'm [__] up for saying that you
know I mean because women are kind of
like well can I marry him is it gonna be
a long term it's not always your
consideration it depends on what your
situation is at the time right sometimes
well because like I said after my
divorce and when I was kind of just like
looking to have a good time like I
wasn't really looking to like settle
down with anybody well that's at all but
I was thinking I was gonna like I showed
it I was like is this person gonna like
entertain me or are they gonna be like
you know what I mean but maybe we could
settle down like but I wasn't really
thinking that's how I was looking at I
was just like so you'll like this one
okay go have fun come on out come back
down here hook up with this [__]
you'll have a [__] good time with
this guy it don't matter if it doesn't
last long is whatever time you had
that's the time maybe it's a year maybe
it's six months maybe it's two years it
I don't look at it that way you just
gotta roll the dice you know what I mean
I you know I understand roll the dust
well everything is I know Michigan she's
up in Michigan everything is an
experience yeah I've had experience the
difference between Michigan and Florida
where's grampers we went to school
together I haven't seen him today okay
big difference all right [__] sofa
would feel a lot better in Florida than
she would in Michigan
uh there's a certain type of person that
does well in Michigan and Sophie ain't
it
but uh
I'm gonna change the story
well
I know the place I like Michigan it's
just that there's just a certain kind of
I couldn't live in Michigan
I could I could visit but I could live
there I lived there before
for years the weird thing about Florida
is I don't know if they're specifically
a type because everyone is from
somewhere else except me I'm from here
no
um you're seeing it from your point of
view because you haven't lived in other
places the people that are moving here
gentle they like it here because they
didn't really like where they were
so no they're the type
Florida has a lot to offer
if you go to Mississippi you'll see how
much Florida has to offer you go to
Louisiana
you'll like Louisiana but then you
realize how different Louisiana and
Florida are
go up to go up to Boston you'd like that
I probably would you would
a couple years later you'd be like yeah
there's certain limitations up here you
know well everywhere minuses yeah well
like I said Austin look I'm from Florida
I was born here which a lot of people
were not
um and even from when I was a kid
I don't know like a lot of it and
Florida is like um
oh I don't know I kind of feel like the
rest of the country sees in a particular
way and there are elements of that that
are shitty and that I hate but
you can't judge all of it by that
because
the um the different sections of Florida
are different like it's almost like
different states in one state
um yeah it's not uniform it's all over
the place right it's kind of all over
the place
um but to be honest parts of parts are
Mississippi almost yeah like the
Panhandle that's Mississippi it's the
same [__] thing having been born here
um and not
you know from a very young age not
really being into the rednecky [__] not
really being into like all that kind of
stuff
um I always kind of hated it I always
kind of hated it and to be honest I
still kind of hate it
um you know a lot of it is not I don't
really like a lot of aspects of it well
the redneck part he is she doesn't I
don't like the rednecky [__] I don't
like the weather
um
I don't know there's a lot of [__] about
Florida I don't like and like I said
I've lived here my most of my entire
life so here's the feel like I can say
that when when you see on the news about
Florida man
half the time that's not rednecky [__]
some of that's Urban stuff too uh the
real redneck [__]
is it the real redneck [__] in Florida
is almost more redneck than Mississippi
Mississippi is not really that redneck
it's country as [__]
but a lot of the people kind of classy
out in the country it's weird it's just
weird you gotta come you got to live
here to understand it
um
I was born here and I still don't really
get it well because it's because you
haven't left you gotta live I have lived
in other places like I lived in the UK
okay but you can get more of a
perspective of [__] what this is
now I get it yeah I just like I said
from a young age I was like I'm not like
this
I like it so I don't I like like it yeah
I like Florida because I think Florida
has it has a lot of choices
in Florida they got redneck stuff but
they also have City stuff then they have
south or like Central American style
stuff here too it's a good like I said
there's a lot of different stuff going
on so you can't just like generalize
yeah but you keep going south it becomes
like [__]
Cuba basically you know which that's
cool it's like [__] you know it it
it's like Central you know having
partially growing up in Brazil I'm
totally [__] comfortable with Central
and South American cultures you know I'm
[__] flute and Portuguese I
understand most of Spanish I could fake
Spanish because Portuguese is real close
and um no
South Florida that looks that's awful
cool I like that yeah yeah I quite like
South Florida actually yeah well in
South Florida has its own thing going on
too it's basically like Cuba but yeah it
also has I don't know if people know
um but it also has a gigantic like
fetish scene yeah it so it also has like
a bunch of that kind of stuff going on
too yeah
it's not conventional it's it's a it
here and it's a it's a land of extremes
I was actually born I was actually born
in California and uh Florida reminds me
of
Southern California in the 70s Long
Beach
San Diego Vista it's kind of like that
back in the 70s
um but it's not the 70s here it's
you know 2023 right
it's uh so you got modern technology you
wouldn't know it by some standards but
you know but it's well it's not Ultra
corporate it's just it's cool I like it
it's it's a good mixture it's a good
mixture I think I think Florida's a good
mixture although I will say that I think
that the goth scene in Florida
is good because I think it was it's a
lot of people like me that got stuck
here or you know just ended up here for
reasons beyond their control Castle too
right and
um so they decided Well I'm gonna carve
out my own lifestyle apart from the [__]
that I don't like about Florida so there
is like a very large goth scene there's
a very large fetish scene so if you're
into that kind of [__] or if you don't
like weird [__] you can find something
to like suit your taste there you don't
have to indulge in the whole
country redneck because a lot I'm not
gonna lie a lot of the mainstream
culture is that especially in Daytona
and I had kind of forgotten about that
because I moved away from there a long
time ago but now that I'm working there
because you know my job is in Daytona
now so I commute back there like every
day
um and I had forgotten how
rednecky that place was
and I was like oh yeah I forgot about
this Victor says so it's gone crazy
politically no it hasn't it's awesome no
it has gone crazy no it hasn't you can
carry guns here they got [__]
constitutional carry you can do whatever
you want
uh it's just traditional American about
to pass that six-week abortion ban too
yay that that would can't wait for that
what is that exactly
meaning you can't get an abortion after
six weeks six weeks of what six week of
pregnancy dumbass
okay what that is an effect which means
uh yeah well a couple years ago would
have affected you you would have been a
dad it's okay
whether you wanted to or not oh that
well then I would be like okay yeah fine
whatever I don't care okay
I have to look at the details it doesn't
matter to you obviously so
man if you had my kid you'd be loving it
right about now
well we all let's not talk about that we
know how that worked out how did it work
I don't think we ever talked about that
on the show did we no no we didn't we
never did talk about that what what's
that
it's like Cuba but with a giant fetish
scene I love it already
um I don't know if I'd go that far
South Florida is like Cuba
Florida is like three or four different
states in one
the Panhandle is kind of like
Alabama it's essentially like Alabama
Central Florida is I don't even know
what the [__] to call it it's just all
over the place there's cool [__] there's
stupid [__] there's red necky backwards
[__] there's
I don't know there's cool [__] it's I
don't know it's it's all over the place
I can't really describe it South Florida
is kind of like
Cuba
but there's also like some other like
there's then there's like swampy [__]
because you have like the Everglades and
stuff
but then there's like a huge I don't
know about now but there was like a huge
fetish scene down there I don't know
about now there is like up here too but
I don't know about nowadays I haven't
been down there in a while
um Jeff yard says contemporary country
panders to privileged Frat Boys from the
Midwest and South
um yeah I
I hadn't really heard like a lot of the
Contemporary country music because why
would I I don't that's not really my
thing
but just from
hearing it
uh
at work like on various playlists and
stuff and I'm just like
it seems they've really I don't know how
old some of the stuff that I'm hearing
on there is it must be fairly new or
fairly popular because I've heard it
um you know subsequently like in other
contexts
but it seems like they're really leaning
Into The Stereotype of
yeah we're just kind of like we're doing
all this stuff about yeah all the
country songs are about my truck and my
[__] like that because like a lot of
them are kind of seem like they're sort
of making fun of that but not
I don't know I'm not
it's hard for me to say I'm just not I'm
just not into it I'm just not into it
and it just kind of like
honestly like listening to it just kind
of pisses me off and I don't really know
why I don't really know why I guess it's
because I grew up around it
my family didn't listen to that kind of
stuff but
it was just always around because I grew
up in a very rednecky kind of
context and it's just kind of like so
anything that smacks of that just kind
of makes me mad you know what I mean
so anytime like I kind of hear that and
it's like there's this oh we're making
like a funny country song about oh this
chick and she loves my truck and all
this I'm just like [__] you know what
shut up I just like I'm just I can't
stand it I can't stand it
I hate that [__] I hate that [__] what
um hold on but what law were you talking
about I'm going to check this out
Florida law what oh the band that
they're trying to pass they haven't Pat
they haven't passed they tried a pet
they're yeah they always they're trying
to pass everything yeah it is amazing as
far as I know it's a 15-week band right
now but they're trying to they're going
to do trimester [__] it's always going
to be they have passed some six weeks
six week bands in other states which
like I said I thought you were saying it
was a law that passed no no there's so
many laws that are crazy that didn't
pass that I don't even worry about that
[__] maybe another drink how about that
um
hold on Sophie saying something DJ
Maniac says older women tend to date me
only for sex back in my 20s and 30s good
for them okay
soap's headed home already wait what
time is it 11.
no it's Michigan no it's an out wait is
it an hour later or two hours an hour
maybe 12. they're Central Time right or
are they Central summer mountain time I
bought me a shirt and his sister worked
good and all that okay we'll see how
okay okay is she central time or
Mountain Time yeah
that's Central Time right
so they're only an hour so it's 12 18.
there
Victor said it did pass April 14th
what's what's the law the six-week ban
let me see what's the name of the law
well the six-week abortion ban sure
this week is uh
I mean I was just reading about it
earlier so I wasn't sure if it had
passed or not
her time is 10 18. Tammy says no Then
She oh that's right it's earlier
why did I think it was later
oh I was thinking of yeah I'm down
I'm down that's right it's earlier
so [__] it's even earlier than I thought
it was she's going home even her like
kids here we're eastern time and it's 11
19. so her it's like an hour earlier
Jeff yard said I live in South Florida
near Fort Lauderdale the Kink scene is
thriving especially yeah see that's what
I thought I haven't been in any fetish
parties down there in a while but I
remember there being like a huge fetish
scene down there uh in regards to
leather s m uh only caveat the weather
isn't exactly leather latex friendly
yeah tell me about it that's the thing
um yeah and DJ Maniac was saying this
earlier
being a goth in Florida it's a it's a
commitment because you were gonna sweat
your [__] balls off and you really
have to
um
I don't know you really have to like
curate your kind of like outfits to make
sure
because man I have I have a whole closet
full of like cool [__] codes and all
this other kind of stuff that I really
can't wear hardly ever
other than maybe once or twice a year
because it's just too
[__] hot it's too [__] hot
they're saying something about the six
weeks but it's not in effect yet and
they're not saying the actual number of
the loss so I can go and read it because
a lot of times they'll
lie about what the law actually says
so I I haven't I don't believe anything
until I actually read the law
and then any law you give me I'm gonna
[__] look at it with a lawyer's eye
about interpretation
I don't really believe in laws I'm a
criminal I've been a criminal most of my
life any law you pass I'm not gonna
follow it anyway let me go ahead and get
the
and uh if you want an abortion there's
going to be all kinds of places where
you can get them
so I don't really care and uh well you
don't have to if I knock something I'm
gonna make sure it happens if I but if
you can't get it done and [__] you
you're not me I don't care
why would you [__] say that because
every person really go make me a drink
every person who takes care of
themselves go maybe it's your own thing
do your own thing don't even go down
this road you're making me really mad
right now you're making me really mad
right now
you're making me really mad right now oh
my God
uh let's see
DJ main access half my tried goth
wardrobe is designed for winter best I
could do in Florida is a kitten a fish
yeah it was a bad shirt
um yeah I kind of hate it because I have
so much [__] that's like long sleeve
just like fabulous and stuff like that
but you can't really wear a lot of it
down here because it's just too I mean
you can but
you're gonna sweat your ass off you're
gonna sweat your ass off
sweat your ass off
good Lauren Tammy said most women don't
even know they're pregnant at six weeks
exactly exactly and like I said I have
some
um I don't think I've ever discussed
this but I have had some personal
experience in that regard but you know I
don't know if I really want to get into
that but you know what I mean
so
yeah it's I don't know it's just kind of
upsetting it's kind of upsetting
because I have personal experience and
this is not
um
one of the reasons I'm not super jazzed
about Florida right now not super jazzed
about Florida
I've never liked it here to be honest
with you but like I said I was born here
so I'm kind of stuck
and I don't like a lot of things about
it some things about it are cool not
gonna lie but
a lot of things about it I don't like
and I've never liked
and that's one of the things
uh you can go to another state it
depends
um
you can but depending on where you are
that might be a really really long
journey and uh you know that costs money
it's not free
so you know it might not be feasible
for some people
so you know not great to be put into
that situation but like I said it's
dudes voting on it and dudes don't care
so I spilled ice everywhere what do you
what do you expect what do you mean what
do I expect
I'm gonna take some of this
she went flying
okay
hold on let me give you some ice
no I'm out I forgot I used all the Ice
Wheels yeah well you dumped it out right
it went flying no I made it made a drink
and I [__] knocked the [__] over the
[__] went flying yeah I heard you say
you knocked it yeah I was like what the
[__]
Jeff yard said it's interesting to see
how the leather Kink scene in the gay
community is evolving into what is known
as the pup play community community
it's mostly about headspace and doesn't
always have to be sexual yeah like I
said I kind of feel like I always have
the perception that there's you know
there's a lot of fetish [__] going on up
here too but I kind of feel like most of
the real hardcore fetish stuff was
always going on in South Florida that's
where all the fetish parties were that's
where all I mean at least that I
remember
The Fetish parties that I went to were
always in South Florida Camp deck says
man cat and I've been drinking all night
I dropped the ice too I feel you yeah
man [__] I dropped I dropped the ice
you can't do anything yeah
yeah Jenny Jenny's mad because
I'm talking about laws I really don't
care about laws in government I think
it's all illegitimate anyway
do whatever you want to do
well the people at the top of the
society yeah but like don't give a [__]
they right whatever the [__] but what if
you can't do that you better find a
walls that are you better find a well
you shouldn't have to find a way you
shouldn't have this is mankind I'm just
like a [__] this is mankind a random
ass person
should I have to we are all random asses
go through all these like [__] jump
through all these things just because
some dude she doesn't know me like past
some stupid law that doesn't know [__]
about [__] this has been the Mankind's
problem since [__] 2 000 years of
civilization
they say all kinds of [__]
it shouldn't affect you
well I mean it's easy for you to say
like very easy a lot of [__] doesn't
affect you at all like that affects me
or that affects others you can get
around anything
any system they make I can break
all right I come from a background of
breaking governments and people
in the US Army the Infantry and [__]
any other kind of [__] sideways [__]
that we used to do just because somebody
writes a [__] down on paper it says it's
a law that doesn't mean anything nothing
you can break anyone anything or any
system
anything you want you can get you can
buy children right now if you wanted to
on the black market as wrong as [__] but
you can still do it none of this means
anything none of it's real
you want to have abortion go get one
you'll find a way
if you don't want to those laws are all
fake
you can get any drug you want
you can get anything you can kill people
and get away with it it's been going on
for thousands of years
just because it's illegal it doesn't
mean anything
the people at top of the society making
these rules and doing all those things
are the biggest criminals you could ever
[__] them none of this legit none of
this is legitimate
none of it
sad but true
so they make up rules
doesn't mean anything
I think technically weed is still
illegal in Florida they're smoking it
everywhere
and then nobody's getting arrested for
it
because they don't care
you know
the [__] that I'm injecting into my
veins all the time is illegal but I do
it anyway I can get it
so can everybody else
I can go over to Silverbacks evidently
and get it
so I'm not a big fan of government
because I think it's fake
it's just an illusion
there's some people who are kind of
raised to believe in to give them a
sense of order
that's not what's actually happening
though
not from what I'm seeing
I mean when I joined the army I thought
there would be order in the army
not really
that was just kind of a semi-controlled
chaos
I've learned to distrust Authority
deeply
there is no Authority
there's only opinion
and Power
they can come and arrest you and kill
you maybe
but could they could they rest all of us
and imprison all of us
and kill all of us no
no
so they're fake
so I've gotten to the point where I
don't care what they say I'm gonna do
whatever I want to do
that's what I've been doing
sad
but true
and it's great that we have a [__]
live stream going
and that this is [__] YouTube and
right now we have [__] about 20
people listening to us
they've been coming and going
this would have been impossible decades
ago but modern technology has allowed us
to stream and talk to other people
one-on-one basically
without any kind of corporate
interference
it's beautiful
but if you pay attention you actually
see what's going on none of this is real
it's all
a fictional reality
and what they're telling us to believe
in they don't believe in it
it's just corruption
the only thing you can depend on is
yourself and the people that you know
and your friends your family
protect you and yours
you can trust that
but people who don't know you they don't
give a [__] about you
they're sad but it's true
that vodka's pretty good though it
sure
you just brought the whole show down
didn't you yeah I'll bring the show down
yeah bring the show down I'm just kind
of having a moment
yeah clearly I'm having a moment right
now
because uh you know
but this is something we just have to
deal with in life you know
that uh
you know I have PTSD
and one of the one of the things about
PTSD is to understand that you've been
lied to a lot you know I was lied to a
lot but I'm sure that you you all were
lied to a lot too yeah
but it's kind of a red pill moment
to realize that you've been alive too
that many of the things that we believe
in or just don't exist
let's see what we're saying
yeah somebody says the law is a popular
delusion yes it is it is a very popular
delusion Ben thank you very much
physically says if you want a divorce
it's just do itself
yeah well there's a lot of [__] I've
just done myself actually over time
well like I said it's there will be a
way it kind of hurts my feelings that
you're not more sensitive about that
given ours how can you control how can
you control other people you're trying
to control other people I'm not trying
to control it did they say something's
wrong you think it's wrong no I don't
think so if other people say some [__]
and I disagree I don't give a [__] I
just do it anyway
right but a lot but sometimes like I'm
saying is that you don't have the
resources to do this [__] yourself you
gotta find it what are you gonna do then
you gotta find a way right but the onus
shouldn't be on you but this isn't a
fair World well yeah no [__] it's not a
fair world no [__] it's done yeah so but
like I said it's not great for
[__] who don't have anything to
do with it or who have other agendas
making [__] more unfair for you when
it's unnecessary fair is a point of view
maybe they think it's very fair I don't
know well I don't give a [__] what they
think honestly but I'm saying that you
know but it's it's just like okay let me
go back to Nichi and philosophy
we live in a world where people are
afraid to impose
okay
but existence itself is about imposing
everything imposes on something else
you know wolves eat rabbits
and rabbits eat grass
and grass compete with other grass for
shade and nutrients
everything imposes on something else
even inanimate objects impose on other
inanimate objects simply by occupying
the space that another object could
occupy
therefore existence itself is to impose
existence in a way and if imposing is
wrong then existence is wrong
the only way not to [__] impose this
did not exist
so we live in a world where everything
imposes
if something imposes on you you got to
find a way to get out from underneath it
all right if not you just sit there and
something's going to impose on you and
this has just been the way its Nature
has been since the dawn of time you know
there's no sense of getting mad at it
even though I do get mad at it but
that's just the way it is
there's always a way
you can move to other countries to get
[__] done or visit with what money
turn tricks
steal money is that really what you're
saying whatever whatever there's a ways
there's ways get it from you that's
really what you're saying there's always
ways there's always ways
are there not always always ways
Mr 80 it says that nichian or drunken
I'm gonna go with both I'm gonna go with
the ladder no it's both he's starting up
it's about ranting it's both it's both
he's starting up in the Reds no that was
Nichi and I'm drunk and
no it's not that was nature
yes I know that yeah Tom yeah but I'm
starting to get annoyed so we're gonna
have to end the show okay fine you want
some more drink no okay I have some
drinks okay we've been streaming plus
it's like 11 30. yeah yeah I've been up
since 4 30. okay we've been going for
like four hours what this is now they're
giving us money Jeff yard says here I
have another drink I mean yeah it was
crazy screw the IRS what are they gonna
do arrest me
yeah they really can't arrest you I mean
I just did my taxes I only ended up
owing
um a hundred and thirteen dollars in
taxes that's all because I didn't make
hardly anything last year well because
last year like this year will be
different but last year was just it was
all uh freelance
and so I wrote off a bunch of my
expenses and ended up owing 113 let me
show you all something
oh dear here we go he says okay they
I didn't pay my taxes what can they do
to me the worst thing they could do to
you is actually kill you all right
and if they kill you
in some kind of like execution
all they're doing you is freeing you
from the suffering of life
and freeing you from their clutches
so no there's not much they can do to
you
just isn't
because I've accepted early on that
first time I joined the service to go to
the war that I was basically a dead man
walking that we're all dead anyway it's
just a matter of time
you die either earlier or later
because you're definitely not Eternal
not in a physical form maybe in a
spiritual form but not in a physical
form
so there's not much they can do to you
especially the older you get the older
you get the less they can do to you
because if let's say I go out and
[__] commit a bunch of [__] crimes
so they give me a life sentence well
[__] that's not even 20 years probably
for me so there's not much they can do
to me you become more immune you know
and if they give me death
well in the United States they probably
still take you 10 15 years to kill you
anyway they'd be the same as life
there's nothing to do
[__] them they don't have any power over
you
which should be a liberating feeling
it's the only thing that bothers me I'm
gonna tell you this the only thing that
bothers me is that I have responsibility
to others if I die then I can't help pay
bills that's it I can't help pookie I
can't help Jenny you know I mean that's
that that's about it that's that's the
only thing they can do to me
but
I gotta look well I would think that you
wouldn't care about that because you
only care about your own self no but
here's the thing
you got to be realistic if I get x'ed
out and killed it'd be another
[__] up in here living in here
in my [__] with shitty that's probably
why would you think that that's probably
what would happen look you'd get another
man why the [__] would I want to put up
with another man after having put up
with you for something
can I just ask you that question
so you say I'm
why on Earth would I want to do that
after this you know that's after this
I'm done
I'm done oh man no thank you
that's enough okay I've had my fill
thank you
no I'm serious are you serious yeah all
right she's at her I'm up to here
all right that's enough after you're
gone I'm just like that's it that's it
okay no no more all right so I don't so
I don't understand why you're so
obsessed with this oh this is some other
dude I'm like no I'm not obsessed with
I'm just saying that's what happened if
I died I'd just be replaced no no I'd be
replaced now I just go live happily by
myself somewhere okay all right and not
have to listen to your [__] all the
time whatever that's what that that's
what happened there whatever
[Laughter]
Jeff yard says uh talking about taxes I
owe way more and it sucks looks like
I'll have to start my only fans well
yeah we're gonna start that [__] too but
it's like you had to sell that booty
hey Jim no shame man Jeffy I'm gonna do
that you should be on gay only fans
I'm gonna do that [__] yeah they don't
have any there's no money the only
reason that I only owed that much in
taxes was because I didn't make hardly
anything like after my expenses were
taken out I made like almost no money
so
that's why I only owed that many taxes
it'll be different this year because you
know I have like a real quote-unquote
job so we'll see how that goes this year
maybe I'll get some money back
if I'm lucky man Louie showed up yeah I
just saw that yeah
you missed so much you missed the whole
thing you missed the whole porn
discussion you missed the whole
everything we were talking about porn I
started getting [__] drunk starting
getting drunk and talking a bunch of
stupid [__] I do what I want to do I do
what I want to do thank you oh my god
thank you thank you damn all kinds of
Jenny's only fans down payment
seriously damn we are probably gonna do
it though but what's up the only fans
well the only fan slash yeah only fans
is one of the sites that we're gonna put
the stuff on we'll see how it goes well
yeah I'll see how it comes out I want to
see how it comes out with the lighting
we just talked about the first one no
remember well that's just the first one
if it doesn't come out good we'll just
get lighting and we'll just we'll
continue we'll have material
but you don't want to do it
yeah I do what it is well then we'll
have material yeah it'll be right I just
like I said I want to see how it comes
out just so I can assess
yeah she wants to see if she looks good
you're gonna look good on it well duh
who's the selling point me yeah so it
didn't kind of see me they're paying to
see you
this is true I told you that we gotta
have no no no
the thing that we talked about was that
you seemed like you were trying to like
oh well you should do all this stuff
like by yourself and I'm like that
wasn't the deal no that's not because
that's not that's what you're reading
into it you read that no you read into
that
I was I was saying that maybe the
channel should be named after you well I
don't know about that I think we should
be easier for them to remember we'll
come up with a good name right that's
all I was saying
because you You Know You're Gonna Want
You're Gonna Want a partner
to help film and to help like I said I'm
not doing this [__] by myself if I had
if I had to do the [__] by myself I
wouldn't do it females do not buy porn
males do right they're straight males
they don't they're not interested in me
but
what I could do is is of course you're
going to need somebody to work with and
you're gonna need somebody to [__]
run cameras with and you're gonna need
you know what I mean no Direction even
helping to [__] write scripts or
whatever to come up with ideas
so yeah we're about to come with some
cool [__]
I'm just saying that
now when now here's another thing I was
mostly talking about video
right I wasn't so much talking about
live stream live stream okay live stream
that that's kind of that's kind of a
different thing all right but I was
thinking that we ought to do a couples
live stream
but then maybe we do
a singles live stream too because some
girls said based on my research that
they made that they did both and that
their singles live streams actually made
more
always still be here with you
yeah because like I said I'm not doing
that [__] because that's weird
because what what I could one of the
things I could do is I could grab the
camera
yeah you know what I'm talking about and
be like a camera man
so that's not the same as being by
yourself
and the [__] doesn't last that long
there you know what I mean these dudes
are [__] only going for four or five
minutes they don't want to spend that
much time
but when it comes to Gold shows you're
going to want to partner
yeah I can help you with that
but some of these [__] you know
what I mean I've done the research
somebody's you know I've talked to the
girls
they jump in and [__] jerk off and
they're gone in [__] four minutes a
dude can't rock up and [__] handle
anything in four minutes this is a dude
just trying to get off real quick
but that's 25 bucks
right
and I mean and there's lots of those
there's more of those than there is
[__] 30 minute gold streams
okay our gold shows you know what I mean
so a lot of that money is just these
[__]
corn dogs jumping in and out for four or
five minutes
so
I don't know you have to just go where
the money goes and and right so let's
see how it goes that's all I was talking
about
mostly Africans the idea is I I want to
sound like a total capitalist but of
course you know if we're in front of
everybody
it's just that this is a business
operation where we're talking about and
it has to be mixed
some [__] we can do is going to be
artistic other shit's just going to be
[__] fast you know because that's
just the way the the market is
yeah because I've looked at how they're
doing it
and there's a bunch of different money
streams you can put your hand in
and yeah you could say well I'm not
going to do those little [__]
um four and five minute dudes
I'm just gonna do gold shows and that's
going to be like a real show
yeah
you might get 200 gold which means you
make like a hundred and [__] 30 bucks
off that because they take 65 or
something
so
so actually it'd be less than that it'd
be the what
you've been making about [__] 60
bucks 70 bucks off of [__] off of
that show
when there's a these dudes jumping in a
[__] 20 bucks a pop for four minutes
it's a [__] kind of a creepy thing
when you think about it
you know
but uh it just is what it is
for me the artistic expression and [__]
would is going to be the video
yeah because you could actually make
that into a product and it edit it and
[__] you know like I said you can do
something cool with it yeah yeah before
you release it and you got a little
story and you've got quality control and
[__] you know
yeah so I actually more look forward to
video
than than live stream but I think the
money is in live stream
probably yeah I think so probably yeah
but we'll see how that goes yeah Tammy
says same as this show we pay to see
Jenny not Tom yes
[__] [__] this is [__] 21 they
got 21 in there now
it's going up
we're gonna [__] stream for [__]
what 13 minutes and [__] we stream
for another hour we'll have 70 people
maybe well it's Friday night everybody's
just yeah they're not they're gonna have
sex Jeff yard said it's by it's been my
experience yeah that women don't usually
buy visual porn but rather rather read
erotic content that is my experience and
honestly um generally like I will watch
porn but only particular kinds I don't
usually like straight CIS hat porn or
anything like that it's not all that
interesting to me it seems very clinical
so
um yeah I usually like uh enjoy more
like reading
erotica yeah because that is more
because you can imagine you can put
whatever you want what other whatever
visuals you want into it and I'm saying
out uh out of all these little um
we call mediums
video is the closest to that in terms of
potential
that live stream [__]
most of that is going to be real simple
well the live stream as far as I could
determine it seemed like a lot of well a
lot of people that came and then
um make money live streaming from caming
a lot of times they'll come on
and they're on for several hours at a
time
but a lot of that time I'll just be kind
of like sitting around like talking to
people like talking about tipping them
it's like you know tip me five dollars
you know I'll flash my tits or whatever
but it's like it's that kind of stuff
but it's like they don't really do
anything like super hardcore until they
get like a certain amount of money and
then it goes like to a private show and
then like they do that [__] but well on
stream mate they do a lot of that
they'll flirt but that's mostly a single
girl okay there's no guy there
if there's a guy there there's not
something without so much of that
flirting there's something about where
they think this they can actually date
this girl this [__] ain't gonna happen
you know I mean but they think they're
gonna date this girl just to see this
weird girlfriend experience with these
guys well that's a whole sub-genre too
then they call it the girlfriend yeah
and so that's the whole thing what
happened which I'm not do I'm not and
then but you know then
um what will happen is is uh during that
time they'll [__] be hey show us your
top here five bucks that type of [__]
and then a [__] will jump in and
they want to go private
okay and that private is you can set the
minute
the per minute uh
price 299 399 4.99 a minute whatever
and those dudes are in and out of their
[__] four minutes
you know that's pretty impressive yeah I
can't imagine it well like I said they
must be like getting ready before yeah
they must have had dick in hand and
ready but that's what I mean they got
the tissues
they're like everything's right right
there and they're just like okay when is
I gotta pay I gotta pay okay
yeah that's what they're doing I mean
they're setting the whole [__] up which
like I said respect so
if you're going to do that gonna go
private and do that then that means
[__] uh
uh that's a that's that's a job just for
a woman [__] stunt cat stunt [__]
can't jump in in four minutes Rock up
knock the [__] out of there and put on a
good show for that's not what that
that's not what he's looking for he
wants somebody to [__] blow a dildo
or do some crazy [__] and [__] bust
it open and do that's all you know he's
gonna [__] then he's gonna be out and
you're gonna get [__] 10 bucks out of
that
Maybe 15.
that's what they're talking about
now the only thing that would be that
would be couples related it would be a
gold show that's where you're giving
them [__] 20 minutes you go hey it's
gonna be 250 [__] gold
and we're gonna make like a hundred
dollars you got 20 minutes to get this
and then if if the money isn't good you
can either reject the show and they all
get their their coins back or you take
the show and then you you're already set
when they're looking they're paying they
know how long the show's Gonna Last and
what's going to happen on it you're
gonna do a show it's like [__] a half
hour
you know what I mean
for like 250 gold
which would make us about a hundred
something dollars
that's a day's work
think about it that's a day's work
they got people to [__] work all day
out in these [__] Farms they don't
[__] make 150 bucks
true all right
well you could do two of those a day
three
yeah if you're really yeah if you're
really into it yeah get all the [__] set
up so
it depends on how you want to do it
Mr 88 said almost everything I know
about porn I learned from Tom and Jenny
yeah really okay probably must hear from
Tom because I don't really watch that
much more
Louie says Jenny have you seen the
trailer for The Last Voyage of the
Demeter looks pretty good yes I have and
that is actually one of the movies that
I'm most looking forward to this year
because I'm excited that somebody
actually made a movie from
uh a part of Dracula that a lot of
movies kind of uh sort of gloss over
here here take some of this
well you do this [__] earlier [__] we
got more people in there now that we had
before you took all of it yeah I did I
just I wanted you to take half of it you
already take all of it yep she stole all
my [__] booze
look at her face yeah but you took all
my [__] earlier you poured so now so you
want me to go get some more yeah are we
gonna qt are you gonna continue
are we going to continue with this or
are we going to [__] um end the ship
well I don't know how many people are
right now 21 they're going it's going up
Planet X where he said wow I missed out
another Marathon live stream it's a
marathon we've been drinking it well
like I said we're drinking it's Friday
uh we're not going any place yeah I'm
having a good time I've been talking all
kinds of [__] you've been talking all
kind of stupid [__] and like I'm getting
annoyed but thankfully you stopped
talking stupid [__] I wasn't talking
stupid [__] that [__] was it was [__]
smart as [__] okay it was smart as [__]
just don't don't be so smart in the
future I'm smart as [__]
it yeah
let's talk about fun [__] like porn or
music
[Laughter]
but yeah seriously I have seen the
trailer for that movie and that was one
of my most anticipated movies for this
year
I've seen a million Dracula adaptations
but
the fact that somebody is just like
focusing it seemed I don't know what the
movie's gonna be like but it seemed like
from the trailer they were focusing
on
um you know that specific aspect of the
book which is kind of like usually
glossed over most of the time I thought
that was like kind of a cool
I still got to see Renfield too because
that honestly looks like pretty cool
Louie said I've always let my
imagination room while it but happened
on that chip see that's what I mean
there's like a whole [__] story there
that nobody's really explored so I'm
glad that somebody's like actually doing
that now
Tammy says yes continue all right like I
said I'm having a good time
even though
you guys I've been up since
4 30 4 30 this morning I woke up
so whoops I kicked my printer but
how I'm still awake I have no idea but
you know what I mean so there are two
Dracula movies in the last year yeah but
they're focusing on different things
it's big enough lore you can
and look Christ Lord knows how many
[__] Dracula adaptations have been
made over the years
um Victor said Renfield was really good
funny and gory yeah I've been hearing
like some good [__] about it and like I
said I saw the trailer it looked
hilarious so
I definitely want to see that
I definitely want to see it maybe we
should actually go to the theater and
see it maybe we should go tomorrow
maybe I'll make Tom go tomorrow
on the way to koi actually it's not on
the way to koiwan but you know what I
mean
just odd two major movies so close
yes but
I don't know I kind of feel like movies
kind of sort of come out in
little groups of [__]
you know
like I kind of feel like back in the 90s
there was a whole little mini
Trend and disaster movies there was like
some volcano movies and like some
[__] earthquake movies and like a
whole bunch of them came out like in one
little time period
so I kind of feel like that happens a
lot it's not necessarily just
people copying one another I think it's
just kind of like whatever's in the
Zeitgeist you know
everybody's just kind of like hey let's
do some disaster movies and then they
all kind of come out at the same time
so I kind of feel like that's what
everybody's just like hey let's do
Dracula but a different angle on it and
a couple people had that idea at the
same time and that's just what happened
man ice maker wasn't making ice because
I forgot to put water in it
man you not only dumped all the ice out
of it but you also forgot it didn't show
the red light that the water was empty
I've noticed that it does not do that
every time it doesn't do it every time
that's why it was sitting there trying
to find this water honestly I just pour
water in it whenever I take ice out of
itches
just to be on the safe side
well hey Polk were you under the table
this whole time
yeah Victor says Armageddon Deep Impact
Dante's peacock volcano yeah that's what
I'm talking about that sounds like a
porn movie right there
Deep Impact deep impact
I don't know if I'd want to watch that
porn movie but okay
um
yeah
like I said that's what I was kind of
thinking of there was
a whole trend of
disaster well I kind of feel like the
bigger Trend was like in the 70s because
I feel like 70s were a big thing there
was like a whole Disaster Movie thing in
the 70s where it was like plane crashes
and earthquakes and avalanches and all
that kind of [__] and then you also had
a little sub trend of nature run amok
[__] it was usually like animals going
crazy and like killing people but not
always it was kind of like you know what
I mean like tarantula Orca you know
[__] Kingdom of the spiders
night night of the lepus with the giant
bunnies
um you know what I mean uh there was a
killer bee one the Swarm
so it was all like yeah
eco-terror Eco horn that's what they
called that so it was like a huge thing
in the 70s and I'm into those I like
they were all like campy as [__] yeah
but
I get it like I get like the cultural
Zeitgeist like where they were coming
from and a lot of them I liked him
because they had
sort of and I think I said this in one
of my reviews I hate to call them like
has beens because that's dismissive but
they were
past their Prime I guess like past their
Prime what's she doing she's all stretch
she's she's right behind my chair she's
not on her back but she's like on her
she's just all her legs are like all
stretched out like she thinks she's a
supermodel oh you short little fat
little thing you just stop calling her
fat don't touch my feet I'm touching
your man I'm gonna touch your feet don't
touch your feet you know she doesn't
like you touching her feet yeah she's
not looking to be touching her feet I'm
just touching feet she doesn't like
anybody touching her feet and yet you
keep doing it yeah yeah
okay
every time like look she knows you're
doing it like your hand gets close to
her feet and she's like don't touch him
don't touch my feet so stop doing it
okay y'all want to see the room again
if y'all want to see the room again I'll
I'll put the camera around because I was
showing some cool [__] that we have over
here
of our [__] future porn scene future
porn backdrop well at least showing my
cool curtains yeah yeah it looks like a
[__] set it looks like a
this is the thing that y'all have been
missing on this show this room looks
like something out of a funeral parlor
if you actually look at it well that's
kind of my whole list yeah it looks like
a funeral parlor in here
I don't just talk the talk man yeah I
love all this yeah like I said and you
can't like show it again if you all want
this is my favorite yeah this is my
happy place this room is my creepy
[__] creepy [__] that's my happy
satanic mirrors and big drapes with
[__]
like funeral I am playing funeral red
chip
yeah and actually those curtains
as rad as those curtains are
I got those on Amazon I think they were
eighteen dollars
per window really that's it yeah it's
because nobody was buying them
I don't know why because
they're awesome if I do say so myself
yeah
I'll turn the light on go show them
it says no means now see I keep saying
he keeps touching her feet I'm like will
you please stop touching her feet she
does not like her feet being touched
I don't touch her feet I don't touch her
belly because she doesn't like it
put the camera here let me show you let
me show you guys the room
see my ride curtains yeah yeah seriously
I think they were only 18 per window or
something like that it wasn't much more
than that I got them on Amazon
and then there's poop
there's poop she's like what are you
doing Dad she's looking right at the
camera and then pook's toys her little
toy pile yeah
and then there's the there's the
backdrop that you guys are looking at
there's my head
okay
there's Jenny's
desk that's my other computer yeah
and then there's the laptop we're
watching you guys on the camera sits
right behind it over there Inception
yeah
and then
back there that's the the little break
room and then
um the bathroom and then to the left of
the bathroom door you can't see it
because I'm on a wire is the dressing
room closet
and then there's the
love seat right there next behind Spock
with there's a package sitting there
it's not well that's what I have to send
um guy Reba yeah the HughesNet stuff
yeah
And Then There It Is
that's it so that's the room we're in
what do you say pook
what'd you say look at her face she's
like I don't know I'm like [__] this is
weird
stop calling your phone she's a little
little fat Pookie
put this one again Jenny doesn't want me
to Fat shave the cat
she knows what you're saying she thinks
that he yeah she knows what I'm saying
okay what'd you do with this camera dude
you like dropped it behind the I got a
table I got
oh [__] what the hell happened
how could that be
what the [__] is it doing
stopping it behind the door no no no
there's not enough oh look it's that
push push that leg back in there
like that's what it is
there it is now lock it
there you go that's all it was
now we got room
now we're all blurry it'll work it out
right out of my aim it Spock
shoulder there you go
that's it there we go yeah Jeff here I
said love those curtains yeah yeah it's
like a funeral I love these curtains too
yeah
like I said I'm just
I love all the creepy [__] in this room
oh my God room tour Tammy says Pookie
she next says damn y'all room is goals
you don't pay Pookie enough to be on
camera yeah she's like yeah I'm just I'm
out yeah yeah [__] all this [__]
oh poor pookie
yeah so the studio is the [__]
just that it doesn't show up all the
time on camera
well like I said because when I was
working at home
this was the room I spent
85 of my life in here go ahead and put
that in but give yourself some you're so
drunk you're not gonna be able to finish
the show
you look she took all of the [__] I
didn't take all of it like give me a
half of that [__] back look at that look
at that [__] look at that [__]
look at that [__] he's [__] greedy
man okay go ahead let's go
that's good let's see if we got any uh
ice
but yeah since I spent so much time in
here I was like you know what I'm just
gonna make this room
as much like I you know as much as I
could like the way I wanted it
you know
depending on how much money I had which
was not a lot
you know what I mean it's not making ice
there you go well next time put water in
it what you didn't put any water in it
okay
well it takes a while to make water
though
or make ISO
yeah but I do love this [__] room
though
because I got all but like I don't have
all my stuff up because there's not room
but
I sold a bunch of stuff rolled up in my
closet but
oh my good [__] is that
Tom is a regular Tarantino with his
[__] foot fetish
I don't really like feet that much well
you like Pookie's feet that's what yeah
that's what he's talking hilarious yeah
but see I always does funny [__] with
her feet I always tell him though it's
like she does not like her feet touched
so I will not touch her feet because I
respect your boundaries yeah Tom does
not respect your boundaries and she's
out here playing with me she'll just
touch her feet she's swatting at me
right now regardless of whether she
likes it or not
she does funny things with her back feet
I'll get it on camera you guys will wait
you guys will see
she also has a weird thing about her
belly but she will let you pet her belly
for about
three or four strokes since we can't
wait to see you all on November what are
we doing on November I don't know we
don't know what's happening on November
bro
I wish it was November maybe he's
talking about maybe he's talking about
[__] only fans
bite me
did she by chance yeah she always bites
they're Love Bites though she doesn't
bite hard
I don't think she's ever bit me no it's
all like uh
mouth love that's a good way to put it
yeah
he's trying to you know she likes to
wrestling
you know you know with your teeth with
Mom it's all kind of like she wants me
to brush her
she wants to like
head butt me
put her nose on my nose that kind of
[__]
Blair day dude says hey Jenny as a
Vincent Price fan you should check out
his radio career I have heard some of
that yeah he because I know he did a lot
of audio stuff like later on
but yeah I love [__] bits of rice
what if you're saying when's it Victor's
in there saying when's the sleepover
where's the sleepover how many of you
people want to come over
we don't have that much for him
when's the sleepover we're gonna have
people like we're gonna have people all
over this [__] like yeah
well we gotta start inventing people to
see well who can sleep over and who
can't
but yeah you know we can't just have
anybody over here but I'm saying we
don't know you all like that I mean you
did you you guys seem cool though a few
of you we can deal with
DJ Maniac I'll let him come over
we let sof come over
she's been overlapped at that yeah she's
been over Lots now
um
just gotta uh
the timing's got to be right you gotta
be cute enough
gotta be cute enough or you gotta be
yeah it's not important enough time I
like approach your butthole and like
yeah an inappropriate fashion I approach
you never know you might have to give it
up you don't know you never know what
happened because you know
he doesn't care about your consent
obviously well if you're coming to me
then no
[Laughter]
Victor says I got dibs on the foot of
the bed
yeah
[__] game aren't you gay Victor I
mean it's hard for me to keep everybody
straight I know I got a lot of gay fans
did we talk about the whole the whole
pegging situation what about the Vegas
issue
shitty just comes out of [__] nowhere
with a pegging situation what's been
Jenny's talking about
is uh somebody on one of the earlier
streams I think it was Zach maybe Zach I
think he said on Wednesday yeah we were
talking about doing camming these like
[__] how much how much would somebody
have to offer for Jenny to Peg Me
right and I said you know and I said in
the in the comments and I was like I'll
do it for free but
I said in the comments I said but it's
not up to me is it that crossed my mind
you know what I mean the [__] then
how much would you like like how much
would it take some [__] dude who's
cruel as [__]
says uh hell I'll give you I'll give you
[__] you know a thousand to [__]
have Jenny Paget and I'm thinking like
to myself how much would I actually
take to do this [__] and I'm thinking
well now I'm curious four grand for four
thousand I could get a motorcycle you
know what I mean or like
and I'm thinking and like I said it's
not like it and yeah like dude is Jenny
right like I said and you were saying
the sport it's like it's not like it's a
dude I don't know right yeah it would
just be me yeah so I was like it must be
like so I was actually trying to compute
how much like my price might actually be
well this is something that you think I
really got to I never really got to An
Answer yeah we did I never really well
this is something that you kind of start
thinking which I think is kind of good
because
this was like discussions we got into it
no this is like discussions we got into
when we first started talking about
doing this well how much money would
somebody have to offer for me to do XYZ
yeah you know what I mean because
there's some [__] that I probably would
not do like for any price you know what
I mean even if somebody gets hey I'll
give you a million dollar a million
dollars for it like there's some stuff
that I'd be like yeah no I'm not doing
that because
but you have to think like you know how
much would you know see because [__]
I was watching I was watching a video
made by another cam couple and [__]
the dude was like saying yeah
[__] I got pissed off a couple times
because I'm in there with her and this
dude comes in talking about what a [__]
I am and that you know how I don't
deserve her and that he's a millionaire
and here's 5 000 bam and if you call me
I'll [__] you know what I mean you
can come move in with me and all kinds
of [__] and the dudes try to steal his
woman
sending thousands of dollars at him
at them in the [__] chat although
jokes on them because nobody can steal
me because yeah well
alert I'm a person and I can actually
make my own decisions yeah she didn't
run off with him but I was just going
like you know and I was like damn
dad well I'm kind of thinking like if
some dumb [__] wants to like offer a
bunch of money and says hey I'm gonna
steal her for this much man I'm like
what should we take that and I'll just
like pretend right and then I'd be like
yeah man and some dude goes Tom you're a
[__] [__] man I [__] hate you
[__] I will give I will give
y'all [__] five thousand dollars
[__] Jen pegs you in the [__] ass
on this [__] live stream a gold show
It's gotta go on for [__] and then
[__] keeps adding the [__]
money up and he goes it'll come it'll
come and then I see it all the gold
comes I'm like oh [__]
now now Jen's got a [__] Peg man like
I said don't ask me because I'll do it
for nothing
so it's all on you
y'all don't know her man cheat I'm a
terrible person she has this weird
[__]
I don't know what it is it's not just
her though I'm not gonna say it's just
her because uh
throughout my life I [__] hooked up
with all these [__] women over the
time and they have this [__] pegging
fantasy
with dudes they do
I [__]
three or four of my exes [__] had
that
that drive in them to try to [__] Peg
some dude up in the booty thank you
Victor
he gave us the Super Chat and he says
stealing Jenny down payment
that's excellent
thank you sir that's hilarious that's
hilarious but uh yeah so I ain't talking
anymore no I'm serious like well this is
a consideration that you I mean you have
to think about this stuff kind of like
those dudes don't have the money
they don't have the money seriously
though some [__] said like hey I'll
give you five thousand dollars because I
feel like you be a [__] dumbass
you sit there and just [__] grin and
bear it and want your face in the
[__] camera while she's back there
just [__] hitting you with that big
old [__] [__] bad Dragon up in the
booty and you sitting there just looking
at the camera and you better [__]
call me daddy and [__] while I run to
[__] camp
because if I had that money and I was
mad at the guy on the camera
I would be cruel as [__] okay I'm like
right I'm gonna have your girlfriend
[__] pig in there and you're gonna
look at me here call me Daddy
if not you're not gonna get the other
half of the money but you don't have
five thousand dollars to give to
somebody else that's right but they have
some rich [__] but if they did
they got some rich [__] out
there that are like that that's five
thousand dollars yeah
that's a down payment on another car
yeah it is that's another car five
thousand you get a car five thousand no
problem I mean that's at least a down
payment on a news
I mean I'm not gonna make you I wouldn't
do that I'm like no but I will try very
hard to convince you
because like I said I'll do it you'll
try hard to convince I'll do it for free
but I'm just saying
I wouldn't do [__] without your consent
I would never do that I would never do
that the thing is though is is it
consent is it consent when you're
holding [__] it is because you could
say no
you don't have to take the money you
don't have to take the money we see you
got to be got to be realistic because
you've got to take this [__] to extremes
because of some dude says look man I'm
gonna give you [__] a million dollars
to do this and I'm like going well
wasn't that the whole million dollars
spam [__] that was the whole premise of
that that's a million [__] that's the
whole premise of that movie with Woody
Harrelson and Demi Moore that what the
[__] was that movie called where that
proposal yeah yeah yeah proposal where
he said I'll give you a million dollars
to [__] yourself wasn't that Robert
Redford
uh yeah yeah yeah that was the dude yeah
yeah yeah and I'm kind of thinking like
I kind of feel like every [__]
couple that went to see that
had that discussion and they were mad
yeah they're like oh yeah well here's
the thing yeah
I did that would never happen obviously
it might happen in certain circles sure
but I kind of feel like a bunch of
millionaires but I kind of feel like the
millionaires that are offering you money
are not gonna look like Robert Redford
no no and um
sure yeah and so yeah I kind of feel
like that's the more likely scenario
yeah so I kind of feel like if it'd be
easier on the man if he looked like
Jabba the Hutt
because you know that the woman isn't
going to enjoy it and she just being
enjoying it is she just gonna endure it
so in a way the movie is kind of like a
more is a more compelling scenario
because if the Dude Looks Like You know
Robert Redford
right like he's oh like he's also like a
good looking dude yeah he's older a
little bit but it's like he's still like
really good looking so it's kind of like
well I mean you know from a Norway
standpoint
but so it's kind of like
so I kind of feel like that kind of
spawned a lot of discussions I don't
really like think about it but because
I'm like I know the shit's never gonna
happen to me so whatever but
I don't know
I don't know I
look I need money too but it's like
I don't really want to do all that kind
of [__] read what they're saying what
American Military 100 says I think you
guys are stealing listeners away from
last podcast on the left right now why
is that really why is that you gotta
give it if that's true uh that's super
flattering because I I love lead last
podcast on the left and they were super
popular yeah what I don't know what
you're talking about uh authentic Jenny
smile upon her mental picture of Tom
calling someone Daddy yeah yeah cause
that's what I would do to a [__]
and I'm afraid somebody else will do
that to me because I'm evil you know
what I mean if I could have like some
other I guarantee you that as evil as
you are I am more evil than you I'm sure
I'm sure you know that [__] okay what
else is this you know that [__] is true
[Music]
this guy knew accused me of putting
pegging spam on his phone I was like
dude I did not touch your phone that I
was like it's probably responding to
your searches then he said now you know
see
Tammy says real question how much for
ball crushing oh oh now that's a good
listen to this show before yes that's a
good question yes this is Tammy yeah oh
no how much would someone have to pay no
no this is an interesting question no
how much would someone have to pay for
me to step on your balls see what
Tammy's talking about is on another show
we talked about we me and Jen were
watching a video where a dude was laying
on his back
and he was a pitiful [__] he's
way on his back
and he had his [__] dick and balls
sticking through a damn hole and yeah
they had a whole thing set up board
and this woman was taking her [__]
heel it's awesome
stiletto spike heels yes depression of
his [__] dick and then on his balls
on the ball and [__] then we're
kicking him and [__] and I was just like
oh man
he was laughing at me because I was just
I was laughing my [__] hair was I had
hair when I was watching it I didn't
have hair down and that made me laugh
even harder I had hair back and my hair
was standing that made me laugh even
harder like his reaction to it I'm like
oh my God this is like sick I was
laughing at some of it but then when she
started stepping on his nut I was like
oh no no oh hell no hell no
no indeed that [__] was gross man that
must have hurt like [__]
crazy I can't understand that but like
good okay but I'm not understanding it
is there
but is there a hypothetical amount of
money that someone could pay you
for me to just step on your mouth
like that girl was doing he doesn't even
want it no no no no no no no no I'm
checking out are you sure check it out
even for a million dollars
check it out
I couldn't imagine what that dude was
going through
I couldn't imagine
you can't imagine what that dude is
going through man
[Laughter]
no so funny my teeth hurt my teeth are
hurting thinking about it seeing that
[__] so funny that was worse than the
sounding video
the sounding video is kind of like it
was kind of hard but it was pain
uncomfortable at the same time sure
there was this video her name is
Penelope black diamond and she's this
German she's this German porn star who's
thin
she's cute goth check she's got these
huge [__] implants they're like the
size of beach balls I remember like
[__] He's giant you know
and her and her boyfriend make videos
together
she had her [__] boyfriend like that
and took this big old sounding rod and
just started sticking it down in his
urethra and [__] and [__] Jenny's
laughing and my [__] hair
I told you I used to sell sex toys on
Amazon and like sounding kits were not a
huge seller but I did get some sales on
that so some people are into it yeah
if you look up look up you go on any
[__] major site I enjoy watching Men
suffer Penelope black diamond
sounding and she's [__] big old long
toenails
painted black with like [__] Claws
and [__] big old long fingernails
she looks like a friend of ours
looks like [__]
what's his name's girlfriend
what's his name that's not really
narrowing it down for me
the old guy
which old guy
we know a lot I like this ex after after
he after they broke up uh
um
Mark oh right she looks like Laura
oh okay if you didn't notice that she
looks like Laura I did not but I don't
remember what she looks like Laura has
that same face in that same building but
if you put two big old beach balls on
the [__] front of Laura that's what
Penelope Black Diamond would look like
kind
but uh no man freaking
and in some videos so she's got [__]
pubes and [__] are a foot long
and [__] it's [__] hilarious man she
does [__] anything that's like really
extreme she's got huge [__] piercings
with big [__]
huge labia piercings with huge [__]
rings they're like [__] three inches
in diameter which I respect that even
more yeah now that I'm jealous
that piercing yeah because it's like I
know people get like [__] piercings and
stuff like that and I'm just kind of
like
I don't think they were that big a
beginning I think I think they get
bigger no yeah they kind of like work up
to it I get it thank you Victor just one
nut yeah just one
here's what's interesting to me look man
if y'all look
this is this is awesome this is The Vic
Vic
I kind of really want to know this [__]
when we open the streaming Channel and
[__] [__] come see us on there
[__] but I you know
I ain't getting pegged unless you got
thousands of dollars thousands although
I have to say and watch these [__]
[__] crowdsource that [__]
that's what I'm saying I'm looking
forward to that I'm just we don't want
to make I'm waiting for the day I'm
waiting oh man no I'm just saying that
you seem more
um
upset [__] [__]
you seem more upset by the idea of me
stepping on your balls yeah than you do
me pegging yeah much more much worse
okay that's good well no that's good to
know no watching that ball [__] it was
[__] when they were stepping on that
dude it did look really [__] Spike of
her heel stepping on one nut and it was
pressed up against that [__] board
what the [__] man and it looked like it
was [__] scrunching it and I was
going like oh no no well because I'm
kind of watching it like fascinating
like ooh is she gonna like break it yeah
look like yeah let's see
see when we we start this new Shadow we
call it Tom and Jen's house of pain
[__] just trying to pay me some
[__] to do something painful to me
imagine that
yeah no [__]
um yeah I wouldn't have done it again
knowing I wouldn't done it again and
like I said I tried to get him one back
because I'm like can I pierce your
nipples now and of course he's not gonna
let me do that no after I saw how it is
and what it feels like no no but I had
to go through it though well we had one
I had to go through it though we had to
do it and I went through one I did once
I realized how hard that was I didn't
want to do the other I did it I'm not
gonna lie I didn't want to do this stop
yeah I knew it sucks I didn't I had no
idea it would be that bad and honestly
well okay before we went into it because
I thought it was gonna be like a regular
needle well no I mean I'd always kind of
wanted that piercing yeah I had no idea
it was gonna be that right and
I knew it was gonna hurt I'm you know
I'm not dumb yeah but I was just kind of
like well it'll hurt but you know I have
a high pain tolerance you know that
um so I was like well it'll hurt but it
probably won't bother me all that much
but it was bad
yeah
um it was far worse than I imagined and
honestly the well the worst part about
it was not the pain which was bad the
pain was bad but I think the worst thing
was that when we did the first one yeah
I was sitting up yeah and
um you know I have really uh what do you
call I have really low uh blood pressure
so
I um so he was doing it nice and I was
like um I'm in a blackout yeah seriously
like the pain was too much and I was
just gonna I'm gonna black out and I
don't want to like
fall backward because I was sitting up
and so I was like um and I didn't really
expect that I didn't really expect to
feel that dizzy or like blackout or
anything like that and so that was
that was worse than the pain I think so
the second time uh we had it laid up
like when he did the second one like I
had it we had it laid up where it was
kind of like where I could lay down and
it still sucked then
especially because you kind of [__] it
up the first time and had to do it again
I do it twice yeah but it wasn't as bad
because I was already laying down and I
was like okay I'm not gonna black out
and like fall backward and like [__]
everything up so you know what I mean
the reason why the first one went bad is
because I had the needle and then behind
it you're supposed to have the piercing
itself and the sizes have to be the same
and I thought they were the same yeah
you have to like push them but they
weren't so you didn't want to push
through the other one now on
um YouTube there are uh real quick okay
there are piercing videos of the nipple
so it should be okay to show it
well I don't know though is it should be
okay because uh they have they have
videos of it happening so I'll show you
the work
um
they look good
and I had my friend who uh he was a
professional piercer
and they're done right
that's one
that's the other
okay
let me see
foreign
I think you guys are able to see it
I'm getting a bunch of messages
somebody named Aaliyah
messaged me hold on
remember Aaliyah
Aaliyah just sent me an ex-girlfriend
yeah yeah she's just I'm vibing out okay
I don't know what she's talking about
Okay Okay the reason why she's leaving
is because that wasn't that wasn't the
club she was at a concert with him oh
okay that's why she left early then it's
that early
so I was gonna say yeah because it's
awful they're an hour ahead right uh
maybe
Tammy says how was wearing a briar
t-shirt or shirt after
um
Okay so
I had like some anti biotic cream that
also had like painkiller in it
so I kept putting that on
um not gonna lie it kind of sucked
wearing a bra like the day after like a
day or two after and I sometimes under
certain shirts like when I would go to
work I would usually wear like a sports
bra
but I didn't do that for
probably like a week and a half just
because I didn't want it like squishing
it into you know squishing everything
together so I just wore like a normal
bra and it was usually okay you know
what I mean like it's every now and then
I'd be like kind of uncomfortable and I
had to like fix stuff but I mean you did
a good job like considering that
the first time uh my friend you had
never done it before yeah my friend Bill
who pierced for years says no that's a
good job yeah and honestly like other
than
like I said they're deep enough they're
not gonna lie it hurt like a
[__] yeah when he did it the
problem was look I've done I've put
needles through myself all the time
the problem is is that the nipple is
very tough material and it's kind of
elastic
and we're talking about large gauge
needles yeah they're through there very
big when he first showed them to me
because he bought the it's a whole
piercing kit it comes with like
everything you need and they have all
the get different gauge needles and he
showed me the news like this is the one
that they suggest for doing nipple
piercings and the first time I saw it I
was like
yeah basically it's big it's basically a
sharp stick it's big
and when it goes through if it were to
go through muscle like a leg like I
normally I inject myself every couple
days all right
um it would go in like butter it would
it would hurt but it would just go in
all right
the nipple is a very elastic tough
material it goes in it's it cracks and
it pops
and it stops like if hitting bone and
I'm like what the [__] I wasn't
expecting that it's a lot harder than I
thought it was
and it took it and it took I was taken
aback by it I was like God damn
and once it's through then you take the
bar and it's supposed to be about the
same diameter if not smaller diameter
and then push the needle through using
the bar and then then screw the bar end
in and then you got the then you got the
piercing
on that second time
I forced the needle through I was trying
to use the smallest needle as I could
and then I took the bar and tried to
force that needle back out through it
and the diameter of the needle was too
small the bar wouldn't follow it she's
going
oh [__] so I pulled that needle out I
said I gotta do it again what I should
have done is taken the bigger needle and
pushed the small needle out and then put
the [__] bar through but she was
protesting so much and I was worried
about her so much that I kind of wasn't
thinking clearly
the small needle I should have just used
a bigger needle to push it out which
would have expanded the hole and then
taking the the bar and put that through
and it'd have been all right so I
actually put her because I was worried
about her actually put her through some
extra pain
but I tell you what
as a man
Infantry
done a lot of [__] up [__] over the
years
as a contractor and all kinds of stuff
she went through a [__] rite of
passage that was [__] tough
but I got him in there and they're
straight and they're deep they they're
it's a pro job they look really good
yeah I really like them they're fun
they're they're a lot of fun they look
good in her and they
I like them I'm glad I did it there's
like they're very sexy I don't know if
knowing what I know now if I would do
them again no as soon as that when I got
done with that first one I was going
like I would never have this done this
material is too [__] tough going
through a nipple is tough so like
talking respect for anybody that has
that [__] because holy [__] I didn't
realize well like I said I have high
pain tolerance so I just thought it was
gonna be and like I said it wasn't so
much the pain I mean it hurt
but
I can deal with that it was just that my
blood pressure dropped so severely when
I was sitting up and I was just like I
was afraid I was like I'm blacking out
I'm blacking out like I kept telling him
like I'm blacking out I'm gonna fall
backwards yeah yeah and like I didn't
want [__] to like tear or whatever is
that cracking it's probably tearing oh
yeah definitely but it's a needle
but the needle is Big it's big it's big
to get that I was alarmed I didn't tell
you but when you showed me the needle
that was going through there I was like
oh no do I really want to do this or not
yeah it was like a 14 and I was like
nope I'm gonna suck it up I think it was
a 12 gauge or 14 gauge needle it's
[__] big
it's very yeah it's large it's very
large and
and I I thought it would just go through
I could send that through meat I could
send that through my leg no problem it
would hurt but I could do it
gone through and gone through a nipple
man it's [__] tough
it's a tough elastic it's a very well I
would told them I was like it's not so
much the weird thing about it is that
it's not so much pain because like I but
it's a very
that's a very sensitive area
so when you're going through there I'm
just kind of like is that nipple still
on there or right you know what I mean
this is a good a good felt like you were
like tearing it off yeah it felt like Mr
88 is going it's a good thing it's a
good sign that Tom was emotionally
impacted yeah I was I was but I had to
stay cool
I couldn't I could tell that he was I
mean yeah I was just kind of like he did
one and I was kind of like yeah that's
cool and I was like do I really want to
do this I was like I do because I want
to even it out but it's like I really
don't because that really was more
[__] up than I imagined
um but I said maybe it'll be easier the
second time because you know we've
already done it once I know what to
expect
and stuff like that and then the second
time was easier but then he
kind of messed it up a little bit easier
because it was a smaller needle right
because I said I'm gonna use the smaller
needle right and that bar will should
follow it it doesn't it didn't though so
I said oh [__] because it's not huge
like the bar but you need to have like
the same the bar has to have the same uh
diameter yeah as the needle or a more
experienced it's about
yeah that big a more experienced piercer
probably would have been a lot faster
than me so it would have been over a lot
faster because I didn't really quite
have the confidence you can feel the
needle going through and I'm grabbing
the nipple to make sure everything lines
up because you got one hole where you go
in and another hole where you have to
come out I had it all pre-marked yeah
there's a tool you it comes with a tool
that you pull the nipple out and it like
keeps it it's got like little markers on
it but I marked it in purple with a
purple flash marker for doing surgery
and stuff to make sure everything was
straight because you don't want them
crooked they got to be straight
and had to be in deep enough to wear the
little balls on the end of the bar
[__] press up against the areola you
don't want them hey you don't want to be
like hanging out yeah you got to be
pressed up against so everything's all
flush and it looks it does it looks cute
yeah you did a good job you did a good
job yeah I mean it did come out it looks
really good I think it looks really good
now when I'll unscrew those bars they're
ready now I'll unscrew the bars pull
them out and I'll slip and slip a ring
through there yeah we have other yeah
you know other we have rings and all
kind of other stuff we can put I want a
ring with a single cap but I'm just
waiting for it to heal yeah I want a
ring with a single captured ball at the
bottom so it's a ring with a little ball
at the bottom
but the thing is you need a special tool
to close that once they're in they're in
it takes uh pliers to get them back
apart it's a permanent thing but people
take them apart just take a plop with a
plier but you need a special tool to
where when you're closing it to capture
the ball
you want to close it make sure that the
ring is round you don't want it to be
oval so there's a little hand tool you
need to close it to make sure it's round
and then she'll have perfect little
slave girl nipples
[Laughter]
yeah the bars are cute yeah I do like
the bars
like I said
um for the first couple days it was you
know because Tammy asked it was
admittedly hard to wear a bra
um when he first did it like the first
day or two I didn't wear a bra I just
like wore like a regular shirt because
it hurt too much but
um
like a day
two days after he did it like because he
did it on Saturday so Monday I wore a
bra I had um
the cream that had painkiller in it and
uh you know that was antibiotic yeah and
I put that on there and then I just put
a regular bra just very very gently and
it kind of hurt like sometimes during
the day but it wasn't bad like I forgot
about it most of the time so it was fine
it was fine yeah
um yeah Tammy says Jenny has all my
admiration and respect I didn't thank
you but I honestly didn't
he yeah it's almost one
is it yeah okay been on forever he told
me afterward he was like oh you were
very brave I was like well I didn't
really expect it because I didn't think
it was gonna be that bad she was very
brave to be honest yeah she was very
brave it sucked I didn't expect it to
suck that much neither did I because
like I said I you know I've been through
a lot of painful experiences and it
wasn't really that big of a deal
um this was
you said it was six out of ten not the
most painful thing I've ever experienced
um but it was up there it was up there
it was she was very brave it was like
something out of a [__] in like a
native I did cry a little bit but that
was mostly frustration I think more I
think I was frustrated well I I only
cried because I thought you were done I
had to do it the second time and then
you were like oh it's done oh wait I
[__] it up I have to do whatever and I
was like seriously no I was like please
don't put me through this [__] [__]
again it's very much then I got
frustrated and I started crying it was
very much a kind of a Native American
style rite of passage like something you
see but other than that I thought I was
worse other than that I thought I was
pretty badass yeah yeah
considering like I said I kind of feel
like if I did it to you no I'm not
really yeah see you don't even want to
do it once I saw what no after us after
I put that first one through there and
realized [__] how tough that material
was I was like no
hell no
if if you were to
have a time machine and show me how
tough that was to go through I'd have
gone back in time and said you wouldn't
have done don't do it yeah but once one
was done we had you had to do the other
one well that's what I mean it's like
once one was I really really did not
want to do the second one but then I was
thinking well one I don't want to be an
even and two I was like well we've done
one so I know what to expect now so it
won't be that big of a deal so and the
second one was easier I will admit that
but I think it was because we knew well
we can't have me sitting up because I'll
pass out because I almost did pass out
the first time
um you know because I've you know I have
super low uh blood pressure so you know
if I'm sitting up and something
upsetting happens or I don't eat or
something like that I will pass out so I
have to like lay down so I was laying
down the second time so that was better
but he also did kind of like use the
smaller needle accidentally the second
time yeah and he had so we had to do it
well I knew it was smaller so yeah I
knew it was smaller but I thought the
smaller one would work because I was
holding the two pieces up and I was
going there's not a big difference in
the [__] diameters there that should
go through but then once I took the bar
and tried to push the old the the little
needle out you went ah that would I
guess it won't go
yeah so like what the [__] are you doing
it seriously telling it felt like you
were tearing my nipple off so what I
should have done is I should have taken
the bigger needle and put it behind the
small needle and pushed that out it
would expand it out a little bit and
take in the bar and push the needle out
yeah and that would have worked but I
wasn't it panicked me I didn't really
have the experience you know what I mean
so I said I got to do it again
I'm gonna grab the needle from the other
side and pulled it out of your nipples
but see well I mean that just goes to
show too that I'm watching stuff on
YouTube is not the same as actually
doing it really no no well it's the
first time you're doing it right had I
had an experienced person with me
they would have been faster and they
wouldn't have used that smaller needle
they would use the the big needle the
one that worked probably well it's
better to just get it over with right
and just get it in one go because like I
said I think that the reason because the
first time like okay the first time
sucked and I almost passed out and stuff
like that but then like when you did it
the second time
um you know when you did the second one
I was kind of like oh that was easy like
it hurt but it wasn't terrible but what
go ahead
Tom's resume military t-shirt Artisan
nipple piercer porn star we'd love to
welcome you to your motorcycle stunt man
spokesman for this Southern Baptist
convention
motorcycle stunt man that too [__] uh
uh [__] mercenary [__] everything
no everything uh yeah you've done all
that [__] yeah but yeah what I was
saying was that the second time when you
did the second one because I was
dreading it he did the first one it
sucked I almost passed out and I was
like look I have to pass out or throw up
or something and you know then we
finished and I was just like can I
please have a break uh so we just like
sat down and watched a movie or whatever
and then like the whole time I was like
dreading I was like oh my God we had
just the second one it's really I had to
like build myself up to it so it's like
we finally did that and we had like I
laid down the second time because I said
I want to pass out if or if I do pass
out I don't want there to be like a
whole issue
so we have me laying down we had a whole
thing worked out and the second time
he did it and I was like oh it hurt a
little bit but it's like oh that he's
like oh it's done and I was like oh that
was nothing that was like no big deal
like compared to the first one yeah but
then he's like oh wait I [__] it up no
it was a little needle it was a little I
tried to push the bar through there and
then you had to do it again and then at
that point I just started crying and I
was like please
please don't make me because I put the
bigger needle in behind it it would have
it would have right but you did but I
picked I didn't think about it right and
uh so I was just kind of I think that
was why I started crying because I was
just like so frustrated because I
thought you were done and I thought it
was all I had to do is just take the
bigger needle and push the small needle
out through it right and then I would
have been it would have been all right
because everything was lubed too that's
nothing you guys understand I'm not just
shoving a needle through there
everything well you did the first thing
you didn't live the first time yeah I
didn't do the first of the second time
it was lubed
I lubed it with a bunch of [__]
hypoallergenic [__] lube for used for
[__] uh what's that machine
ultrasound machine yeah
you could use that and it it went
through a lot easier
okay
um how long we've been streaming we've
been on forever man and we're running
out five hours five hours oh [__] what's
the guys who are watching too all right
all right we're gonna come off for this
oh my God it's almost one in the morning
yeah yeah so it's chilling well like I
said we're not they're making fun of us
we've been on here so long
it's like a [__] marathon five hours
five hours that's is it been five hours
actually more than five it's five hours
and 20 and 21 minutes how the hell did
that happen
well you know I thought it was two hours
just a few minutes ago
that's what happens when you drink yeah
okay we gotta get off here
yeah well that's yeah well that's right
it's so long everybody's gonna listen to
this show but like you said more people
coming on like is this your longest I
don't think this is our longest show
we're one of the longest we've done a
couple shows that were like six hours
yeah this is ridiculous but usually
they're like two parts because sometimes
like our stream would cut off and we'd
have to like do a part two so we've done
like a couple that were like six hours
but yeah
is among the longest though
yeah among the longest
it didn't seem like it though I was
having a good time like I said yeah
we're not going any place that's true so
we just spent the [__] yourself
Mr 88 said the longest I recall was 457.
no we've for real duns and there were
like more than six hours but they were
probably like in two parts
because some we had problems like with
the stream and sometimes the stream
would cut off
what are you doing I'm making a video of
us hi how you doing and then we're
streaming live it's for Alia for Alia
because she's she's uh she's messaging
us
we're live streaming what's up say hi to
everybody
how are you doing
gold stars for both of you I mean for
real considering I've been up since 4 30
this morning I think I'm doing pretty
good
the fact that I'm still awake is just
that's a miracle at this stage
I feel like I'm probably gonna sleep
till [__] what what I say it I'm
gonna sleep till like one in the
afternoon tomorrow but I'm sure I won't
I'll probably wake up at [__] 7 A.M
just like usual
as soon as the sun comes up
yeah my eyes are gonna open and be like
well I'm fake let's go do some [__]
Victor says the classic show
this is a classic show is it how could
it be classic it's brand new
Classics it's an instant classic shut up
don't hate
Ben says uh YouTube DIY dentistry and
cosmetic surgery videos aren't reliable
I'm pretty sure I could do cosmetic
surgery I mean if I had all the
equipment
I could do well I don't know because I
have to have the training you felt super
confident about the nipple piercing and
look how that went no it went great no
it did but I'm just saying that there
are a lot of unforeseen con you know
there are a lot of unforeseen well you
have to have that you have to have
hands-on experience right that's what
I'm saying so it's like just watching
[__] on a video it was a lot different
than doing it yeah but there's always a
first time too sure all right had you
had you been unconscious it would have
been a lot easier
because uh
I feel like that's the case in a lot of
situations yeah you know had you been
unconscious yeah this way because she's
trying to save you from a bunch of pain
too I was like uh
but had I been chilled on I just
wouldn't I would have did I'll use a
little one to be honest yeah
like as as sucky as it was for me
because it did suck a lot
I kind of feel like afterward I was kind
of like I kind of feel like maybe
maybe it sucked for Tom more I was
[__] upset about it I was later on I
don't think it did because it seriously
it really hurt and until like later on
that if I could do it to you
and you could see what it was like later
on later on that night I was like what
it was a big one yeah but I did too
I did too and I feel like I had a better
like grasp on it because I actually like
experienced it so I woke up later and I
was like oh my God my nipples are being
torn off you know what I mean so it was
like that kind of situation go ahead and
shut the [__] show down General yeah
[Laughter]
uh Victor says probably the longest
since movie Friday yeah I feel like
we've been selling like I said it didn't
seem like that long but you know
telling her previous to hands-on
experience I mean he did but not
punching holes in it you know uh Tammy
says great time tonight good night all
yeah uh okay so I'm glad you guys had
such a good time I had such a good time
I didn't like realize it was like five
and a half hours but you know what I
would have we're not going anywhere so
it's okay we're just getting drunk and
hanging out with you guys so um we'll be
back Sunday I'm not really sure what
movie we'll be talking about
we haven't really planned one might be
Breakfast Club might be House of Wax
like Danny rolling suggested we'll get
into that in a little bit uh whatever it
is that we watch over the weekend we
will talk about it on Sunday but
hopefully we see you guys again on
Sunday evening at
six o'clock yeah six o'clock
uh so you're all right yeah all right so
thanks for hanging out with us this
Friday evening have a good Saturday you
guys and we will see you guys again on
Sunday evening good night